Das sind Anne-Sophie Mutter.
Ja.
Das ist das Einzige, was ich weiß.
Und Hilary Hahn und Isabel Faust.
Ich bin froh, dass du nicht André Rieu gesagt hast. Aber er ist ja auch ein Mann.
Ich habe ihn auch dieses Jahr nicht erlebt, außer im Kino im Sommer.
Aber ich habe diese drei Geigerinnen nun oft gehört, auf Aufnahmen habe,
viele CDs von ihnen und habe sie aber nie live erlebt.
Und diesmal hat es tatsächlich geklappt, also nicht alle drei zusammen,
sondern nacheinander und es war dreimal beeindruckend auf unterschiedliche Weise,
also jede der Geigerinnen hat ja ihren ganz eigenen Stil und diese Brillanz
zu erleben, diese enorme Leidenschaft, Musikalität war für mich das Tollste.
Ich habe viele schöne Konzerte und viele Opern gesehen, aber das war jetzt so
ein lange gehegter Wunsch, der dann wahr wurde, diese drei mal zu erleben.
Und es ist ja doch so, wenn man über das Jahr nachdenkt, dann sind es ja meistens
Erlebnisse, die hängen bleiben. Oder?
Ja, die Produkte bleiben ja auch im nächsten Jahr. Die klammern ja man nicht an ein Jahr fest.
Das stimmt.
Ich war auch dieser Tage das erste Mal alleine in der Oper.
Ach, allein, weil sie mir so gut gefallen hat. Nein, wirklich nochmal.
Es gab noch erste Reiheplätze für Marta, also bin ich nochmal reingegangen.
Ja, also wir müssen was dazu sagen. Friedrich von Flothoff hat diese Oper komponiert.
Und nun ja, was soll man dazu sagen? Es ist eigentlich eine sehr biedermeierliche
Oper, die auch nicht mehr so häufig gegeben wird.
Und bekannt ist eigentlich nur diese eine berühmte Arie. Letzte Rose.
Pause, da, di, da, da, da.
Und der Rest, naja, wir waren gemeinsam da drin und ich dachte so nach einer
halben Stunde, oh, oh, ob das Stefan gefallen wird. Und dann warst du in der
Pause völlig begeistert.
Wolfgang hatte Angst, dass es mir zu kitschig ist. Wobei ich doch,
wenn aufgeschlossen, dann vor allem für den Kitsch.
Die geben sich ja redlich Mühe in Frankfurt, das zu modernisieren und so kann
man da vielleicht sich dem nähern, aber ich habe nicht so recht verstanden,
ob wir diese Oper noch wirklich auf dem Spielplan brauchen,
aber es gibt offenbar junge Fans, also ich sage mal so, die Oper Martha,
das hat man ja auch so gemerkt, es gibt ein sehr altes Publikum,
das noch dafür empfänglich ist, das auch noch kennt aus entsprechenden Shows,
wo diese berühmten Sängerin mit Peter Alexander da rumgelaufen sind.
Und die haben noch diese Erinnerungen an diese Oper.
Und wir wurden ja auch darauf hingewiesen, weil wir Donnerstags uns Martha angesehen
haben. Und ich sagte diesen Satz, Donnerstag ist Martha.
Donnerstag ist Martha. Und dann wurde uns ja gesagt, das ist ein Loriot-Sketch.
Und tatsächlich, den gibt es an der Opernkasse.
Ah, das siehst du.
Ja, kann man sich ansehen. Naja, du warst begeistert davon. Ich bin ein bisschen
überrascht. Denn wir haben schon interessantere Opern erlebt.
Das stimmt. Und beim zweiten Mal war es auch noch insbesondere ein Erlebnis.
Du kennst ja bestimmt die Situation, wenn irgendwelche älteren Herren oben nochmal
reinrufen, das ist Oper live. Also was ist passiert?
Der eine Sänger war ein bisschen erkrankt, konnte nicht singen, aber spielen.
Ah ja.
Weshalb man ein, ich glaube es war die hohe Stimme Tenors, die höhere,
aus Wien einflog, der am Bühnenrand stand.
Aber sich sichtlich unwohl fühlte, sich dann für die Pause entschuldigen ließ
mit Ich bin jetzt auch krank.
Woraufhin der Ursprüngliche aus
dem Ensemble meinte, ich habe mich warm gesungen, ich schaffe es jetzt.
Was dann bedeutet, ist ja eh schon Szenenapplaus, komische Oper,
es wird extra Zeit gelassen.
Wenn der Typ dann nach der Pause sein erstes Lied singt und alle wissen,
er kämpft sich hier gerade durch, ist natürlich die Hölle los.
Toll. Ja.
Also es war ein tolles Jahresendeerlebnis. Die Leute sind ausgerastet und ich auch.
Ja, für mich gibt es heute Abend noch AIDA.
Oh ja, sehr gut.
Und dann schauen wir mal weiter. Ja, das waren die Highlights,
aber wir machen ja jetzt nicht einen fröhlichen Podcast zum Jahresende,
sondern die Themen sind ja sehr ernst.
Zum einen, wir freuen uns natürlich alle, die in Frankfurt dabei waren.
Ich hoffe, man hat mir nicht angemerkt, dass ich schon wieder ein bisschen angepisst
war von dieser Technik, die einfach immer nicht so richtig funktioniert.
Für nächstes Jahr haben wir aber einen Plan.
Wir kaufen ein neues Gerät, das macht einfach die Aufnahme, danach schicken
wir das an Joscha, der macht uns das hübsch.
Also wir quälen uns nicht mal mit zwei Mikrofonen in der Case und so weiter,
für alle, die das vor Ort gesehen haben. und außerdem ist mir vorhin aufgefallen,
wenn man am zweiten Weihnachtsfeiertag morgens seine Podcast-App aufmacht, gähnende Leere.
Ja.
Ist nichts da. In der Hinsicht, wenn ihr Fans von diesem Podcast seid und es
ist jetzt gerade der erste Nachweihnachtstag und ihr macht morgens den Podcast
auf und freut euch darüber, dass die 29er da sind, teilt das doch der Welt mit.
Sehr viele Leute wissen gerade nicht, was soll ich denn jetzt hören vier Tage
lang oder zwei Wochen, bis das neue Jahr beginnt und damit die Podcast-Welt.
Deswegen, wenn ihr das hier hört, jetzt den Podcast teilen in euren gehend leeren
Social Media. Niemand hat Content gerade.
Teilt euren Lieblings-Content.
Ja, oder per WhatsApp, was wir herausgefunden haben.
Ich hatte es schon im Live-Salon gesagt, dass über WhatsApp am häufigsten unser Podcast geteilt wurde.
Und dann kommen erst Instagram oder Facebook.
Das würde uns sehr freuen. Und uns freut es auch, wenn ihr den Salon abonniert,
um den Podcast zu unterstützen.
Das könnt ihr über mehrere Wege tun. Wir empfehlen, das mit Steady zu machen.
Dort habt ihr das gesamte Archiv. All die Jahre sind dann euch zugänglich.
Ab 2,50 Euro im Monat kann man ihn buchen und hat dann immer noch drei Stunden,
dreieinhalb Stunden extra pro Monat.
Plus die Salons, also der neue Live-Salon, der vor wenigen Tagen aufgezeichnet
wurde, der ist dort auch zu finden.
Und ihr könnt, wenn ihr jetzt noch ein Weihnachtsgeschenk braucht oder generell
was verschenken wollt, diesen Podcast auch noch verschenken.
Ihr findet den Podcast aber auch über Apple, dort ist er zu buchen, über Patreon.
Und wenn ihr bei Spotify diesen Podcast hört, dann könnt ihr auch von dort direkt
auf einen Button klicken und kommt zu Steady, also alles ist da möglich und
ja, es hilft uns sehr, wenn ihr den Podcast teilt und gut bewertet.
Denn es ist doch ein Kampf gegen die Algorithmen, den man so führt.
Es ist ganz erstaunlich, also wir werden heute noch über YouTube und Twitch
sprechen und dann habe ich auch nochmal so ganz eigene YouTube-Erfahrungen gemacht,
Wenn man da was sucht und es nicht mehr findet und all das.
Und das ist schon sehr erstaunlich. Ich hatte mit einem Hörer ein längeres Gespräch
dann nach der Live-Show, der sagt,
also er hat sich jetzt hingesetzt und mal ganz entschieden deabonniert und abonniert,
was er wirklich hören will.
Und gar nicht mehr auf die Empfehlungsseite blickt er, sondern er geht direkt
zu den Abos, die er hat und schaut sich das dort an.
Also er muss es so ganz bewusst machen, damit er dann noch tatsächlich die Inhalte
bekommt, die er sehen will.
Und bei mir ist jetzt der Browser natürlich völlig vernichtet,
dadurch, dass ich im Twitch-Beef recherchiert habe.
Da brauchst du den Porno-Modus der Browser, die haben ja immer ein Inkognito-Dings,
der sofort die die ganze Historie, sobald man den Browser schließt, wieder löscht.
Dadurch verfängt sich da nichts.
Und was muss ich da machen, denn ich habe jetzt nur noch KuchenTV und so weiter
dort angezeigt. Das ist nicht schön.
Ja.
Ja, wir wollen aber auch nochmal ganz kurz über die Schuldenbremse sprechen,
denn diese Schuldenbremse ist ja zum einen etwas, was in Berlin stattfindet,
in Karlsruhe entschieden wurde,
dann geht das durch die Talkshows, aber wir wissen ja, die Kommunen sind stark
überschuldet und vielleicht haben manche diese Meldung mitbekommen.
Das ist jetzt SWR aktuell und das ist eine Meldung, die ist zwei Wochen etwa alt.
In Bosenbach im Kreis Kusel sind Bürgermeister und Gemeinderat geschlossen zurückgetreten.
Der Schritt sei eine Reaktion auf die Umsetzung des Landesfinanzausgleichs, hieß es.
Dieser fordere einen ausgeglichenen Haushalt.
Dafür müsse die Grundsteuer drastisch erhöht werden. Das wolle man keinem zumuten.
Der Schritt erinnert an den pfälzischen Ort Freisbach.
Hier waren aus dem gleichen Grund Gemeinderat und Bürgermeister zurückgetreten.
Bosenbach hat kein Geld für das, was sie eigentlich machen wollen.
Und jetzt sagt die Moderatorin, es erinnert an Freisbach. Und man denkt so,
Freisbach, Freisbach, was war denn da?
Ja, im August war da etwas in Freisbach.
Und zwar ist dort auch die Gemeindespitze zurückgetreten, hat gesagt,
wir wollen eigentlich hier etwas bewirken, haben aber gar nicht die finanziellen Mittel dazu.
Und man findet jetzt zu diesem Fall Bosenbach gar nicht viel.
Es ist auch, wenn man SWR aktuell dann die Sendung sich anschaut,
da kommt erstmal eine Meldung, noch eine Meldung und dann kommt mal kurz das,
also das war es dann schon dazu,
dann findet man bei SWR.de ein bisschen mehr dazu oder auch mal eine DPA-Meldung,
denn es bleiben jetzt einige doch in der Gemeindespitze für noch ein paar Wochen.
Um Fördergelder, die sie bekommen für einen Gemeindebau, noch mitzunehmen,
weil die in diesem Jahr ausgegeben werden müssen. Also so wird jetzt da irgendwie geschaut.
Es sind also keine Machtspiele jetzt hier. Was wir ja in Berlin beobachten,
sind ja politische Machtspiele.
Und das sind jetzt keine Machtspiele, sondern hier überlegt man,
gut, wir können nicht unverantwortlich sein und einfach rausgehen.
Wenn hier doch noch ein paar Hunderttausend über einen Fördertopf kommen,
der nichts mit dem Land zu tun hat, Und dann müssen wir den auch noch gut verwalten,
damit wir nicht der Gemeinde noch was zumuten.
Also es ist eigentlich ein sehr, sehr verantwortungsvoller Umgang.
Naja, aber es findet eigentlich nicht groß statt.
Und ich weiß nicht, ob du den Bericht gehört hattest im Deutschlandfunk von
Nils Schniederjahn über die Schuldenbremse, wie sie eingeführt wurde 2009.
Ich wollte die fünf Minuten gestern Abend noch hören, da bin ich drüber eingeschlafen.
Ich habe deine Empfehlung gesehen, werde es noch nachholen.
Ja, unbedingt mal anhören, denn es war so erstaunlich, dass 2009 die Schuldenbremse
eingeführt wurde und der Tagesschau kommt erstmal als Meldung irgendwas mit
den Opel-Werken, müssen sie schließen oder nicht, dann kommt noch was und dann
kommt was zur Schuldenbremse.
In der Zeit wohl gar nichts dazu damals, Süddeutsche so ein Artikel,
naja wird dieser Papiertiger dann helfen und dann war es eigentlich nur Sebastian
Dullien, der schon damals gewarnt hat, da kettet ihr euch an, macht das nicht.
Also sollte man diese fünf Minuten mal hören und da sieht man so,
also so eine fundamentale Entscheidung, die jetzt das ganze Land lähmt,
inklusive der Gemeinderäte und so weiter,
wurde einfach so übergangen, weil dann gerade diskutiert werden musste,
wird das Opel-Werk geschlossen und dann kommen die Politiker hervor und nicht
mit mir, man weiß ja wie das dann läuft.
Und das ist jetzt auch wieder so ein Fall, wir haben jetzt hier so ein Gemeinderat,
aber wer weiß schon wo Bosenbach ist und wo Freisbach ist,
weiß eigentlich auch keiner in Rheinland-Pfalz und ich habe dann mal nachgeschaut,
da gab es ein SWR-Interview mit dem Bürgermeister Peter Gauweiler,
der nix mit dem SCSU Peter Gauweiler zu tun hat.
Du meinst mit dem reichsten Bundestagsgeabt in aller Zeiten, der sich die…,
die Anwaltsschar zusammensuchte, um das Bundesverfassungsgericht zu missbrauchen
und Deutschland aus der EU und der Verschuldungsregel und so weiter rauszuklagen.
Und wir haben das ja im Mai 2020 alles geschaut, das Drama.
Ganz richtig. Mit diesem Mann hat dieser Peter Gauweiler nichts zu tun.
Er ist also dieser zurückgetretene Bürgermeister aus Freisbach,
wird im August interviewt.
Hat sich denn der rheinland-pfälzische Innenminister auch bei Ihnen gemeldet?
Noch nicht. Wahrscheinlich, weil ich nicht beim Amt bin.
Wir hatten zwar informell mal Besuch von einem Landtagsabgeordneten,
der die Halle angeschaut hat.
Ansonsten keine Rückmeldung, außer entsprechende Interviews dann vom Minister
in Presse oder auch in Rundfunk.
Genau, und in solchen Interviews hat der Minister zum Beispiel gesagt,
Brocken hinwerfen löst auch keine Probleme.
Was antworten Sie ihm, wenn er Ihnen das direkt ins Gesicht sagen würde?
Also ich würde sagen, dass ich mich geärgert habe.
Ist nicht meine Art, ein Amt, das ich über 20 Jahre lang ausgeübt habe,
mit vollem Herzen einfach hinzuschmeißen oder wie er sagt, aus der Verantwortung zu stehlen.
So, hier verstecken sich so viele Pointen. Der rheinland-pfälzische Innenminister.
Also Rheinland-Pfalz hat eine Hauptstadt, du kennst sie, Mainz.
So, wer hat in Mainz regiert, als Biontech dort Milliarden für die Stadt einfuhr,
weshalb man in Mainz sagte, wir machen mal den niedrigsten Gewerbesteuersatz,
Hebesatz in Deutschland,
damit wir da konkurrenzfähig und so weiter.
Welcher Bürgermeister war das? Welches Amt könnte der heute,
ah, es ist heute der Rheinland-Pfälzische Innenminister, der hier für die Kommunen zuständig ist. ist.
Also wir haben in, ich kenne gerade seinen Namen nicht, Lutz oder irgendwie so heißt er.
In einer Person haben wir die Erfahrung von.
Ich habe alle Gelder bei mir, ich kann alles machen, ich bin die reichste Kommune
der Welt, weil bei mir wurde der Biontech-Dings hergestellt.
Was mache ich? Ich senke Steuern, nutze mein Handlungsvermögen nicht,
sondern er arbeite mir einfach einen Standortvorteil.
Der Typ wird dann Landesinnenminister und ist jetzt für diese Kommunen zuständig.
Die reihenweise sagen, bei uns mangelt es eigentlich nicht am politischen Engagement.
Wenn wir sagen, wir machen unsere letzte Gemeinderatssitzung,
kommt sogar das ganze Dorf, also kommen einfach alle zusammen,
die sieben beschließen das nicht alleine, sondern die machen dann nochmal eine
große Feierstunde und so und sagen, es hat keinen Sinn.
Die eine Kita, die wir betreiben, verbraucht mehr Budget, als wir insgesamt für alles haben.
Dann kann auch gleich das Land kommen und sagen, hier, das ist euer Haushaltsplan.
Ihr dürft darüber hinaus nichts machen. Also es lohnt sich gar nicht,
da politisch tätig zu sein.
Und damit ist die lokale Politik, das fast im römischen Sinne die Polis,
die Gemeindeangelegenheit einfach Einfach erledigt.
Einfach historisch aussortiert. Und das sind Verstrickungen von Biontech über
diesen Mainzer Bürgermeister, der dann Innenminister wird und sich überhaupt
nicht dafür interessiert, dass sich sein ganzes Land politisch ausschaltet.
Das ist einfach ein Drama.
Und es ist volkswirtschaftlicher Wahnsinn, denn es handelt sich hier um eine
Kita, die der große Streitpunkt war.
Und es gibt ganz viele Meldungen, wenn man mal nachschaut, wo Gemeinden Probleme
damit haben, den Anforderungen der Länder zu entsprechen beim Kita-Bau.
Es ist nicht genug, ist sein Name. Also wenn ihr einer Sache nochmal politisch
nachgehen wollt, das ist das Schicksal von Michael Ebling,
der sowohl während Biontech die ganze Welt rettet, Bürgermeister von Mainz ist
und dann als Innenminister das verantwortet, was wir hier hören.
Und wir hören mal, was da los ist mit den Kitas.
Sie waren, Sie haben es selber gesagt, lange Jahre Ortsbürgermeister von Freisbach.
Machen Sie sich denn in einem gewissen Punkt Vorwürfe, dass die Gemeinde seit
Jahren mehr Geld ausgibt, als sie einnimmt?
Nein, also wenn man sich den Haushalt richtig anschaut und da kann ich nicht
vergleichen mit kreisfreien Städten oder mit Landkreisen.
Wir haben einen Haushalt, der hat relativ sparsame Ausgaben.
Ich habe immer versucht, den
Haushalt so schlank wie möglich zu halten und habe auch diese Ausgaben.
Und da kommt das Land und sagt, du hast eine Kita, du musst jetzt machen Ganztagsbetreuung,
Mittagessen und, und, und. Und dafür brauche ich Geld.
Eigentlich eine schöne Idee. Wir versuchen es möglich gut zu machen für die
Kinder, damit sie gut ausgebildet werden.
Und dann haben Sie gesagt, Sie wollen die Kita neu bauen. Ich habe mir gesagt,
ich will nicht, ich muss sie bauen, weil die Räumlichkeiten,
die ich zur Verfügung habe, reichen nicht aus, um den neuen Anfall des Landes zu erfüllen.
Und dann geht aber der Streit im Klein-Klein los, weil dann heißt es ja,
vielleicht hätte ja auch ein Umbau genügt und kein Neubau und hin und her.
Aber es geht Ihnen ja, wenn ich das richtig verstehe, um was Grundsätzliches.
Also Sie wollten ja auch mit Ihren Kolleginnen und Kollegen im Gemeinderat zusammen etwas bewegen.
Sie wollten auf ein Problem aufmerksam machen, oder? Ja gut,
wir wollten auf das Problemaufwand machen, dass wir, wie alle Kommunen,
dann Aufträge des Landes übernehmen, quasi Aufgaben, sprich Kita,
und sind hier deutlich unterfinanziert.
Meine Kita macht ohne Kindergartenneubau 380.000 Euro minus im Haushalt.
Die fehlen mir eigentlich dann für Aufgaben, die ich in der Kommunalverfällung sehe.
Das ist doch der reine Wahnsinn.
Also Michael Ebling, ich sage es nochmal, im Oktober 2022 hat er die Seiten gewechselt.
Ich kassiere das Geld ein als Oberbürgermeister von Mainz und danach ist er
Innenminister von Rheinland-Pfalz geworden.
Und seitdem lässt er die Gemeinden davor, die für 380.000 oder so.
Und Funfact, Mainz hat inzwischen so hohe Mieten, dass die Mainzer nach Wiesbaden,
das war früher die Stadt der Reichen, der Pelzträger, dass die nach Wiesbaden
ziehen, weil sie sich das Wohnen in Mainz nicht mehr leisten können,
aber in Mainz dann arbeiten gehen.
Und Gauweiler führt das jetzt nochmal auf so eine andere Ebene.
Und wenn sich die finanziellen Rahmenbedingungen nicht ändern,
das heißt konkret muss das Land mehr Geld in den Topf des Finanzausgleichs reinfließen
lassen, weil das Definitivität hier in der Kita erzeuge, eine übertragene Aufgabe
des Landes muss ausgeglichen sein.
Wenn das nicht so ist, dann führt das zum nicht-automaten Haushalt.
Und dieses Problem haben alle. Und wenn es so bleibt, gibt es ja für uns keinen Spielraum mehr.
Warum sollen sich Ehrenamtliche für irgendetwas einsetzen, wenn sie gar nichts
bewegen können? Wir verwalten Menschen Schulden, für die wir nicht können.
Ja, warum sollte man das machen? Bist du Quatsch? Ja.
Es wird immer weniger Leute geben, die sich im Meerenamt engagieren,
weil sie nichts bewegen können.
Und eigentlich müsste man darüber nachdenken, ist das nicht eine gute Grundlage
jetzt, dass sich eigentlich die Gemeinderäte gegen Land und Bund verbünden.
Also es gibt ja jetzt, die sind ja alle davon betroffen. Also es wird ja kaum
eine Gemeinde sein, die sagt, wir haben aber eigentlich schon zu viel Geld.
Das heißt, wenn die sich verbünden würden, dann könnten die tatsächlich den großen Aufstand wagen.
Also ich glaube eine wirklich radikale Reform der Schuldenbremse könnte einhergehen,
wenn eigentlich jetzt die Gemeinderäte alle streiken würden und sagen,
ja wir können nächsten Monat alle nicht arbeiten, wir haben ja gar kein Geld.
Wir können ja nichts verwalten, ist es sinnlos, wir bleiben zu Hause.
Und dann würde man ja mal sehen. Denn das sind ja alles keine Berufspolitiker.
Die bekommen vielleicht 60 Euro Sitzungsgeld oder so.
Also die sind überhaupt nicht abhängig davon. Die bringen sich nur ein.
So Amtszeiten von sieben Jahren und so. Damit man so, wir haben wieder erstmal
sieben Jahre Ruhe, weil wir eh schon keinen finden, der da Lust drauf hat und dann sowas.
Ja, also die müssten jetzt eigentlich in den großen Streik gehen,
dass Land und Bund reagieren müssen.
Und jetzt nochmal, muss man sich ja vor Augen führen, in Rheinland-Pfalz ist 2024 Kommunalwahl.
Und im nächsten Jahr ist Kommunalwahl in Rheinland-Pfalz. Wie schauen Sie darauf?
Ja, genau, das gleiche Problem. Also ich gehe davon aus, dass das Problem,
was wir haben, dann haben im Landkreis bei uns, glaube ich, 38 Kommunen schon
einen nicht eigentlichen Haushalt.
Der Ehrenamtliche, der sich in seiner Freizeit einbringt, der will ja irgendwas bewegen drin.
Aktuell kann nur Sachen abnicken, die vorgegeben sind. Eigene Initiativen oder
sonstige Maßnahmen finden ja mangels finanzieller Mittel gar nicht mehr statt.
Ja, das ist wirklich, während wir gleichzeitig dieses,
ich hatte es ja schon mal thematisiert, ich war ja in Frankfurt bei so einer
komischen Veranstaltung,
ich weiß nicht genau, wie man das nennt, Agentur, Kanzlei oder wie auch immer,
also so Immobilienverwalter, die, was weiß ich, so 30 Quadratmeter Omniturm
irgendwie für eine Million verkaufen und sowas.
Also so in diesem, von mir jetzt Pi mal Daumen dargestellten,
die dann ehemalige hessische Ministerpräsidenten einladen, um nochmal ein Gespräch
gegen die AfD zu führen, weil es wird ja jetzt wirklich gefährlich und es ist
uns auch allen Herzensanliegen.
Und dann steht da aber so ein Buffet für 5000 Euro für 30 Leute und dann glaubt
man am Ende des Abends tatsächlich, man hat jetzt was gegen die AfD getan,
weil man mal kurz über die AfD gesprochen hat. so.
Ja.
Während rundrum alles bröckelt. Ja. Und die das auch, wenn man da über Mietpreise redet und so, ne.
Ich hab jetzt keinen Move gemacht dort, ich war nur als Zuhörer da.
Aber ärgert mich im Nachhinein, dass man da hättet doch nochmal so.
Aber die Mietpreise, das macht alles keinen Sinn. Die Leute werden rausgezogen
aus ihrem Engagement sozusagen.
Ja. Es bleibt kein Handlungsvermögen übrig.
Weder für den einzelnen Bürger, der einfach am dritten des Monats sein ganzes
Geld an den Vermieter überweist, Und dann hier, Leute, die sich engagieren,
also die, was weiß ich, über den Elternbeirat Kindergarten reingerutscht sind,
ach so läuft das, ja klar, da stelle ich mich auf und so, und dann stellen sie fest,
nee, macht ja keinen Sinn, wir schreiben nur irgendwas auf, schicken das ans Land,
Weil Haushaltsvorbehalt, wir müssen das ans Land schicken. Das Land schickt
dann einfach eine Liste zurück mit das, das, das nicht und das ja.
Und dann hat man da nochmal eine Frage zu und dann erreicht man da aber niemanden
und so. Es antwortet ja auch keiner in Mainz, wenn man da nochmal eine Frage
zu seinem Haushaltsding hat und so.
Und da werden Leute komplett, also es ist einfach eine Depolitisierung.
Also das kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen.
Also die müssten jetzt so eine Bewegung gründen, sich vernetzen,
wirklich online und alle nach vorne. und ein paar Leute, die sehr gut sprechen.
Ja, das ist erstaunlich, dass man da, ich kann ja durchaus die Wut der Bauern
verstehen, aber ich finde es schon erstaunlich, wie das so rezipiert wird.
Also die haben einfach die B42 lahmgelegt über Stunden.
War überhaupt keine Chance, nach Koblenz dann reinzufahren. Und das ist aber alles okay.
Das ist alles okay. Man braucht einfach schweres Gerät, egal wo man arbeitet.
Am Ende wird der Traktor noch.
Gut, dass sie sich nicht festgeklebt haben.
Nächstes Jahr, also die Bauern, wenn sie echt kein Business mehr haben,
sollten sie ihre Traktoren einfach vermieten, für Leute, die mal eine politische Demo machen wollen.
Ach ja.
Dann steckst du einfach ein und sagst, worum geht's? Kindergarten.
Okay, hier hast du meinen Traktor. Dann fährst du halt mit einem Kindergartenschild
oder was auch immer dein Anliegen ist.
Ja, stimmt. Und blockierst. Ist eine schöne Idee. Wir müssen über Gaza sprechen, was dort los ist.
Über Israel, ich will nur zum Einstieg einen Clip von Baerbock spielen.
Ja, ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich noch was dazu sagen soll zu diesem Clip oder
ob wir einfach nur ihn uns anhören und mal überlegen, ob das das ist,
was wir von einer Politikerin, die Außenministerin ist, erwarten.
Und warum sagen Sie nicht ab sofort Waffenstillstand, wenn Sie diesen Leid selbst gesehen haben?
Weil um dieses Leid zu lindern, um möglichst dafür zu sorgen,
dass insbesondere jetzt in Gaza die Menschen mit dem Nötigsten versorgt werden
können, mit Wasser, mit Lebensmitteln, dann hilft es eben nicht einfach aus dem Impuls heraus,
die Waffen müssen schweigen zu sagen, weil das ist nicht Aufgabe von Politik,
sondern daran mitzuwirken, dass auch wirklich diese humanitäre Hilfe ins Land kommt.
Also für Frieden zu sorgen, nicht die Aufgabe von Politik und Hilfsgüter ins Land.
Irgendwas so in der Art, hat sie gesagt.
Naja, als der Klausowitz sagte, Krieg ist ja nur ein anderes Mittel,
Politik mit anderen Mitteln, haben ja alle gesagt, nein, das ist was eigenes.
Also sagt sie sich, ja stimmt, und ich bin ja Politikerin, also jetzt ist gerade
Krieg, jetzt habe ich da nichts zu suchen.
Ist nicht politisch. Ja. Oh Mann. Es ist irre.
Wir behandeln kurz das Thema, aber ohne Clips weiter. Wir können dann auch nochmal
zwei spielen, aber die sind nur illustrativ.
Ich habe zwei Texte, wir haben uns ja lange gefragt, wie verhalten sich die,
der innerste Mainstream sozusagen, wann bricht es auf, was kriegen wir eigentlich
für eine Weihnachtsbotschaft?
Und wir haben ja schon auf Instagram festgestellt, ohne Namen zu nennen,
selbst Leute, von denen wir dachten, die wachen niemals auf,
die bleiben für immer woke, teilen plötzlich Botschaften, wo es heißt,
das ist aber schlimm in Gaza.
Hätte ich gar nicht gedacht, dass der 7. Oktober dann doch so in Verirrung führen kann und so.
Und es gab zwei interessante Texte, die sich damit befassen und es spielt einen,
also es macht echt einen dramatischen Unterschied oder einen dramaturgischen
Unterschied, welchen man zuerst liest.
Deswegen habe ich einfach nach eine kleine Mickey Mouse, zog ihre Hose aus,
zog sie wieder an und du bist dran, ausgewählt, welchen wir zuerst lesen und
es ist die New York Times.
Israel, ich habe es von Deep L auf Deutsch übersetzen lassen,
Israel hat die Geldmaschine der Hamas schon vor Jahren entdeckt.
Niemand hat sie abgeschaltet, lautet die Überschrift.
Den israelischen Sicherheitsbehörden gelang 2018 ein großer nachrichtendienstlicher Coup.
Geheime Dokumente, in denen sie bis ins Detail dargelegt wurde,
wie ein privater Aktienfonds aussah, den die Hamas zur Finanzierung ihrer Operation nutzte.
Der wurde also bekannt.
Was bedeutet auch die inhaltlichen Verquickungen? Was macht man denn mit diesem Geld?
War dann bekannt, Zitat, in den Büchern, die aus dem Computer eines hochrangigen
Hamas-Beamten gestohlen wurden, sind Vermögenswerte im Wert von Hunderten von
Millionen Dollar aufgeführt.
Die Hamas kontrollierte Bergbau-, Hühnerzucht- und Straßenbauunternehmen in Sudan.
Zwei Wolkenkratzer in den Vereinigten Arabischen Emiraten, ein Immobilienunternehmen
in Algerien und eine an der türkischen Börse notierte Immobilienfirma.
Die Dokumente, die die New York Times eingesehen hat, waren ein möglicher Fahrplan,
um der Hamas den Geldhahn zuzudrehen und ihre Pläne zu vereiteln.
Die Agenten, die die Unterlagen erhalten hatten, gaben sie innerhalb ihrer eigenen
Regierung und in Washington weiter.
Und dann ein Satz, der als einzelner Paragraf in diesem Text steht. Es passierte nichts.
Es geht um 500 Millionen Dollar, von denen man dann wusste, sie sind unter der
Obhut der Hamas und sowohl die amerikanischen als auch die israelischen Beamten wussten also,
ah ja, und jetzt rückblickend wissen wir, das ist der Grundstein für die Anschläge
vom 7. Oktober, wie die New York Times hier schreibt.
Zitat Jeder spricht über das Versagen der Geheimdienste am 7.
Oktober, aber niemand spricht über das Versagen, das Geld zu stoppen,
sagt Udi Lewy, ein ehemaliger Leiter der Abteilung für wirtschaftliche Kriegsführung des Mossad.
Also der Typ war selbst zuständig dafür, hat diesen Erfolg, diesen Finanzstrom
aufzudecken, errungen und weitergegeben und es ist nichts passiert.
Es ist das Geld, das Geld, das dies ermöglicht hat, sagt also Lewy.
Selbst nachdem das Finanzministerium im Jahr 2022 Sanktionen gegen das Netzwerk
verhängt hatte, konnte mit der Hamas verbundene Person durch den Verkauf von
Anteilen an einem Unternehmen, das auf der schwarzen Liste stand,
Millionen Dollar erlangt werden.
Also Hamas hat einfach weiter verdient, hier hat sich niemand für nichts interessiert.
Der Fokus lag damals wohl auf dem Iran.
Man wollte dieses Abkommen da durchsetzen, durchprügeln und so weiter.
Wir haben es ja mitbekommen, wie die Sanktionen immer Thema waren.
Aber die Hamas war so gar kein Thema mehr.
Die israelische Führung glaubte, dass die Hamas mehr am Regieren als am Kämpfen interessiert sei.
Netanyahus Mosachev schaltete Levis Team, die Task Force Harpoon,
so nannte sie sich, aus, dass sich darauf konzentrierte, den Geldfluss zu Gruppen
wie der Hamas zu unterbrechen.
Also nicht nur interessierte man sich nicht dafür, sondern mit den Infos,
die daraus gefunden wurden, hat man diese Gruppe einfach aufgelöst.
Ehemalige Harpoon-Agenten waren über die Untätigkeit so frustriert,
dass sie einige Dokumente auf Facebook hochluten, in der Hoffnung,
dass Unternehmen und Investoren sie finden und ihre Geschäfte mit hermaßnah
stehenden Unternehmen einstellen würden.
Also wenn man Beamte hat, die merken, das geht ja in die falsche Richtung,
wir publizieren das mal öffentlich, Wesentlich, damit zumindest die Öffentlichkeit
in der Lage ist, einzelne Unternehmen, die mit der Hamas Geschäfte machen,
irgendwie so zu privat sanktionieren, wie auch immer.
Das ist fast so eine Snowden-Geschichte, in der er dann sagt,
Moment, wenn ich hier selbst und so und dachte, jetzt kommt Obama,
jetzt decke ich es auf und intern kommt man da nicht weiter,
dann wird das alles nichts, dann geht man da so ein bisschen an die Öffentlichkeit.
Terroristische Organisationen wie Al-Qaida und der Islamische Staat nutzen oft
Scheinfirmen, um Geld zu waschen, also man kannte die Prinzipien,
aber hier sahen die israelischen Agenten etwas anderes, etwas ehrgeizigeres,
ein multinationales Netz echter Unternehmen, die echte Gewinne erwirtschafteten.
Also im Sinne der Gespräche, die Sie hier führten, sagen Sie nochmal,
das war eigentlich offensichtlicher und auch deutlicher, was Sie da sahen,
als Al-Qaida und IS-Finanzierung, die man vorher schon in den gleichen geheimdienstlichen
Kreisen beobachtet hatte.
Naja, sie gehen dann diese Namen durch, die da immer wieder eine Rolle spielen,
als Aktionäre, Führungskräfte, Vorstandsmitglieder und so weiter,
Eigner dieser Unternehmen.
Hisham, Kwafishe, Ameer Al-Shawar, Ahmed Odeh, also das sind alles diese von
der Taskforce Harpoon aufgedeckten Namen.
Mitarbeiter aus allen Bereichen der Terrorismusbekämpfung, Spione,
Soldaten, Polizisten, Buchhalter, Anwälte. Diese Taskforce war also groß aufgestellt.
Man hatte wirklich aus allen Bereichen, also nicht nur Spione,
Geheimdienste, sondern man hat sich in allen Bereichen Israels Hilfe geholt.
Und dann wurde es einfach aufgelöst.
2016 wurde diese Gruppe von Netanyahs Regierung einfach aufgelöst.
Nun ja, die Hamas hat ab 2016 GPS-Störsender, Drohnen, Präzisionswaffen gekauft,
wurde alles dokumentiert.
Sie hat 6000 neue Aktivisten in ihre Reihen aufgenommen mit Arbeitsvertrag,
alles dokumentiert und registriert. Und Netanyahu so, interessiert mich nicht,
mich interessiert nur der Iran.
Zu Netanyahu steht hier, insgeheim sagt er anderen, also Netanyahu,
dass eine Stabilisierung der Hamas den Druck auf ihn verringern würde,
über einen palästinensischen Staat zu verhandeln.
Naja.
Also er wollte, dass die Hamas sich da etabliert, damit einfach gesagt werden
kann, ne, wir müssen hier gar nichts
mehr klären, weil dort sind die Palästinenser, regiert von der Hamas,
wo doch klar ist, die machen eh nie wieder Wahlen und da geht es auch nicht
demokratisch zu, sondern die machen, was sie wollen.
Naja, und...
Ja, die Leidtragenden sind dann am 7. Oktober die Geiseln, die Hingerichteten
und sind jetzt die, die bombardiert werden, wo größtenteils dann Zivilisten getroffen werden.
Also ich meine, jetzt werden wahrscheinlich manche kritisieren,
ja größtenteils, was heißt größtenteils?
Naja, wir sind so unendlich viele Kinder davon betroffen.
Also wir sprechen jetzt von über 20.000 Toten. Wenn man jetzt AP zum Beispiel.
Und das ist ja eine sehr renommierte Nachrichtenagentur, glauben kann und die
sagen, 70 Prozent der Schulgebäude in Gaza sind beschädigt durch die Bombenangriffe.
Ein Experte hier, der so Satellitenbilder auswertet von Vandenhoek, der sagt,
der Gazastreifen hat jetzt aus dem Weltraum eine andere Farbe,
es ist eine andere Textur. So stark sind wir.
Und jetzt aus diesem AP-Bericht, da heißt es dann, in etwas mehr als zwei Monaten
hat die Offensive mehr Zerstörung angerichtet als die Zerstörung des syrischen
Aleppo zwischen 2012 und 2016,
des ukrainischen Mariupol oder im Verhältnis dazu die alliierten Bombenangriffe
auf Deutschland im Zweiten Weltkrieg.
Sie hat mehr Zivilisten getötet als die US-geführte Koalition in ihrem dreijährigen
Feldzug gegen die Gruppe Islamischer Staat.
Also das sind die unglaublichen Zahlen.
Das ist AP News von Julia Frankel und das sind erschreckende Zahlen.
Und jetzt gehen wir mal, seien wir mal so zynisch und sagen ja,
aber es ist ja doch das Ziel, die Hamas zu zerstören und das sind dann die Kollateralschäden.
Also wenn man diesen Zynismus mal
mitbringt.
Wie hier steht, der große Durchbruch.
Mahmoud Ghazal, der Buchhalter des Hamas-Portfolios, wird aufgegriffen.
Und auf eine Art und Weise verhört in Saudi-Arabien, dass man hier im Text so
sagt, okay, das war Folter und so.
Diese Infos werden weitergereicht, aber es passiert weiterhin nichts.
Man muss sich es fast wie in so einer Fernsehserie vorstellen und hier kommen
dann auch die Länder ins Spiel.
Also die arabischen Emirate, Saudi-Arabien und so weiter, die sind alle eigentlich
daran interessiert, also sage ich jetzt mal so pro forma, die sind interessiert daran,
dass hier illegale Machenschaften, weil auch nicht alle, nur weil sie arabisch
oder persisch oder wie auch immer sind, auf Seiten der Hamas stehen,
dafür klare Verhältnisse sorgen.
Und es ist eigentlich Israels Aufgabe ist schon allein, weil das eben ein israelisches
Staatsgebiet ist, wo man nicht einfach dann handhaben kann und was gegen die
Hamas tun kann, selbst wenn man es wollte.
Und Israel tut einfach nichts und sie entdecken dann über diesen Gazal diesen Fonds in der Türkei.
500 Millionen Dollar Umfang. Wird quasi nur genutzt, um Waffen und Material
und Leute und so zu kaufen.
Und die ganze Regierung weiß eigentlich Bescheid. Und es passiert trotzdem einfach nichts.
Bis hin zu, dass dann diese hauptsächlich von Frauen angeführte Beobachtungsbrigade
kurz vor Gaza da sieht, dass die da sogar üben, Trainingsplätze einführen,
Bomben werfen und sowas.
Und die noch Bescheid sagen, Achtung, hier steht irgendwas an,
die planen irgendwas und so und es passiert genau gar nichts.
Also auch unter diesen Dimensionen hat es wirklich so einen 11. September Charakter.
Wir wissen ja, wie die Nachwehen des 11. September waren, also relativ viele
Fernsehserien, die das nochmal thematisieren, wie die Amerikaner da sehenden
Auges oder eben Blindheit, weil
18 verschiedene Geheimdienste nicht miteinander arbeiten können und so.
Also es war alles offenbar, Aber es wird einfach nicht durchgegangen.
Und wie Erdogan zur Hamas steht, haben wir ja gesehen.
Beim deutschen Stadtbesuch hat er es sich nicht getraut, aber typischerweise
thematisiert er ja die Hamas nur als Befreiungsorganisation,
die nichts mit Terror am Hut habe und so.
Und von daher ist so ein Geldmanagement-Ding über die Türkei abgewickelt,
von denen selbst andere arabische Länder international warnen und in echtem
Kontakt mit Israel stehen und sagen, wir haben hier jemanden,
den haben wir auch verhört, ihr wollt nicht wissen wie und so,
da droht irgendwas und trotzdem passiert es.
Also es ist wirklich ein ganz großes, großes Drama.
Ja und deswegen ist das ja dann auch eine sehr eigenartige Aussage,
wenn man sagt, man will die Hamas jetzt zerstören. Und was bedeutet das jetzt eigentlich?
Also gehen wir mal diesen Zynismus weiter mit und sagen, ja das sind dann Kollateralschäden
und das sind dann auch Kinder, die Bomben abbekommen oder so.
Mhm.
Was würde denn passieren, wenn man jetzt noch viele weitere wichtige Hamas-Kämpfer tötet?
Die sind ja nicht alle in Gaza.
Die halten sich ja woanders auf. Das heißt, man kann sie gar nicht ausrotten,
um es jetzt so ganz brachial zu sagen.
Und es sind auch noch weiterhin zwei Millionen Palästinenser da,
von denen wahrscheinlich der ein oder andere sich jetzt gerade radikalisiert,
beziehungsweise haben wir ja noch andere Gruppen, Hisbollah wäre zu nennen und
andere, die durchaus Interesse haben,
dort auch einen Fuß in die Tür zu bekommen oder dort mitzumischen.
Das heißt, es ist ja nicht so, dass man sagen kann, wir müssen noch etwa 1000
Hamas-Kämpfer töten und dann ist aber Frieden eingekehrt. Ganz im Gegenteil.
Und deswegen ist ja gerade das, was dann auch Baerbock sagt,
so verantwortungslos, weil sie ja erkennen muss, dass es nicht eine Frage ist
von wie viel Hamas-Kämpfer müssen getötet werden, damit das Problem aus der Welt ist.
Das Problem kann gar nicht so aus der Welt sein, aus der Welt geschafft werden,
wie man sich das hier vorstellt und das bedeutet, dass man jetzt weiterhin in
dieser Reaktion ist, dass man sagt, ja aber der 7.
Oktober rechtfertigt diese Art der Angriffe und dann würde ich sagen,
das ist also auch vor der Weltöffentlichkeit und das hört man ja dann auch deutlicher.
Zum Teil dann in Talkshows jetzt von Louis Klamrott oder sonst was,
wo sowas dann auch geäußert wird, auch dann von Leuten, wo man es gar nicht
so erwartet, ist das bald nicht mehr darstellbar.
Und ich meine, die Feuilletons hier und die Twitter-Leute und die linksliberalen
Podcaster, die warten eigentlich jeden Tag darauf,
hoffentlich ist wieder irgendein verrückter, entweder ein anderes Thema oder
wirklich irgendein verrückter antisemitischer Student mit lila Haaren,
der in Berlin irgendwas von sich gibt. Und dann kann ich natürlich die ganze
Zeit diesen Clip spielen.
Und ja, das ist ein Problem, das sollte man auch ernst nehmen,
aber hier, das ist jetzt auch reales Leid von 20.000 Menschen und man kann ja
auch wiederum überlegen, wenn diese Radikalisierung durch die Bilder,
durch all das jetzt gerade stattfindet, wie unsicher wird das Leben auch künftig in Israel sein?
Denn es ist ja nicht so, dass die hier dafür sorgen, dass so ein Anschlag nie mehr sein kann,
sondern vielleicht kommen ganz neue Dimensionen dann auf die Bevölkerung in Israel zu von Terror.
Und das muss einem doch klar sein, dass das nicht sich so in Wohlgefallen auflösen
wird oder dass man irgendwann sagt am 15.
Februar, jetzt scheint es gut zu sein.
Ja, wir haben eine unaufgearbeitete Vorgeschichte vom 7. Oktober.
Es ist nicht im Vakuum passiert.
Diese Aufbauten der Hamas über Jahre, die da mitbeobachtet wurden, haben alle damit zu tun.
Und ich finde es auch, ich habe jetzt nur so ein Deutschlandfunk-Clip noch im
Ohr, wie so Korrespondent sagt,
ja unter Mithilfe von Katar hat man jetzt Verhandlungsergebnisse und so.
Wo ich mir auch denke, nee, das kann man so nicht sagen.
In Katar sitzen nicht Leute, die dankbarerweise noch Kontakt zu Hamas haben,
sodass man mit denen reden kann, sondern das ist dort die Hamas.
Ja.
Ja, so und nur weil man nicht in der Lage ist, auch noch Katar zu bombardieren,
um dann die militärische Lösung herzustellen,
die Hamas sitzt nicht in Katar, die hat ihr Geld in der Türkei,
die Leute, auf die es ankommt, sind, wenn sie in Gefangenschaft sind,
auch egal, werden einfach ersetzt, genau wie die Kämpfer da auch,
die Radikalisierung läuft halt, wie die Radikalisierung bei Terror läuft.
Und ich würde mal auch sagen, Israel stehen jetzt wirklich ganz unsichere Jahre,
wenn nicht Jahrzehnte bevor.
Also wie soll denn das jetzt wieder eine friedliche Lösung, nachdem es schon
bei dem Zustand vorher keine friedliche Lösung gab, wie soll denn das jetzt
eine friedliche Lösung geben?
In der Hinsicht, was ist die Lage vor Ort? Christoph Reuter,
wir kennen ihn als Autor, der ganz viel zum IS auch Bücher geschrieben hat, die sehr gut sind.
Einer heißt irgendwie die Schwarze Macht oder so. naja, jedenfalls Christoph
Reuter, hat zusammen mit Fritz Schaab im Spiegel über die humanitäre Krise geschrieben.
Überschrift, die Menschen in Gaza werden in Massen sterben. Vorspann,
kein Wasser, kein Essen, kein Strom, keine Antibiotika.
Nach elf Wochen der fast völligen Abriegelung Gazas werden Kinder verletzter
Alte bald in Scharen sterben, egal ob die Bombardements weitergehen oder nicht.
Wir haben es mit einer täglich verzweifelter werdenden Lage für 2,3 Millionen
Menschen in Gaza zu tun, schreibt er.
Zigtausende in Gaza, vor allem Kinder, Alte, Kranke, für die es keine Rettung
mehr geben wird, selbst wenn morgen keine einzige Bombe mehr, viele.
Und sie sprechen dann mit einigen, wie hier zum Beispiel Ärzte ohne Grenzen, Lara Dovifat.
Was die Expertin für humanitäre Notlagen in ruhigen Worten ausbreitet,
ist der langsame, sichere Weg, Menschen massenhaft, auch ohne Luftangriffe und
Panzerbeschuss umzubringen, indem man sie von allem abschneidet,
was sie zum Überleben brauchen.
20.000 Menschen, zwei Drittel Kinder und Frauen sind in den elf Wochen des Krieges
in Gaza schon getötet worden.
Tausende Verschüttete, ebenso an Krankheiten und Verletzungen Gestorbene blieben unerfasst.
Also wir haben sogar mit, wie er jetzt sagt, bisher hieß es ja immer,
naja das sind ja die Zahlen der Hamas, die übertreiben.
Und jetzt ist eher die Vermutung, ne da wird nicht alles erfasst, was es zu nennen gibt.
1,9 der knapp 2,3 Millionen Einwohner sind immer weiter nach Süden geflohen.
Zwei oder dreimal weiter geflohen, weil auch die Sicherheitszonen immer wieder bombardiert werden.
Das fand ich ja so crazy, dass Volker Beck ja einfach twittert,
aber was halten sich die Menschen da auf?
Diese Gebiete wurden doch als Gefechtszone definiert.
Wo ich denke, naja klar wurden die als Gefechtszone definiert,
aber man hat den Leuten den Strom, das Internet und alles genommen.
Erstens, wie erhalten sie die Information? Und zweitens.
Israel hält sich nicht an die Gefechtszonen-Definitionen, sondern da wird ja
einfach alles bombardiert.
Beispiellos nennt UNRWA, also hier das konkrete Hilfswerk, Sprecherin Thuma
gegenüber dem Spiegel die Angriffe auf völkerrechtlich geschützte UN-Gebäude.
136 Mitarbeiter sind bislang umgekommen, das hat es in der Geschichte der UNO noch nie gegeben.
UNRWA-Chef Philippe Lazzarani, Zitat, Ich sehe dort Familien auf nackten Booten ohne Decke leben,
in derselben Kleidung, in der sie vor 50 Tagen geflohen waren,
den ganzen Tag damit verbringend, irgendwo etwas zu essen zu finden.
93% der Menschen sind laut Welternährungsorganisationen jetzt vom Hunger bedroht.
Die Menschen sterben nicht nur wegen mangelnder medizinischer Versorgung,
sagte vor Tagen der Koordinator des medizinischen Notfallteams der WHO, Sean Casey.
Zitat, sie verhungern und verdursten. Am 9.
Oktober verkündete Israels Verteidigungsminister Joav Galant die vollständige
Belagerung des abgeriegelten Gaza-Streifens.
Es sollte keine Nahrungsmittel, kein Strom, kein Diesel für die Zivilbevölkerung
geben, auch kein Trinkwasser.
Also das war die Losung am 9. Oktober und jetzt zwei Monate später stellt man
fest, ja, also es war tatsächlich der Plan und er wurde vom Verteidigungsministerium umgesetzt. Am 17.
Dezember öffnete Israel den zweiten Grenzübergang Kerem Shalom,
um mehr Lastwagen abfertigen zu können und ließ ihn am 21.
Dezember auf palästinensischer Seite bombardieren.
Am Freitag wurde der Übergang zum zweiten Mal von einer israelischen Drohne
beschossen. Es gab mehrere Tote.
UNRWA musste alle Transporte stoppen. Also die Israelis machen das auf,
als Grenzübergang, auch internationaler Druck und dann zwei Tage später wird
es einfach bombardiert.
Also man sorgt sozusagen für Tatsachen, weil dann traut sich wieder keiner hin
und dann ist es ja faktisch wieder geschlossen. Die Tuma von der UNRWA.
Häufigste Todesursache weltweit. Also wenn die Nahrungsmittel einfach nicht
im Körper bleiben und da drei Tage lang durchgespült werden, ist einfach...
Und üblicherweise, die Leute leben nicht alle in Frankfurt oder Suhl oder so,
wo es Krankenhaus gibt, sondern wenn es hier heißt, von der WHO Durchfallerkrankungen
und die Hälfte betrifft die Kleinkinder, dann ist das wirklich lebensbedrohlich.
Von einst 36 Krankenhäusern in Gaza, Stand Donnerstag, sind neun noch teilweise funktionsfähig.
Sie sprechen hier mit James Elder von UNICEF.
Man steht hier vor einem Perfect Storm der Krankheiten. Also es ist UNICEF, die hier das sagen.
Das Nassau-Krankenhaus im Süden Gazas ist eines der letzten,
das noch Schwerverletzte und Patienten mit Verbrennung dritten Grades behandeln kann.
Trotz wiederholter Angriffe der israelischen Armee, trotz zuletzt am 17.
Dezember, als die Entbindungsstation bombardiert wurde und ein Kind umkam,
sind die Ärzte ohne Grenzen mit drei Mitarbeitern weiterhin dort.
Die Notaufnahme ist völlig überfüllt, beschrieb vor Tagen ihr medizinischer
Teamleiter Chris Hook die Bedingungen.
Neue Patienten werden auf dem Boden behandelt, die Ärztinnen und Ärzte müssen
über Leichen von Kindern steigen, um andere Kinder zu behandeln,
die wahrscheinlich auch sterben werden.
Die Menschenrechtsorganisation Human Rights Watch hat Israels Regierung am Montag
vorgeworfen, mit dem Aushungern von Zivilisten sich eines Kriegsverbrechens
schuldig zu machen. Also solche Debatten werden jetzt geführt.
Diese Debatten werden in der Welt geführt, nicht so sehr bei uns.
Nicht in Deutschland. Außer hier in diesem Spiegeltext. Unterdessen scheint
das erklärte Ziel des Krieges in den Hintergrund zu rücken, also die Hamas zu
bekämpfen, denn man findet sie einfach nicht.
Man hat damals am 7.
Oktober 1200 Menschen getötet, verschleppt wurden 240 und man weiß nicht, wo die restlichen sind.
Die ausgedehnten Tunnelsysteme, in denen die Hamas-Führung sich und die verbliebenen
Geiseln versteckt hält, sind nach Angaben mehrerer israelischer Offiziere bislang
nicht lokalisiert worden.
Auch dürfen die Soldaten nicht in die entdeckten Tunnel vordringen,
man bombardiert stattdessen die Eingangsschächte.
Also wir hatten ja gehört, dass jetzt drei Geiseln erschossen wurden,
nachdem sie unbewaffnet, fast ohne Kleidung und mit weißen Fähnchen und so,
also klaren Signalen da auftraten und trotzdem erschossen wurden. Offenbar...
Findet die israelische Armee Tunnel und bombardiert sie einfach,
statt nochmal nachzuschauen, ob da vielleicht Geiseln drin sind. Letzter Absatz.
Minimieren. Und den lassen sie einfach so stehen, den Satz.
Also wir haben jetzt hier den Mainstream des Mainstreams präsentiert mit dem
Spiegel der New York Times und der AP.
Und es ist doch erstaunlich, wie wenig eine Sensibilisierung dafür in der deutschen
Debattenkultur stattfindet.
Man in diesen Grabenkämpfen ist, man sich nur darüber streiten will,
was an irgendeiner Universität in Berlin rum läuft und passiert und gesagt wird.
Also das kann man auch alles machen, an bunten Tagen, würde ich vorschlagen.
Aber ich sehe doch da so eine Ignoranz gegenüber Fakten.
Und da braucht man ja gar nicht in dieses ganze Debattenfeld Antisemitismus,
welche Begriffe verwenden wir für was.
Sondern hier muss man ja sagen, hier geht es darum, reales Leid zu minimieren
und darüber nachzudenken, wie man das schafft und wie kriegt man da einen humanitären
Ansatz hin. Und dazu braucht es auch eine wirtschaftliche Grundlage.
Ich will das nicht lange ausführen, aber nur darauf hinweisen,
dass Patrick Kaczmarczyk und...
Adam Tooze, gemeinsam in der Zeit einen langen Artikel geschrieben haben,
der überschrieben ist mit dem Titel Den Kollaps verhindern, die Verwüstung Gazas
macht ein Leben dort langfristig unmöglich, deshalb muss es schnell zu einem
bleibenden Waffenstillstand kommen.
Europa kann aber noch mehr tun und dann zeigen sie die prekäre ökonomische Lage
der Palästinenser, Wie dort gewirtschaftet werden kann,
wie sehr man dort aber abhängig ist natürlich von ganz vielen Faktoren.
Also die palästinensische Wirtschaft besteht aus drei Fremdwährungen.
Also das Wichtigste für den Zahlungsverkehr ist der neue israelische Schekel,
dann der US-Dollar und der jordanische Dinar.
Da kann man sich ja schon vorstellen, das ist nicht alles so einfach damit.
Das produziert dann auch Handelsdefizite. Sie schreiben hier,
diese Ungleichgewichte und Gegebenheiten führen dazu,
dass das palästinensische Handelsbilanzdefizit von insgesamt 48 Prozent des
BIP 2022 eines der höchsten der Welt ist.
Durch das hohe Handelsbilanzdefizit ist auch die Leistungsbilanz permanent defizitär,
wenngleich die Einkommen der palästinensischen Arbeiter in Israel,
Rücküberweisungen aus der Diaspora sowie Hilfsgelder der internationalen Gemeinschaft
das Defizit ein Stück weit korrigieren konnten.
Allerdings blieb das Leistungsbilanzdefizit in den letzten 20 Jahren mit einem
Durchschnitt von 16% des BIP enorm hoch. Und?
Die Entwicklung ist weitgehend miserabel. Das bittere Fazit ist,
schreiben die Autoren, dass das Projekt Zwei-Staaten-Lösung im Hinblick auf
die Wirtschaft nie ernsthaft angegangen worden ist.
Heute sind durch eine de facto Währungs- und Zollunion zwei Partner miteinander verflochten.
Die Ungleicher nicht sein könnten und wo ein Land über allen Maßen von seinem
größeren Partner abhängig ist, Um die Ungleichheiten an einer Zahl festzumachen,
auf ein US-Dollar-Einkommen für einen Israeli kommt ein Palästinenser auf lediglich 8 Cent.
Mit einer solchen Dimension der Ungleichheit und Abhängigkeit ist an eine Zwei-Staaten-Lösung
nicht zu denken und nach den schrecklichen Ereignissen des Herbstes stehen die
Zeichen für eine nachhaltige Entwicklung in der Region noch schlechter.
Ist ein langer Artikel, ich empfehle ihn sehr zu lesen, weil er einfach mal
ganz sachlich, wirtschaftlich aufdröselt, wie kompliziert es ist,
wenn man jetzt tatsächlich eine Zwei-Staaten-Lösung beabsichtigt, wie kompliziert es ist,
so etwas bei einer solchen Ungleichheit der Volkswirtschaften durchzusetzen.
Und wir haben damals gesagt, ich glaube es war im Teaser dann,
dem Teaser Anfang November,
dass da viele jetzt oder ich glaube oder war es schon in der Folge,
dass wir schon sagten, ja da werden wahrscheinlich einige ihre Meinung,
die jetzt so ganz klar sagten, Ceasefire geht auf keinen Fall und so,
werden vielleicht anfangen die Meinung zu revidieren.
So ein bisschen scheint es zu bröckeln, zumindest sieht man es eher am...
Wir reden ja so viel über das Schweigen, man sieht es vielleicht ein bisschen
an dem Schweigen derer, die sich sehr stark erst mit diesem Konflikt auseinandergesetzt
haben und jetzt aber weitergezogen sind zu anderen Themen,
dass sie sagen, naja, aber jetzt ist doch gerade die Lage sehr intrikat und
es muss doch möglich sein, darüber so zu reden,
dass man sagt, alles muss getan werden, um menschliches Leid auf beiden Seiten zu verhindern.
Und wie gesagt, diese Bombardierung, die da jetzt stattfindet,
wird eine neue Radikalisierung nach sich ziehen,
wird also dauerhaft die Sicherheit der Israelis gefährden und wird auch generell nochmal,
um von diesem menschlichen Leid abzuheben auf etwas Grundsätzliches,
wird auch generell nochmal weltweit den Blick auf den Westen sehr stark verändern.
Wenn man jetzt nicht hier einen humanitären Ansatz versucht.
Die Lösung wird nicht so klar auf der Hand liegen, aber zu sagen,
dass es einfach mal so weitergehen soll, noch ein paar mal muss es rumsen und
dann ist aber bestimmt auch wieder ein Waffenstillstand möglich oder dann ist Ruhe oder Frieden.
Davon kann ja nun tatsächlich niemand ausgehen.
Und wir weisen immer mal wieder darauf hin, deswegen ist dieser Text ja so wichtig
auch von Patrick und Adam Tooze.
Am Ende ist das zwar auf dem politischen Felde, aber man braucht eine ökonomische, tragfähige Lösung.
Denn wenn man eine Grenze hat und auf der einen Seite verdient die Leute einfach
15 mal mehr im Schnitt als auf der anderen Seite, dann ist Befriedung schwer.
Dann nützen alle politischen Anstrengungen nichts.
Entweder man gesteht den Palästinensern auch ökonomische Handlungsvermögen zu oder halt nicht.
Aber wenn nicht, dann hat man eine Fortschreibung der Geschichte,
wie sie bis hierhin führte.
Denn von diesen prekären Verhältnissen war ja offenbar, wie wir jetzt durch
die New York Times erfahren, die Hamas nicht betroffen.
Die konnten ja die Gelder über ganz andere Kanäle nutzen.
Ja, es ist immer schwierig zu formulieren, aber das palästinensische Volk,
was da jetzt in Gaza lebt, ist in unterschiedlichem Maße,
aber es ist eine funktionale Augenhöhe Opfer der Hamas und der israelischen
Regierung. Also die werden da richtig zerrieben.
Ich komme immer wieder auf diesen Tweet von Jan Fleischhauer zurück.
Er meinte, die Lösung für Gaza ist doch ganz einfach. Die Palästinenser geben
einfach die Geiseln zurück.
Nur diese 2,2 Millionen Palästinenser, von denen wir gerade lassen,
die haben mit den Geiseln gar nichts zu tun.
Die haben damit so wenig zu tun wie Jan Fleischhauer selbst.
Und in der Sicht ist das wirklich eine dramatisch verworrene Lage,
die unbedingt auch eine ökonomische Befriedung braucht.
Ja, aber das passiert, wenn man Regierung und Bevölkerung in eins setzt.
Und das werden wir heute auch noch einmal erleben. Aber wir reden doch jetzt
erstmal über den, denen es gut geht.
Den, denen es am besten geht, nämlich unseren. Wen geht es eigentlich am besten?
Was würden wir einfach so sagen, bevor wir wissen, um wen es geht?
Nun, nachdem ich mir das Material angeschaut habe, bin ich mir nicht so sicher,
ob es denen am besten geht.
Also denen geht es ökonomisch am besten.
Aber ich habe nicht den Eindruck, dass ich da so glückliche,
reflektierte, weise Menschen vor mir habe.
Sondern es ist so ein doch recht brutales Ausagieren, wo man doch mit einer
solchen Summe eine Gelassenheit an den Tag legen kann, die man vielleicht auch
schon mit 5000 im Monat hätte.
Aber ja, da müsste es ja auf jeden Fall der Fall sein.
Aber nein, man hat es doch mit merkwürdigen Leuten zu tun, oder? Allerdings.
Also wir reden über die Superreichen. Es gab ja diese Doku von Julia Friedrichs
und Jochen Breyer, die sehr gut ist. Wir empfehlen sie sehr.
Sie geht in dreiviertel Stunde. Man kann sie sich einfach anschauen.
Wir wollen trotzdem nochmal rote Fäden rausdröseln. Aber ich finde auch den
ersten Einschlag, den du jetzt gemacht hast, um den geht es mir eigentlich. Eigentlich.
Denn wir starten jetzt in ein neues Jahr, in dem wir feststellen gleich,
okay, sehr vielen Leuten geht es wirklich sehr viel besser und die Zukunftserwartungen
Einzelner sind schlecht.
Bislang hatten wir statistisch immer so ein, okay, die Leute am Ende des Jahres
gefragt, war es für sie ein gutes Jahr, sagen die doch überwiegend ja, so auch dieses Jahr.
Wir merken aber, es ist nur Hoffnung, dass das noch eine Weile so ist.
Ob die Leute wirklich immer jedes Jahr dann nur sagen werden,
nee, das Jahr war eigentlich ganz gut, ich habe nur Angst vor dem nächsten,
aber das nächste wird dann doch nicht so schlecht.
Diesmal fühlt es sich ja ein bisschen anders an.
Ja, es fühlt sich nicht nur anders an. Es ist ja auch ökonomisch sehr viel schlechter
geworden für sehr viele Leute.
Wir haben so ein paar Kennziffern, die sind nicht gut.
Und nicht nur für die ganz Armen. Also klar, denen hat man auch noch mal eins drauf gesattelt.
Aber generell können wir das auch für die, die im mittleren Einkommenssegment sind, feststellen.
Also man merkt generell eine sehr negative Stimmung, die aber realwirtschaftliche
Ursachen hat. Und die auch daran liegt, dass jetzt die Ampel diese Sparpakete durchdrückt.
Sie hätte ja auch mal überlegen können, also jetzt SPD und Grüne meine ich damit,
wenn doch bei der CDU auch manche, sagen wir mal, Redebedarf haben hinsichtlich
der Schuldenbremse, hätte man nicht in ganz anderer Weise Druck aufbauen können.
Wenn ich das jetzt richtig sehe, dann hat man ja doch wieder mehr Sanktionen,
hat beim Bürgergeldfortschritt solche Fortbildungen rausgestrichen.
Also eigentlich ist Hartz IV zurück, kann man sagen.
Und um das noch gerade anzuführen, bevor wir dann wirklich zu den Reichen gehen,
noch für mich das Ärgernis des…,
des Heiligen Abends am 24. Dezember twitterte Sven Lehmann von den Grünen. Hast du es gelesen?
Nein.
Sven Lehmann von den Grünen, also Bundestagsabgeordneter. All I want for Christmas
is also das ist die Teile aus dem Mariah Carey Lied.
Mit dem sie jedes Jahr 25 Millionen Dollar Tandem verdient und so.
Ich gratuliere und sie behauptet immer sie hätte das eigentlich fast selbst
geschrieben und dann kommt immer wieder der eigentliche Komponist und sagt nee,
also sowas kann die die gar nicht schreiben. Wie dem auch sei.
All I want for Christmas is, dass Menschen nicht niedergemacht werden,
weil sie arm sind. Weder privat noch politisch.
Und hatten wir das nicht mal mit Ferda Attermann, wo auch irgendwann so ein
Vorschlag von ihr kam, ja und da müssen wir auch mal gucken,
wie wir dann Wort wegfinden für Arme.
Also man hat hier jemanden, der Teil der Regierung ist, ist,
die dafür sorgt, dass Menschen jetzt nochmal massiv ärmer werden in Deutschland.
Und er sagt, wir haben die zwar arm gemacht, die Menschen, aber bitte,
tut mir einen Gefallen, diskriminiert sie nicht.
Es kann doch gar nicht sein.
Es ist alles ganz schräg und hier stimmt irgendwas im Gesamtgefüge nicht.
Wir brauchen neue Diskussionen über die Politik, die für sowas verantwortlich ist.
Ich würde sagen, irgendwer braucht mal, wir haben ja immer diesen IFO-Geschäftsklimaindex
und das BIP und dann hören wir noch in der letzten Vorweihnachtswoche DAX neuer Rekord hoch und so.
Also wir haben ganz viele Maßstäbe dafür und ich werbe auch dafür.
Wir müssen uns mal Gedanken machen.
Wir brauchen es eigentlich, vielleicht machen wir das mal bei einer unserer
Chaos-Veranstaltungen, wo wir so ein bisschen alberner werden,
aber wir brauchen so einen Maßstab dafür, sowas einzupreisen,
darzustellen. Also wenn er sowas twittert,
Da ist ein politisches Versagen unter der Haube, das müsste man mal auf eine
Tafel kriegen irgendwie, dass man es versteht.
Vielleicht sollte man das Jahr 2023 nochmal aufarbeiten im Sinne von,
wir hatten im Koalitionsvertrag die Verschuldung oder Entschuldung der Kommunen drin.
Sie kam nicht, wie so vieles andere. Man wartet auch auf die Verantwortungsgemeinschaft
oder sehr viele Sachen, die gar nicht budgetrelevant sind und trotzdem das Leben
erleichtern. Also wir sehen nichts von irgendwas.
Und man bräuchte nochmal so eine neue Bilanzziehung der Politik.
Stichwort Verantwortungsgemeinschaft. Ich habe dieses Wort seitdem Anne Spiegel
zurückgetreten ist, nie mehr irgendwo gehört. Was ist da los?
Ja, Lisa Paus ist irgendwie, ich weiß auch nicht, das ist keine gute Besetzung.
Weil ich meine, das war ja jetzt von Spiegel auch vorbereitet und ausgeführt und gab ja Sinn.
Ja, eigentlich lag das alles bereit. Ja, ich habe es in der Alten Republik ja geschrieben.
Wir haben Anne Spiegel nach Hause geschickt, weil sie sich Familie und Beruf
nicht vereinbaren lässt.
Wir hören heute zum Abschluss vielleicht nochmal einen ganz traurigen Clip über
Olaf Scholz. Ich will jetzt nur teasern.
Aber ja, wir brauchen so eine neue Bilanzziehung der Politik,
in der wir knallhart Kennziffern nennen.
Wie zum Beispiel, wie viele Gemeinderäte sind gerade noch im Amt und wie viele
Haushalte sind dort in eigener Hoheit und nicht unter Haushaltsvorbehalt des Landes.
Und wenn wir dann feststellen, eigentlich ist nur noch Weißerach frei,
und dann fragt man sich, warum?
Ah ja, weil ja die Porsche-Teststrecke ist klar. Die haben natürlich Gewerbesteuer.
Alle anderen sind komplett unter Wasser und dann kommt auch noch echtes Hochwasser dazu.
Also man muss das mal irgendwie bilanzieren, dass man so sieht,
nee, macht keinen Sinn, vor allem immer nur Bundesliga zu spielen in der Politik,
also immer nur zu gucken, wie der Kanzler drauf ist, sondern man braucht da
mal so andere. Wir nehmen Vorschläge entgegen.
Gut, also wir brauchen eine neue Diskussion auf allen Ebenen,
auch über Superreiche, denn die spinnen alle.
Und das meine ich jetzt nicht im Sinne von, ich bin neidisch,
ich hätte auch gern so viel Geld, die machen das Falsche mit dem Geld oder sowas,
sondern irgendwas stimmt da nicht mehr.
Also das ist so das gesamte Gemütszustandsgefüge in unserer Superreichenklasse,
angegliedert natürlich ganz nahe das politische System, stimmt da nicht mehr.
Und wir nähern uns dem aber langsam, also der Frage, wie stehen Erbe und Ehre
eigentlich zueinander und wo überall schlägt sich Ungleichheit nieder,
wenn sie finanziell ausgelöst ist. Da gibt es ja noch mehrere Aspekte.
Und wir nähern uns dem aber langsam, indem wir in der aktuellen Doku von Breyer
und Friedrichs mal einer Frage nachgehen, wo sind eigentlich diese Superreichen?
Denn es wird hier ein bisschen zu einfach gemacht.
Hier irgendwo lebt die reichste Familie Deutschlands. Geschätztes Vermögen mindestens 50 Milliarden Euro.
Das ahnt man hier nun wirklich nicht. Auf der Liste der reichsten Deutschen
taucht die Familie nicht auf. Warum, sage ich Ihnen später.
So, er läuft also durch irgendeine Stadt und sagt, irgendwo hier ist die Hausnummer
der superreichen Familie, der reichsten Familie, die sich aber ansonsten bedeckt
hält und auch in der Manager Magazinliste nicht auftaucht, weil rausgeklagt und so.
Man darf ja nicht einfach so darüber reden, habe ich auch gar nichts dagegen.
Dann redet man halt nicht darüber, nur diese Frage, wo sind sie?
Die kann man gar nicht so beantworten. Wo ist ein Milliardär?
Ein Milliardär ist einfach überall. Ich habe letztens mal einen Milliardären
hier leibhaftig, er stand drei Meter neben mir gesehen und man spürt sofort,
ja dieser Typ ist halt jetzt gerade mal hier, aber wir wissen genau wo der ist,
nämlich der sucht sich einfach aus seinen 80 Wohnungen eine aus und dann ist er halt einfach dort.
Und die Frage, wie kommt er da hin? Naja, immer mit dem gleichen Transportmittel,
mit seinem Flugzeug, mit seinem Auto.
Da musst du ja nicht drüber nachdenken, der sagt einfach nur Bescheid.
Ich will da sein und dann ist er einfach da. Also die haben ja ein ganz anderes Konzept von Raum.
Die sind halt einfach irgendwo.
Die sind selber nicht so genau, wo sie eigentlich sind. Die Premium-Touristen.
Also von dem Milliardären, den ich hier gesehen habe, heißt es,
der hat einen Travel-Designer. Der sagt ihm einfach, wohin, wann und wie.
Also mit welchen Rahmenbedingungen. Ja, das wird man nicht bewältigen können.
Genau. Und dann ist er einfach ein Büro, das dafür arbeitet,
dass er dann da hinkommt, zu dem Zeitpunkt, zu dem er da hin wollte.
Also der kümmert sich gar nicht um Raum. Für den ist einfach die ganze Welt,
der ganze Globus steht einfach zur Verfügung. Grundsätzlich.
Ja, das ist wie zoomen, nur in real.
Genau.
Ja, man kann mit zoomen einfach jemanden sagen, komm, lass uns morgen chatten, egal wo du bist.
Der ist auch nie länger als eine Übernachtung unterwegs, da muss er auch niemals
umsteigen oder so, außer wenn er das Verkehrsmittel wechselt,
vom Auto ins Flugzeug und so.
Also diese Frage, wo sind sie, ist gerade auch unter dieser,
Wie besteuern wir sie jetzt? Naja, so wie man sie halt besteuert.
Die sind halt da, wo sie sind.
Und wenn man feststellt, der hat jetzt ein Haus in Berlin, muss man halt dieses
Haus in Berlin einfach mal in Berlin besteuern. Anstatt zu sagen,
naja, aber auf dem Papier ist seine Firma, die das Haus besitzt,
ja da und da. Also muss das da und da.
Da gibt es eine UG, die ist wiederum woanders hin verlagert.
Und das ist ganz gut, denn den Punkt merken wir uns jetzt nachher schon mal
für das Thema, was ist mit den Ukrainern?
Müssen die kämpfen, auch wenn sie hier leben? Die sollen nämlich nicht ortlos sein dürfen.
Die dürfen nicht irgendwo sein. Also der normale Bürger, die Palästinenser können
nicht einfach sagen, gut, dann ist jetzt gerade ungünstig hier,
ich fahre mal nach Paris in Urlaub und warte, bis es vorbei ist,
können die nicht machen.
Die Ukrainer sollen zurück, wir sollen auch natürlich immer hier schön bleiben
und bekommen nochmal einen Brief von der Steuer, wenn was nicht ganz stimmt.
Aber hier, das ist völlig ortlos.
Ja, also man muss bei der ersten Lösung, da würde ich sagen,
das ist wirklich super easy.
Wie besteuert man einen Milliardär? Naja, so wie man mich auch besteuert,
wenn ich mir eine Milch kaufe.
Ich bezahle halt meine Umsatzsteuer da, wo ich die Milch kaufe.
Ich sage dann nicht an der Kasse, sorry, ich versteuere die woanders.
Das ist völliger Quatsch.
Ich habe ein Konto in Lichtenstein, wussten Sie das nicht?
Ich besteuere meine Milch nicht hier. Das ist totaler Mumpitz.
Wenn diese Leute und die haben ganz viele Immobilien, es ist total egal,
wo die ihren Hauptwohnsitz haben oder sowas. Einfach da, wo halt Sachen anfallen,
die sie machen, einfach mal besteuern.
Dann gibt es ja zum Thema Raum dieses schöne Konzept. Es hat wohl Konjunktur.
Superjachten gehören zu den teuersten Luxussymbolen der Welt.
Sie kosten bis zu 500 Millionen Euro pro Boot.
Dafür sind sie komplette Maßanfertigungen. Das heißt, der Besitzer bekommt alles,
was er will. Den eigenen Heli an Deck.
Den selbst spielenden Flügel.
Und an der Wand im Salon ein Original. Alle Bilder an Bord sind von Peltracki.
Aber es sind keine Fälschungen, sondern es sind echte Peltrackis.
Das ist der Humor, der mir gefällt übrigens. Und einfach die Peltrackis an der Wand, die echten.
Und kauft sich ein Flügel, der selbst spielt, also Pianola.
Da merkt man auch, man möchte gern den Sound.
Ja, es ist aber nicht mehr so diese alte Hochkultur, die man noch bei Thomas
Mann finden kann, wenn da ein Unternehmer auftaucht.
Die buchen sich dann auch Pianisten, aber in dem Moment, wo man einfach nur mal kurz was hören will.
Ich habe mir das so ein bisschen, also auch noch andere Dokus angesehen,
also das große, also die wirklich superreichen sind nicht mehr.
Waren sie es mal, also wir kommen da gleich zu, ich habe dazu auch einiges zu
sagen, ich wusste aber auch, dass dich das triggert.
Denn die Frage nach, was ist eigentlich, wir sind ja nun in dem,
ich sage jetzt Vorsicht, liebes Holger, nicht erschrecken, dunklen Mittelalter,
weil ich wirklich das Stereotyp meinte, ich weiß, das Mittelalter war nicht dunkel.
Aber wir sind diesen dunklen Mittelalter sehr enteilt.
Also unter gewissen Gesichtspunkten können wir feststellen, das beste iPhone
und einmal im Monat in die Oper schafft man.
Und die Frage ist dann, wie viel mehr Lebensqualität kann man durch mehr Geld
noch erreichen? Und dann ist die Antwort relativ zügig, wenig,
denn die Sachen, auf die es ankommt, kann man sich dann doch nicht so mit Geld
kaufen, höchstens so ein bisschen fördern.
Und in der Maßgabe, finde ich sowieso, sollten wir dieses ganze Superreichen-Ding
nochmal genau betrachten.
Aber ein vernünftiger Flügel kann halt nicht selbst spielen,
deswegen kauft er da einfach irgendein Ding.
Die feinen Unterschiede, wie Bourdieu
sagen würde, sind bei dieser Milliardärsklasse nicht mehr vorhanden.
Wir kriegen jetzt hier eine Metrik, die für unsere Fragestellung,
welche Kennziffer und welche Maßstäbe brauchen wir, auch als politische Auswertung
von Jahresergebnissen.
Ganz interessant.
In der Yachtbranche merkt man, dass es immer mehr Menschen gibt,
für die ein paar Millionen Peanuts sind.
Hunderttausend neue Superjachten wurden in der letzten Saison bestellt.
Ein Viertel mehr als im Jahr davor. Und sie werden länger.
Die deutsche Werft Abeking hat gerade ein 118-Meter-Boot verkauft.
Die Zahl der Superreichen in Deutschland steigt ja auch, merken Sie das?
Ja, wir hatten früher überhaupt keine Kundschaft aus Deutschland.
Jetzt haben wir doch schon Anfragen aus Deutschland. Und die Leute wollen auch
zeigen, was sie erreicht haben im Leben.
Das sind nicht nur immer Leute, die das auch richtig für sich nutzen,
sondern auch als Aushängeschild nutzen.
Ja, das Konzept Superjacht, wenn ich mir das leisten könnte,
ich würde es ja sofort zu meinem Hauptwohnsitz machen.
Ich verstehe gar nicht, warum man nicht. Das ist doch ein komplettes Haus,
das einem dann zur freien Verfügung und man fährt halt einfach so.
Man nimmt das, das ist eigentlich interessant, wenn wir verreisen,
haben wir so Reglements, wie viel Gepäck kann man so mitnehmen,
wie viel schafft man einzutragen.
Die nehmen halt einfach alles mit. Also die reisen mit allem.
So, und wenn man hier feststellt, okay, dann sitzt das Geld irgendwie locker.
Es gibt jetzt mehr deutsche Kunden, die auch längere Yachten kaufen.
Dann muss man das politisch einpreisen.
Zum Beispiel bei der Frage, wie besteuert man jetzt solche, naja,
wenn die in den Hafen reinfahren, müssen die sich halt einen anderen Hafen suchen.
Man kann dann halt nicht mehr nach Hamburg fahren oder nach Bremen oder an deutsche
Küsten, wenn man sich das nicht leisten kann.
Das ist ein bisschen wie Autofahren in Singapur. Das Auto kostet 50.000 Euro,
aber die Lizenz, Auto zu fahren, eben auch.
Und wenn man sich das nicht leisten
kann, ja gut, dann kann man halt nicht Autofahren. Ja, so ungefähr.
Da muss man ein bisschen durchgreifen, denn hier scheint ja sehr viel Geld abgreifbar zu sein.
Also bei der Frage Kindergrundsicherung, zwei Milliarden oder Yachten,
das Geld einfach liegen lassen, die Leute dürfen hier kostenlos anlanden und so.
Nö, einfach mal zukraft. Ja, kannst du überall rumfahren. Jetzt kommt Herr Wild,
einer der Protagonisten.
Es ist ja wirklich dramatisch, ihn so zu sehen und zu hören.
Man sieht ihn ja auch nur alleine.
Er ist jetzt nicht so, dass er da so eine Entourage dabei hat.
Wahrscheinlich hat er das so extra getimt, dass man ihn da allein sieht.
Wir hören ja mal, wie viel er so besitzt, wo und überhaupt.
Milliardär Hans-Peter Wild ist nach langem Zögern bereit, uns mitzunehmen.
Wir fliegen nach Paris, zum Profi-Rugby-Club Stade Francais,
den sich Wild gekauft hat.
An Bord nicht nur Chef-Stewardess Monique, sondern auch das Trinktütchen,
das ihn reich gemacht hat.
Und das Trinktütchen ist Capri-Sonne.
Also, die Capri-Sonne. Ich habe einmal zu meiner FAZ-Zeit, ich habe es glaube
ich ein paar Mal erzählt, eine Pressreise mitgemacht.
Wo also Reiseveranstalter...
Ich dachte, jetzt kommt einmal eine Capri-Sonne getroffen.
Macht und saß dann also, weil das sind ja dann so hochpreisige Reisen,
man sitzt dann so im Fünf-Sterne-Hotel in den Alpen irgendwie und wartet so
auf seine Spa-Anwendung in so einem Foyer-artigen, so.
Und da sitzen sie nun, die Millionäre, die dann erzählen, womit sie so reich geworden sind.
Und dann sagen die, während man selber so, ey geil, ich bin im Föta,
was schreibe ich morgen, was ist hier, da und überhaupt und so.
Und dann reden die plötzlich über Kiesgrube.
Und zwar stundenlang.
Ja.
Und das ist auch das ganze Leben, die Kiesgrube.
Und ich will jetzt es ausdrücklich ganz despektierlich sagen,
im Sinne vor, ich saß da als Armer Fötonist und hab plötzlich festgestellt,
wie erfüllt und reichhaltig eigentlich mein Leben ist, während die einfach nur eine Kiesgrube haben.
Und es tat mir auch ein bisschen leid. Und ich meine das genau so.
Da steckt dann auch nichts dahinter oder so.
Diese Leute werden einfach mit,
wie soll man sagen, sagen, wirklich nicht erfüllenden Sachen, super reich.
Die Capri-Sonne ist eine kleine Alu-Verpackung, in die man oben einen Strohhalm reinsteckt.
Und das ist seit 40 Jahren, da kam keine bessere Idee dazu oder sonstiges.
Der Typ hat einfach nur ein bisschen Erfolg gehabt mit dem Marketing,
also hat die richtigen Leute angestellt, die da irgendwie die Märkte erobern
und wie auch immer sowas dann funktioniert.
Aber es ist einfach nur, das ist das ganze Leben, die Capri-Sonne.
Ja, ein zuckersüßes Getränk.
Ich kann mich gar nicht erinnern, es mal getrunken zu haben,
wahrscheinlich als wirklich ganz, ganz kleines Kind mal.
Aber etwas, was du da jetzt gerade ausführst, findet sich pointiert bei Arthur
Schnitzler in seinem Stück Weites Land.
Und zwar ist dort ein Schriftsteller, der ja auch hadert mit seiner Existenz
und über sich nachdenkt und die Welt, aber doch etwas Kreatives schafft.
Und dann taucht ein Fabrikant auf, auch ein Millionär.
Und der sitzt dann diesem Schriftsteller wie ein Größeres gegenüber und sagt,
ja, Sie als Schriftsteller, Sie haben ja Ihre Leidenschaften und Ihre Mängel,
die Sie spüren und führt das aus und so weiter.
Und dann sagt der Schriftsteller irgendwann zu ihm, und wissen Sie, was Sie sind?
Ein Glühbirnenfabrikant. Ein Fabrikant von Glühbirnen. Nichts weiter.
Und das ist eigentlich die richtige Aussage dazu.
Diese Leute tun so, als hätten sie unglaubliche Erfindungen gemacht,
als seien sie Da Vinci und Michelangelo in einer Person.
Und ja, sie haben Glück gehabt, dass sich dieses Tütchen mit diesem sehr süßen
Getränk wahnsinnig gut verkauft und der Rest geht ja dann quasi von selbst. Genau.
Wir reden ja jetzt in diesen modernen Internetzeiten, wo man alle nur noch mit
so einer ganz immateriellen Idee, also man braucht noch einen Server,
auf der das alles läuft, aber im Grunde ist alles nur noch Software.
Und dann sagt man immer, ja, so richtig große Erfolge werden dann einfach skaliert.
Also Amazon.com, Jeff Bezos verkauft Bücher.
Und der Unterschied ist dann einfach nur noch, verkauft er Bücher an 100 Leute
oder an 100 Millionen Leute.
Dazwischen liegt aber für ihn selbst kein Unterschied. Also er merkt das gar
nicht. Er sitzt halt in seinem Büro und macht irgendwas. Und es wird nun alles
nur noch auf Zahlen abgebildet.
Und wir bräuchten eigentlich mal auch für junge FDP-Wähler, die immer glauben,
naja, ich bin ja noch jung und irgendwann werde ich aber dann einen großen Erfolg
haben, also einen großen finanziellen Erfolg.
Und dann stellen sie irgendwann fest, ich bin jetzt schon älter als die Fußballer,
jetzt bin ich schon älter als die Fußballtrainer, es wird ja offenbar nichts
mehr, ich bin enttäuscht.
So geil, dass dieser finanzielle Erfolg wie soll man sagen indirekt korreliert mit der.
Die ansprüchen und bedarfen an eigener Kreativität.
Also in der Soziologie dieser beliebte Spruch, ich habe ihn schon häufiger genannt,
Freundschaftsdienste oder Geld ausgeben.
Also wer keine Freunde hat, braucht Geld. Und wer Geld hat, braucht keine Freunde.
Wer so viel Geld hat wie diese Leute hier.
Muss wirklich etwas dafür tun, noch herausgefordert zu werden,
weil die umgeben sind von so einer Entourage, die ihnen entweder,
weil sie direkt dafür angestellt werden, ihnen die Sachen zu machen oder wie auch immer.
Wenn man einen Travel-Designer hat, sind die Reisen eigentlich fast nichts wert,
weil man kommt halt irgendwo an, aber auch wenn es jetzt ganz albern klingt,
aber diese ganz profane,
ich organisiere jetzt mal eine Reise und springe dann über eine Hürde,
die mir echt Kreativität abverlangt, weil ich kann es mir nicht einfach kaufen.
So, das kennt jeder aus der Grundschule, wenn die Lehrer sagen,
wir basteln jetzt, in der Kreativität sind keine Grenzen gesetzt.
Und man fragt sich, hä, aber wozu brauche ich denn Kreativität,
wenn ich keine Grenzen habe?
Also nur weil ich Grenzen habe, brauche ich Kreativität. Und wenn man so viel
Geld hat, dass man keine Grenzen mehr hat, dann schleicht auch die Kreativität
so langsam aus dem Leben aus, weil dann macht man nämlich morgens einfach auf,
sagt fünf Befehle und das ist wirklich sehr verlockend.
Also ich stelle das selber an mir fest, wenn ich bei Veranstaltungen bin und
plötzlich so ungewöhnterweise wird alles für mich geregelt.
Also ich sage einfach, was ich zu essen haben will und dann kriege ich halt
ein Essen. Statt dann zu überlegen, ah ja, dann bin ich dann da,
dann gehe ich aber vorher noch da was essen, was gibt es denn eigentlich?
Und dann gehe ich so Google Maps durch und durchsuche das Stadtviertel und wie
auch immer, solche Sachen.
Also man, diese Art von bequemem Leben kann relativ zügig dahin führen, dass man...
Es ist nicht ohne Grund, dass jemand wie Kurt Krömer als Multimillionär und
eigentlich im Zentrum der Aufmerksamkeit Depressionserfahrung hat.
Da gibt es so eine Korrelation, die muss man sich nochmal genau anschauen.
Wenn man zu wenig, wenn man zu viel Handlungsvermögen hat, scheint einen das
irgendwie zu begrenzen.
Und als ich dieses Bild hier sah, also wir sehen ja in dieser Doku einfach dieses riesige Flugzeug.
Er sitzt da so ganz alleine drin
und fliegt einfach mit so einer riesigen Passagiermaschine durch die Welt.
Und dann auf dem Tisch eine Capri-Sonne mit dem Strohhalm drin und nochmal so
eine Designer-Sonnenbrille davor gelegt, damit es nicht ganz verloren wirkt.
Aber es wirkt schon wahnsinnig verloren.
Ja.
Und diese Capri-Sonne hat dann noch so ein quatschiges, wahrscheinlich ist das
Design der Capri-Sonne, die Augen als zwei Herzen und dann so einen strahlenden Mund,
hat ihm wahrscheinlich noch eine Milliarde mehr eingebracht,
aber er sollte vielleicht mal mehr Kontakt zu Menschen haben,
die, keine Ahnung, diese Kindergeburtstage feiern, für die man so eine Capri-Sonne dann kauft.
Ich glaube, das Sinnstiftende geht ja völlig verloren, denn wenn man irgendetwas
Sinnstiftendes im Leben hat, würde man ja nicht auf die Idee kommen,
also was mich jetzt mal glücklich macht, ist eine Yacht mit einem Helikopter
und einem U-Boot noch unten dran,
damit ich dort fünf Tage im Jahr mal sitzen kann in der Sonne.
Also das ist ja kein Gedanke, dem man jetzt so nachhängt.
Wenn man seinem Leben hier so folgt, wie das dargestellt wird,
stellt man auch fest, der Maßstab dafür ist einfach,
Grenzen des Handlungsvermögens. Also was kann man für Geld kaufen und sonst niemand?
Und dann kommt man eben auf ein Flugzeug, ein Boot und dann zwei Adressen,
sodass man zwischen diesen zwei hin und her pendeln kann. Und das war's.
Und gleichzeitig sieht man ihn da so ganz verloren in dem Flugzeug und mit seiner Capri-Sonne.
Dass er diese Verpackung einfach immer dabei hat. Seine Chef-Stewardess und diese Capri-Sonne.
Und dann hat er sich jetzt einen Sportverein gekauft, damit er auch mal so ein
bisschen Kontakt hat zu Genau.
Der ist aber in Paris. Die sprechen dort Französisch. Er kommt da hin,
motiviert dann nochmal auf Englisch irgendwie vorm Spiel.
Er geht halt hoch auf die Loge und schaut sich das an. Also es ist,
wir hören mal, wie er in Paris dann anlandet.
Wenn Hans-Peter Wild in der Stadt ist, übernachtet er meist hier. Im Le Bristoll.
Ein Hotel, das übrigens der deutschen Milliardärsfamilie Oetker gehört.
Wild empfängt uns zum Interview in seiner Suite.
Er bekommt hier einen Sonderpreis.
Regulär kostet die Suite an diesem Wochenende 17.000 Euro pro Nacht.
Und zwar, man glaubt es kaum, ohne Frühstück. Das wird extra berechnet.
17.000.
Euro. Das wird natürlich extra berechnet, weil es keinen Sinn macht.
17.000 Euro für ein Hotelzimmer macht einfach keinen Sinn. Du hast dann 17 Räume,
in die gehst du eh nicht rein. Also, ähm,
Umso mehr Geld man so, man verliert dann diese Gemütszustandsregulierungsmaßeinheit.
Ja, der ist eine Nacht in Paris, der kann ja gar nicht jetzt sagen wir mal ein
Zimmer nehmen für 500 Euro.
Das wäre ja auch schon sehr sehr viel, aber dann würde er jetzt als Milliardär in einem Zimmer wohnen.
Das braucht er eigentlich nur für diese eine Nacht, ist aber gar nicht machbar.
Also muss er diese 17 Zimmer anbieten, weil er Milliardär ist.
Das sind dann die Sachzwänge.
Ja, also für die Milliardäre habe ich jetzt festgestellt, für die Superreichen
gilt ein bisschen wie das, was für die Alten gilt.
Man muss sich zuallererst fragen, in welchem sozialen Kontext,
bevor man Fragen klärt wie wo, was, wann und so. Erstmal muss geklärt werden, mit wem.
Es macht keinen Sinn für 17.000 Euro zu sein, weil das ein Spiel hat,
die eigene Mannschaft nach Paris zu fliegen und dann aber den Tag alleine zu verbringen.
Vielleicht nochmal mit einem Journalisten, der vorbeikommt.
Also das ist irgendwie das, keine
Ahnung, es wirkt jedenfalls nicht sehr erstrebenswert, das so zu sehen.
Aber unter dieser ganzen Frage, wo sind Milliardäre, dieser Raum,
dass man einfach, es steht einfach alles zur Verfügung.
Der Typ kommt mit seinem Privatjet nach Paris, steigt dort direkt aus dem Flugzeug
die Treppe runter ins Auto ein und ist eine halbe Stunde später im Hotel.
So, das finden wir natürlich alle mega erstrebenswert. Nur wenn in dem Hotelzimmer
niemand ist, der auf einen wartet, kann man auch eine Stunde später da hinkommen.
So ungefähr wäre die Lebenslosung dann.
Der Wild äußert sich hier selbst mal zum Thema Politikraum superreich sein.
Was sagen Sie denen, die finden, dass sie vielleicht wegen der Steuer Deutschland
verlassen haben und dass das doch nicht solidarisch gegenüber Deutschland ist?
Das möchte ich ja nicht rechtfertigen.
Wir haben eine große Wahl, die wir immer machen können, mit unseren Füßen.
Dahin gehen, wo es uns gefällt.
Aus unseren Daten wissen wir, mehr als jeder Zehnte der deutschen Milliardäre
hat bisher mit den Füßen gegen die Steuergesetze abgestimmt und das Land verlassen.
Die Leute haben das Land nicht verlassen, ganz wichtig. Die sind einfach sowieso überall.
Aber haben den Ort, wo sie Steuern zahlen müssen, geändert. Das ist die Abstimmung mit den Füßen.
Und wie gesagt, diese Doku läuft, Während wir zugleich eine Debatte darüber haben,
dürfen die Ukrainer mit den Füßen abstimmen und hier leben oder sollen die mal
gefälligst an der Front sterben und müssen wir auch mal kriegstüchtig werden,
damit wir unserem Land was zurückgeben.
Also bitte nicht abhauen, du bist ein Mann, du kannst kämpfen,
du darfst nicht mit den Füßen abstimmen.
Und er chattet hier rum und wird wahrscheinlich Deutschland auch nicht mitverteidigen.
Vermutlich nicht, da wird er auch was anderes vorhaben.
Zum Thema Raum in Berlin.
Aber der wird bestimmt so eine Capri-Sonnen-Spende dann an die Freunde schicken.
Ja, genau. Der wird für Belustigung sorgen. In Berlin gibt es ein China Club.
Es ist völlig egal, wo Sie Ihren Hauptwohnsitz haben. Sie sind eh überall.
Ich kann es nicht häufiger betonen.
Außer man will mal was von der Politik. Dann ist man nämlich einfach ganz nah
dran. Im Sinne von einfach nah.
Hier, das ist normalerweise mein zweites Zuhause, wo ich immer bin.
Das ist mein Lieblingsraum.
Wie oft waren Sie schon hier im China Club? Ca.
3.000 Mal. 3.000 Mal?
Bis zum Regierungsviertel sind es nur ein paar Meter.
Das macht den China Club so attraktiv für die Elite aus Politik und Wirtschaft,
wie es immer wieder heißt.
Die sich den Rückzugsort einiges kosten lässt.
10.000 Euro Aufnahmegebühr. Dazu 2.500 Euro Jahresbeitrag.
Plus Kosten für Speisen und Getränke. Können Sie einen Karottensaft bitte bringen,
Das ist schon alles im Tisch eigentlich.
Dann zeigen Sie mir, wo der Karottensaft ist. Ich sehe keinen. Sehen Sie den?
Nee, da haben Sie tatsächlich recht.
Man muss schon ganz schön vermögend sein, um hier immer wieder herzukommen, oder?
Ja, also sagen wir mal, mit Bürgergeld wahrscheinlich nicht zu finanzieren oder
bestimmt nicht zu finanzieren, ja.
Ja, da wird das Personal nochmal zurechtgewiesen, wenn der Karottensaft nicht da ist.
Ja, das Personal ist aber auch das einzige Anwesen der menschlichen Biomasse in dieser Doku da.
Klar, die sind natürlich dann hier, das sind so Drehsituationen und so,
aber das ist auch ein bisschen traurig zu sehen.
Das ist wirklich, es ist kurz vor Altenrepublik, du bist in Suhl,
da wohnt jemand noch in seinem, aber das ist doch mein Eigentum,
das verlasse ich doch nicht und stirbt dann einfach zehn Jahre lang so einen
ganz einsamen Tod vor sich hin.
Hauptsache man hat an den ökonomischen Grundlagen seines Lebens nichts geändert
oder irgendwie und so weiter. Alle wichtigen Fragen werden einfach so ausgeblendet.
Und dieser Rainer Zittmann, da haben wir sogar mal bei Wohlstand für alle eine
Folge zu dem gemacht, der ist ja gut vernetzt mit der FDP.
Ja, so sieht der auch aus. Was macht er? Wo hat er sein Geld her?
So Coaching und der hat auch so Vermögensberatung für Vermögens und der hat
dann mit dem Thomas Sattelberger da von der FDP auf Twitter,
merkt man da ist so ein Austausch da, also ja, das sind wirklich diese Die kümmern
sich ihr ganzes Leben lang nur ums Geld.
Obwohl sie es eigentlich nicht müssten.
Ja, was sollen sie sonst machen? Die werden ja nicht in die Oper abends gehen.
Hier nochmal Wild und das, also das was wir von Wild hier sehen Thomas Sattelberger
war doch der, der diese FDP Politiker, der dort stand und dann aus voller Brust
bei TikTok Laila gesungen hat.
Um nochmal zu zeigen, wie patriotisch...
Ich lass mir meine Kultur nicht nehmen.
Also den wirst du heute Abend nicht in AIDA treffen.
Oh wei, oh wei, oh wei. Dieser Clip, den wir jetzt von Thomas,
wie heißt der Thomas, also Herrn Wild sehen, dem Capri-Sonnen-Chef,
Der hat schon seine Runde so gemacht und der hat aber nochmal eine besondere
Einbettung, weil er ist wirklich das Finale von dieser ganzen Doku,
also die letzten zehn Sekunden werden diesem Ding gewidmet und man hat ihn vorher
schon da in Paris und dann sitzt er irgendwie da und die größte Lebensentscheidung
ist noch die Farbe der Trikots von seiner Mannschaft und dann ist er irgendwie
unzufrieden und dann sagt ihm der Typ vom Team,
Ja, das kann auch am Drucker liegen, dass das gerade nicht so richtig wirkt.
Eigentlich gefällt ihnen das schon.
Sie haben immer eine andere Ausrede.
Ja, ja, genau. Also man sieht das so und denkt sich, Leute, habt doch jetzt mal Spaß.
Sie sind alle so verkrampft und irgendwie.
Und dann ist das ja auch immer in tausend Sprachen, weil da sitzen Franzosen,
die müssen mit ihm auf Englisch reden und so.
Also es fühlt sich alles nicht sehr gut an. Und dann sitzt er am Ende in seinem Flugzeug da.
Wo geht es jetzt als nächstes für Sie hin? Ich fliege jetzt aufs Boot. Auf ihrer Yacht? Ja.
Haben Sie manchmal auch ein schlechtes Gewissen? Hier zum Beispiel sind wir
ja im Privatjet. Ja, hätten wir das zu Fuß gehen sollen?
Das ist die Alternative. Wir hätten wieder Bahn fahren können.
Fahrrad. Was hätten wir denn machen sollen?
Ja. Wie zur Yacht kommen.
Ja, wie zur Yacht kommen. Ich habe jetzt so ein Bild vor Augen.
Man sitzt auf dieser Yacht.
Man hat sie sich verdient, man will das auch niemand anderem gönnen,
also man ist da irgendwie so alleine, allenfalls mit der Familie.
Und dann ist sie ja an irgendeinem Urlaubsort und dann sieht man vor sich auf
der Promenade entlanglaufen Leute, die sich nur einmal im Jahr so einen Urlaub
leisten können, die also dann da sind und sagen, ey cool, von hier sieht man
ja zumindest mal von außen diese Erachten.
Und du hast dann da so eine Gruppe, irgendwie so ein Abijahrgang oder so und
du siehst, die haben richtig Spaß.
Du bist selber aber 60 Jahre älter und hast gerade nicht so viel Spaß und bist auch ziemlich allein.
So, und eigentlich ist doch dieser Benjamin Button, dieses Szenario,
jemand verkauft seine Seele um nochmal und so weiter, das scheint mir,
also darauf scheinen diese Leben immer hinaus zu laufen.
Ja, ich glaube, das ist sehr stark so.
Du hast alle Annehmlichkeiten, die du soweit erkaufst, es ist nur noch eine Annehmlichkeit,
was unerreichbar für dich ist und das ist diese Gebrechlichkeit,
ja, so, Jugendhaftigkeit,
die kannst du dir nicht kaufen und ich, man sieht es ihm ja so ein bisschen
an, darunter leidet man dann sein restliches Leben, statt einfach mal ein Leben
so anzunehmen, also es war hier durch die Bank,
ich weiß nicht, wir klingen jetzt wahrscheinlich sehr, also gerne mit,
ihr seid ja nur neidisch und so weiter, ja, da habe ich gar keine Lust,
das abzuwehren, nur ich glaube, man weiß, was ich meine.
Ja, ja. Also das ist ein Leben, das nicht erstrebenswerter aussieht.
Also das ist tatsächlich so. Also gewisse Vorzüge sind mir, also habe ich auch
in meinen Vorstellungen nicht die Yacht oder so.
Also ich fände es jetzt auch angenehm, ich würde manchmal irgendwo hingefahren
werden und müsste es nicht über die deutsche Bahn regeln.
Ich war ja in Oslo, bin nach Oslo geflogen.
Und das war auch ganz interessant, weil in Oslo hat jetzt auch kein Chauffeur auf mich gewartet.
Aber das ist ja ein Land, in dem vieles sehr viel besser läuft,
auch weil da hohe Steuern gezahlt werden.
Und dann sagt man mir, ja, der Flughafen ist 50 Kilometer außerhalb von der Innenstadt.
Und da sagte ich, oh, wie komme ich denn da hin? Ja, einfach mit dem Schnellzug.
Dieser Schnellzug fährt alle zehn Minuten und braucht 18 Minuten.
Und dann ist man in der Innenstadt mittendrin und man kann, wenn man zurückfährt
mit diesem Schnellzug, wenn man zurückfährt zum Flughafen, dann kann man schon
in diesem Zug einchecken, also schon mit dem Einchecken beginnen.
Das heißt, da sieht man, jetzt würde mich der Chauffeur auch nicht schneller
dahin bringen, das heißt also, wo das tatsächlich ins Gesellschaftliche verlagert
wurde, also wie schafft man sich ein gutes Leben,
profitieren so unglaublich viel mehr Leute davon und es ist sogar noch schneller,
als ein Auto fahren könnte diese Strecke, weil es dieser Schnellzug ist,
der geradewegs durchgeht.
Ich fahre aber von Berlin ab, bin in einem Hotel in Berlin-Mitte,
weil ich da im Brechthaus war.
Und ich musste früh am Flughafen sein, da sagte man mir, ja,
ich könnte mit der Bimmelbahn fahren, dann fährt man da 45, 50 Minuten hin.
Also bin ich mit dem Taxi zum Flughafen gefahren, das so teuer war wie mein
Flug nach Oslo. Und da merkt man einfach, wie wenig dann wieder da funktioniert.
Es ist genau das, was sich ändern müsste.
Aber ja, das Thema Fliegen machen wir nochmal ein andermal, da habe ich auch
nochmal eigene Thesen zu, aber da zeigt sich dann auch, wie ist eigentlich das Leben so.
Und wenn ich das dann in Oslo sehe, also wie das dann auch dort so am Abend,
wie dort die Auskriegskultur ist, dann fand ich das jetzt sehr, sehr angenehm.
Ja, also ein erfülltes Leben, glaube ich, führt man dann, wenn es egal ist,
ob man mit seinen Freunden gerade in so einer Bar ist, wo es die Cocktails für
sieben Euro gibt oder auf einem Boot.
Also wenn es einfach fast keinen Unterschied macht, außer dass nochmal die Kulisse
des Fotos so anders wirkt natürlich auf die Leute, die es dann sehen.
Aber wenn das keinen Unterschied macht.
Und den Herrn Wild in dieser Doku zu sehen, ohne jemals mit irgendwem,
der nicht gerade von ihm bezahlt wird, seine Chefstewardess,
sein Rugby-Team oder was auch immer, nicht Rugby-Dings, Cricket,
sondern ihn nur zu sehen von unfassbar teurem Kram.
Ist wirklich die Programmierung auf ganz große Unzufriedenheit, würde ich sagen.
Nun gut, jetzt hat das alles mit uns zu tun und da wird es natürlich dramatisch.
Wir gucken eine andere Doku, die diskrete Welt der Superreichen.
Steffen Klusmann seinerzeit, ich glaube die Doku ist so 2018,
2019, auch AD-Material, war damals Chef des Manager Magazin,
heute leitet er ja den Spiegel und er macht so eine kleine Anmerkung nur.
Also gerade in Großstadtimmobilien, in Metropolen sind die Preise in den letzten
zehn Jahren dermaßen explodiert.
Da haben ja viele Leute ihr Immobilienvermögen mehr als verdoppelt.
Und wenn man da dann mit fünf Milliarden gestartet ist, dann sind es halt heute mal gerne zehn oder 15.
So, also du hast eine gute Idee, Capri-Sonne. Dann hast du plötzlich Geld.
Er sagt ja so, ich wollte 150 Millionen Cash haben.
Also hat das irgendwie so organisiert, dass es aus dem Unternehmen das rausfloss.
Das bedeutet für ihn, naja, das gibt man nicht aus, das investiert man.
Wie? So, dass sie es verdoppelt. Klusmann sagt Immobilien, also Immobilien.
Unsere Wohnungsnot ist direkt verkoppelt.
Das ist jetzt hier ein klassischer Steffen-Mauscher-Triggerpunkt, wie schon angemerkt.
Deren Vermögen ist über unsere Wohnpreise mit uns verkoppelt. Eins zu eins.
Selbst wenn wir sagen, mein Vermieter wohnt auch unten, der gehört da nicht dazu.
Stimmt, aber in Städten wie Berlin, falls ihr in Berlin zuhört,
80% der Leute mieten, sind ungefähr zweieinhalb Millionen Menschen.
Und es gibt eigentlich nur 3000 namhafte Mieter.
Ja, es gibt auch Kleinscheiß, aber Vermieter.
Berlin wird von 3000 Leuten vermietet.
Die kleinen Vermieter, die darunter wohnen unter einem, die profitieren ja davon auch.
Also die profitieren ja von diesem Anstieg der Mieten ganz genauso.
Die werden so ein bisschen mitgeschliffen, genau, da hat es sich ja genauso
verdoppelt. Ich fliege heute Morgen im Bett und denke, ich höre mal einen Podcast,
stelle fest, es ist Weihnachten, niemand macht gerade Podcasts.
Also gehe ich in Apples Podcasts App, ich reproduziere das gerade mal, ob das immer noch so ist,
gehe im Reiter unten auf Entdecken, sehe oben unsere Lieblingspodcast 2023 von
Apple selbst ausgewählt,
ganz links oben Teurer Wohnen.
Ja, das war ein sehr guter Podcast.
Sechs Etappen oder so von Decoder-Dings. Ist es Decoder? Decoder FM?
Detektor FM, so heißen sie. Decoder ist ja das, die uns die Russen übersetzen.
Also, Detektor FM. Ich spiele nur einen so kleinen Clip und wir steigen ein
ins Thema Erben und Ehre.
Denn jetzt kommen wir zu den richtigen Fehlspezifikationen.
Eben mit dem Raum, das war ja nur so nebensächlich. Also, Teurer Wohnen, Ausgabe 2.
Also sie reden mit so einem Typen, der die Wohnungen hermacht für Leute,
die dann für 22.000 Euro den Quadratmeter, also 100 Quadratmeter,
zweieinhalb Millionen Euro in Berlin Wohnungen kaufen.
Und wenn die Leute dann zucken, weißt du, das ist nicht das Richtige.
Okay, was sind das für Leute, die nicht zucken, wenn sie zwei Millionen Cash
auf den Tisch legen sollen?
Fast alle unsere Kunden, die solche Immobilien kaufen, sind Unternehmer.
Das sind keine Leute, wo Mama und Papa sagen, hier hast du mal eine Million.
Das sind Leute, die haben sich das selbst verdient, die haben das erarbeitet.
Es gibt ganz wenig Fälle, wo jemand sagt, ich habe das Geld geerbt,
ich habe es geschenkt bekommen, ich habe es auf der Straße gefunden,
ich habe ein Lotto gewonnen. Das gibt es einfach kaum.
Hm. In Deutschland wird auch einiges vererbt.
Das Deutsche Institut für Wirtschaftsforschung schätzt jedes Jahr rund 400 Milliarden.
Natürlich landet davon auch einiges in Immobilien. Aber diese UnternehmerInnen,
von denen Achim Ammann spricht, die habe ich ja auch im Grundbuch gefunden.
Also die, die an der Ecke Wieland-Pestalozzi kaufen, da sind bestimmt einige
dabei, die in ihren Jobs ordentlich Geld verdienen.
Aber einige sind ja auch noch sehr jung. 24, 23, die jüngste ist erst 21 Jahre alt.
Ob die wirklich schon so viel verdient haben?
So, können wir lösen. Mit Pranko Milanovic, der hat ja dieses Buch geschrieben,
Kapitalismus global und einige andere Bücher über Ungleichheit.
Und er sagt, ja, es gibt einen Unterschied zum 19. Jahrhundert. Im 19.
Jahrhundert waren die Superreichen fast alle nur Rentiers. Das heißt,
die haben einfach nur eingenommen.
Von Pachtzinsen angefangen bis hin zu Handel. Die haben selbst nie gearbeitet.
Die neuen Superreichen arbeiten auch, aber die haben in der Regel Geld im Hintergrund gehabt.
Eine unglaubliche Anschubfinanzierung.
Und diese konnten sie dann extrem skalieren. Warren Buffett beispielsweise hat
einen Vater gehabt, der war Senator, der hatte ein Unternehmen, der hatte also Geld.
Verglichen mit dem, was Warren Buffett heute hat, hat er natürlich wenig gehabt,
aber Warren Buffett konnte da also sehr, sehr einfach auf einem hohen Niveau
anfangen und konnte das dann vervielfachen.
Im Übrigen auch in anderen Bereichen, Karl Lagerfeld ist der Sohn eines Kondensmilchfabrikanten,
da war immer klar, wenn er Geld braucht, es ist vorhanden, er kann nach Paris gehen,
er bekommt auch noch den neuesten Mercedes dazu und eine Wohnung und einen Chauffeur,
all das ist möglich und dann kannst du dein Business auch noch weiter skalieren.
Das heißt also, wir haben es bei den Superreichen mit Leuten zu tun,
die auch arbeiten, weil, so Branko Milanovic, ich glaube das ist sehr eindeutig,
weil das Arbeiten auch mit zum Lifestyle gehört, was sollte man sonst auch machen.
Also man fliegt hin und her, hat Business-Meetings, aber natürlich erwirtschaftet man ja nicht,
also das muss ich ja glaube ich nicht eigens betonen, diese Beträge,
sondern andere arbeiten für einen, erwirtschaften diese Beträge und man selbst
koordiniert dann noch so ein bisschen rum und sagt,
ja ich arbeite 80 Stunden die Woche, sagen die dann immer.
Und dann sage ich, ja kann ja sein, aber warum ergibt das ein paar Milliarden?
Ja, der Typ ist jetzt so ein typischer Gentrifizierer, der also Häuser kauft,
alte Vermieter raus, dann wird irgendwie nur halb so viele Wohnungen,
damit sie größer sind und so weiter.
Und dann hat man das fertig. Und dann steht er so da und sagt,
nee, das ist alles, ich verkaufe nur an ehrbare Kaufleute sozusagen. zu sagen.
So, und man kann ihn einfach statistisch schachmatzetzen.
Mit 3.800 Euro netto im Monat verfügbaren Nettoeinkommen gehört man in Deutschland zur Top 10.
Mit 7.800 zu Top 1%.
So.
Wenn jetzt ihm, also wenn er sagt, für mich ist maßgeblich, wie die Leute reagieren,
wenn ich ihnen sage, die Wohnung kostet zwei Millionen Euro,
dann ist einfach völlig klar, er verkauft nicht an die 99,9 Prozent.
Kann er gar nicht. Weil das Arbeitseinkommen, im Sinne von, wie er meinte,
der hat sich das selbst erarbeitet, reicht einfach nicht für niemanden.
Man braucht Vermögen. Aus dem Einkommen allein kann man solche Wohnungen gar nicht kaufen.
Man braucht Vermögen. Und wenn die Käufer 21, 23, 24 Jahre alt sind,
dann haben sie es nicht erarbeitet.
Kann nicht sein. So.
Ist einfach faktisch ausgeschlossen. Warum?
Werden ja nicht alles Topmodels sein.
Genau. Warum sagt er das trotzdem so?
Ja.
Wir wissen ja wahrscheinlich sehr genau, er wird die Leute nicht danach fragen,
wo das Geld herkommt. Er will es einfach nur haben.
Er kann sich das also schönreden, er weiß es nicht besser.
Aber wo kommt die Motivation her, sich bewusst nicht einzugestehen und das auch
noch vor laufender Kamera sozusagen,
also eingeschaltetem Mikrofon, so felsenfest zu behaupten, ich arbeite nur für
ehrbare Leute, die hier nicht, mein Onkel hat die Capri-Sonne erfunden oder sowas.
Wie kommt es zustande? Und das war auch in diesen Dokus schön zu sehen,
wenn wir jetzt versuchen, da so einen roten Faden rauszuleiern,
wie man einfach sich das selbst einredet,
statt ein Erbe zu sein, ein ehrbarer Arbeiter zu sein.
Also da gab es einige Beispiele. Wir hören hier mal fast wahllos rein.
Also was wir jetzt hier so sehen und miterleben, ist ja nur ein kleiner Teil
ihres Lebens. Sie sind Erbe, sie sind Unternehmer.
Ich kann nicht nur sagen, das Erbe,
ist da. Sonst hätte ich einen guten Start ins Leben.
Der Typ redet gerade über ein Erbe aus dem Bankvermögen Saal-Oppenheim.
Damals größte Bank des Landes und so. In der seine Familie Eigentum,
Besitz hatte. Die besaß diese Bank.
Das spielt für ihn so wenig eine Rolle.
Verglichen mit dem, was er heute hat, sagt er. Da hat man auch mal klein angefangen.
Da wütend auf den Tisch. Das spielt gar keine Rolle.
Aber das ist nicht das, was ich im Leben verdient habe, nicht mal ein Archiveau,
das habe ich alles selber verdient.
Woran machen Sie es denn fest, dass Sie mit den Dingen, die Sie anpacken, Erfolg haben?
Wenn ich was mache, rechne ich mir schon aus, dass man scheitern kann.
Jeder kann scheitern, das ist doch nicht so schlimm.
Aber letztendlich, das Gleiche mit dem Restaurant, das wird zum Erfolg hier.
Vorher hören wir nicht auf. Ja, das wird hier zum Erfolg.
Ja, da sollte doch Thomas Pscher einfach mal einen Ratgeber schreiben.
Fest dran glauben, manifestieren. Wir haben im Live-Send-Out drüber gesprochen.
Und dann wird es schon so sein, dass da natürlich alle Möglichkeiten im Hintergrund
sind, mit dem besten Koch zu arbeiten in dem Restaurant und, und, und.
Alle Kontakte zur Stadtpolitik da sind, um sowas groß aufzuziehen.
Naja, das ist was anderes. Aber wenn man fest will, dann wird es schon.
Ich meine, wenn ihr sagt, scheitern kann jeder. Das stimmt ja nicht.
Und auch die Frage, was ist das Maß für Scheitern?
Leute sind in Deutschland so arm, dass es für sie schon als Scheitern gilt,
die 3,80 Euro, die sie brauchen, um mit einer öffentlichen Straßenbahn zu fahren, nicht zu haben. Ja.
Also Helene Steinhaus hatte letztens so ein Tweet, die twittert ja immer aus
ihrem Sankt-Sohns-Frei-Kosmos.
Dingsda-Booms wohnt an der Nordsee, will auch mit ihrem Hund immer mal hinfahren.
Man denkt sich so, oh cool, die wohnt an der Nordsee.
Aber die 2,80 Euro für die Straßenbahn sind zu teuer.
Sie kommt also gar nicht so. Auf diesem Niveau scheitert man bereits,
wenn man beispielsweise die 2,80 Euro mal hat und dann findet man sie aber morgens
nicht, weil man hat sie irgendwie verlegt oder keine Ahnung oder man muss was
anderes, dringenderes dafür kaufen.
So, dann, also auf der Ebene ist das dann schon so ein persönliches Scheitern.
Mein Ziel für heute ging nicht auf.
Für ihn ist Scheitern, naja, ich habe jetzt 5 Millionen über 5 Jahre in dieses
Restaurant gesteckt und es macht immer noch keinen Gewinn.
Aber ich habe ja noch 500 Millionen weitere, also mache ich einfach weiter.
Das ist für ihn so, wir scheitern hier nicht.
Ich weiß, was scheitern ist, nämlich wenn ich jetzt sage, ich mache das Restaurant
wieder zu, nur er kann es mit einer grünen Null über unendlich lange finanzieren.
Also es gibt da in diesem Maße gar kein Scheitern.
Es ist einfach, diese Maßstäbe gehen völlig, und er redet jetzt,
das haben vielleicht auch schon einige gehört, es so zu hören,
wie wir das auch diskutieren, Also gerade Steffen-Mau-Triggerpunkte,
wir haben eine politische Arena und eine ökonomische.
Und wir wollen das ja nicht so sehr verwechseln, insbesondere wenn dann noch
auf diesem identitätspolitischen Felder und so weiter da irgendwie Argumente
reinkommen und plötzlich haben wir eine ganz andere Regierung,
weil wir nach völlig verqueren Gesichtspunkten gewählt haben,
statt einfach mal ökonomisch uns die Kennzahlen anzugucken, was tut uns denn gut.
Und wie er die politische und
die ökonomische Agenda einfach als eins betrachtet, ist wirklich herrlich.
50 Prozent der Deutschen, also die ärmere Hälfte, besitzt, was glauben Sie,
wie viel Prozent des Gesamtvermögens?
Das ist, ich kenne diese Statistiken. 1,4 Prozent? Ja, klar.
Und wenn die jetzt 10, 20 Prozent kriegen, was passiert dann?
Haben die 20 Prozent mehr Konsum, das ist eine kurze Blase. Naja,
sie haben ein bisschen mehr Sicherheit im Leben.
Wenn die das entsprechend tatsächlich in dieser Richtung benutzen würden, dann haben sie recht.
Tun sie das? Weiß ich nicht. Aber das klingt jetzt so, als würden die Leute
mit dem Geld nicht umgehen können.
Ich sorge dafür, dass gewisse Sachen passieren.
Wenn das Geld verteilt wird, wird es nicht investiert, wird es ausgegeben.
Das kann ja auch investiert werden, die Leute können nur nicht ...
Dann sagen Sie mir mal, die Deutschen sind kein Land der Eigenverantwortung.
Sagt der Großerbe, der hier dieses FDP-Programm, ja wir wollen es nicht an die
Leute verteilen, sonst geben sie es aus.
Die verkonsumieren das ja.
Ja, wir warten hier und gucken, dass wir das nach oben verteilen,
denn dann nur wird es investiert in ganz großartige Restaurants,
in die dann diese Leute wiederum nicht rein können.
Und dann, dass ihm das auch nicht auffällt, wenn er sagt, wenn man denen jetzt
20% mehr gibt, dann geben die das aus. Ja, wenn jemand 1400 Euro hat und bekommt
20% mehr, dann hat er 280 Euro mehr.
Da kann er immer noch nicht in das Restaurant gehen, in dem er eben gerade gesessen hat.
Ja, 20% mehr heißt für die deutsche Durchschnittsfamilie im Monat 80 Euro mehr
oder so. An freien verfügbaren.
Diese 80 Euro, die werden wahrscheinlich nicht investiert, sondern verkonsumiert.
Allerdings lokal. Das ist ja eh das, was die Städte mal brauchen.
Wir wundern uns immer, dass die Innenstädte so sterben, weil Konsum irgendwie ausbleibt.
Ja, wenn man aus Berlin einfach eine Million extra nur durch Mieterhöhungen
raussaugt, ist das halt so.
Da geht halt keiner mehr seinen Kaffee für 5,50 Euro kaufen,
was ja auch bescheuert ist. In Rom kriegt man den für einen Euro.
Also das Gesamtgefüge stimmt nicht. und die ganze Herangehensweise von ihm ist
ja auch wieder im Rahmen, wie wir mit diesem Wild diskutiert, so, wie soll man sagen,
ich will ja das Wort Depressionen vermeiden, sondern da steckt so eine Unzufriedenheit
drin. Der Typ ist ja grob unzufrieden.
Ja.
Obwohl er Milliardär ist.
Wir hätten das ja damals als Porsche und VW so ein bisschen ihren Hickhack da
gemacht haben, dass der Typ von Ratiofarm vor den Zug sprang.
Weil er eine Milliarde verloren hat obwohl er noch eine Milliarde übrig hatte
und sowas solche Sachen es ist,
die Quellen der Unzufriedenheit sind wirklich verwirrend und ich finde es auch therapiebedürftig,
insbesondere weil diese Leute ja so die Agenda vorgeben im Gespräch mit Politikern
wir haben es schon besprochen dieser Fetisch des unverbrauchten Staates der
Bundeshaushalt soll nicht belastet werden durch Leute,
die da einfach Geld Geld rausziehen und es dann einfach bei Rewe ausgeben.
Das ist nicht, wir wollen, dass die Gelder, die durch den Bundeshaushalt bewegt
werden, zu mehr Geld führen. Es darf nur investiert werden und so weiter.
Und dann ist man da ganz nah an so einem Ungeziefer-Menschenbild irgendwie dran.
Wir wollen das Ungeziefer aus unserem reinen Staat so raus erhalten.
Und diese Art Unverständnis führt dazu wirklich ganz viel...
Traurigkeit in unserer Gesellschaft.
Wenn die nicht mehr da sind, dann bricht die totale Dekadenz aus unter den Arbeitern
und Arbeitslosen und dann geht alles den Bacher runter.
Und das ist diese Elitenvorstellung, die dort tatsächlich da ist und das Problem
ist, dass die Politiker gerne zu dieser Elite gehören würden.
Die würden zwar machtpolitisch das tun, aber ökonomisch natürlich arme Schweine
sind, wenn die so jemandem gegenüber sitzen.
Und die Journalisten, mit Ausnahme jetzt mal hier einer solchen Doku,
in der Regel auch nochmal fragen, was wollen denn unsere Unternehmerverbände gerade?
Und sich auch in so einer Position vorfinden, wo sie glauben,
sie seien auch mächtig, aber die ökonomische Macht ist halt die,
dass die ihre 3000 netto, die sie dann verdienen, auch mal einmal im Monat in
einem Restaurant von diesem Herrn zum Teil verbraten.
Ja und das macht eben diese Doku so gut, weil der Breyer die ganze Zeit aus
unserer Blickrichtung war sie da und nicht, ah der DAX hat wieder einen Rekord,
gut, gute Nachrichten, der DAX ist stark.
Genau, die Leute halten sich für absolut unverzichtbar und Dokus wie diese kratzen
einfach an deren Ehre, denn wo kommt dieses Geld her?
48 Prozent. Das ist das, was normalos wie Sie als Singles laut Netzwerk für
Steuergerechtigkeit an Steuern und Sozialabgaben so abtreten.
Die haben aber auch ausgerechnet, wie viel Steuern für einen Mustermillionär so anfallen.
24 Prozent, also nur noch die Hälfte. Und das alles ohne Tricks.
Überhaupt ist die Politik in den letzten Jahren den Superreichen,
sagen wir mal, entgegengekommen.
Nehmen wir zum Beispiel Sie hier, Frau Susanne Klatten, Unternehmerin,
BMW-Erbin, geschätztes Vermögen mindestens 25 Milliarden Euro.
Und gehen wir mal zurück auf das Jahr 1996. Da hörten wir im Radio die Fugees
in Endlosschleife, im Kino lief Werner, das muss kesseln.
Und er hier war immer noch Ewig-Kanzler Helmut Kohl.
Damals, so steht es in den Daten, die mir zugespielt wurden,
wären auf die BMW-Erträge von Susanne Klatten satte 61% steuernfällig gewesen.
Aber seit damals kannten die Steuern nur noch eine Bewegung runter. Was für ein Glück.
Keine Vermögenssteuer mehr.
Niedrigere Unternehmenssteuer. Und runter mit dem Spitzensteuersatz.
Also dieses Geld, was er sich aufsummiert, korreliert einfach mit diesen politischen
Entscheidungen, die getroffen wurden.
Ja, es gab Ende Oktober einen Artikel bei Zeit Online von Nathanael Heffner,
Mia Janssen und Annik Ehmann und da ging es um den Global Tax Evasion Report
und der hat sich das global angesehen und da sprechen wir bei Milliardären von
einem effektiven Steuersatz von 0 bis 0,5 Prozent.
37 Milliarden Euro haben deutsche Milliardäre im Ausland geparkt.
377 Milliarden Euro haben deutsche Milliardäre im Ausland geparkt.
Und diese Mindeststeuer mit den 15 Prozent, die wird ja jetzt gerade von den
USA nicht durchgesetzt wegen des Inflation Reduction Act. Da will man sich jetzt
nicht das schlecht machen.
Großbritannien macht auch nicht mit. Und gerade sind wir da so bei 8% in Deutschland,
wenn wir die Mindeststeuer da hätten,
dann würde Deutschland auch 17 Milliarden Euro mehr pro Jahr einnehmen,
wenn diese Mindeststeuer 15% käme.
Ja und generell haben die ausgerechnet, dass man, also wenn man mal so mit diesen
Mindeststeuern und 2% Vermögensteuer sowas rechnen würde,
2% Vermögensteuer ist ja auch wirklich wenig, dann hätte man 300 Milliarden
Euro mehr Steuereinnahmen von Unternehmen und 250 Milliarden Euro mehr Steuern.
Wenn es diese Vermögenssteuer für Milliardäre gäbe.
Ja, genau.
Und das sind ja alles noch moderate Forderungen, weit weg von dem,
was hier vorgestellt wurde.
Wir wollen jetzt triggerpunktemäßig das zusammenklamüsern, weil die Milliarden
nützen uns ja nichts als pure Zahl.
Aber wenn wir, wie der Johannes Winkel da in der Landessendung feststellen,
ja, im Bundeshaushalt müssen 117 Milliarden mobilisiert werden,
um die Renten aufzufüllen.
Dann sind das diese 117 Milliarden, die fehlen, weil die ja vorher rausgezogen wurden.
Also man hat über Entkopplung von Produktivität und Lohnentwicklung die Löhne
gedrückt, damit auch die Lohnnebenkosten.
Es ist weniger Geld da reingeflossen.
Der Bedarf ist aber geblieben. Und jetzt hat man halt eine Lücke von 100 Milliarden
und fragt sich, wo kommen die denn her?
Und dann fängt er irgendwie an, in der Geschichte rumzuwühlen und irgendwie
Vorwürfe zu machen. Aber wir haben ja das Geld.
Wir müssen es ja nur einsteuern, wir brauchen halt für den Bundeshaushalt da
eine Geldquelle und hier haben wir sie gesehen.
Ich meine 17 Milliarden allein über diese Mindeststeuer, das ist ja zehnmal
so viel, wie wir jetzt für die wahrscheinlich nicht kommende Kindergrundsicherung bezahlen.
Das könnte eine einzige Person einfach bezahlen. Da braucht man gar keine große
politische Diskussion, das könnte man im 1 zu 1 lösen.
Da könnte man anrufen und sagen, zahl mal, wir brauchen hier für alle Kinder.
Da steht dein Name dran, das ist dann die Kindergrundwildsicherung.
Hast du auch diesen Clip mit Kevin Kühnert dabei?
Ja, den hören wir glaube ich gleich.
Okay.
Hoffe ich.
Erbe und Ehre, die Superreichen äußert sich hier mal zum Thema.
Sie schreiben, Reiche seien eine diskriminierte Minderheit.
Das hat mich, ehrlich gesagt, sehr überrascht. Wie kommen Sie darauf?
Ich habe geschrieben, es ist eine Minderheit, die mit Vorurteilen und Stereotypen konfrontiert ist.
Weniger so im täglichen Erleben, sondern in den Medien.
Oder auch in der Politik, dass immer irgendwie eine Stimmung gemacht wird gegen
Reiche. Ich sage Ihnen jetzt, in meinem Bekanntenkreis sind überwiegend Unternehmer.
Und ich kenne fast keinen, fast keinen, der nicht über Auswandern nachdenkt.
Und zwar ernsthaft nachdenkt. Das werden jetzt viele nicht tun,
aus unterschiedlichen Gründen. Warum denken die über das Auswandern nach? Wegen dieser Stimmung.
Wegen dieser Stimmung, weil sie sagen, ich fühle mich nicht willkommen,
ich fühle mich nicht gewertschätzt.
Ja, was können wir für sie tun, dass sie sich wohler fühlen?
Sie gehen natürlich nicht.
Ja, aber auch wie er sagt, nicht jetzt aus dem alltäglichen Erleben,
sondern mehr die Stimmung in den Medien.
Ich meine, wenn du super reich bist und irgendwie den Schulklassen deiner Kinder,
die alles bezahlst und dich da engagierst und so weiter, du wirst angehimmelt im ganzen Stadtteil.
Du ersetzt ja quasi den Gemeinderat, der aus Finanzierungsgründen dann ausfällt. Und so.
Und wie er dann trotzdem noch dieses, obwohl man sich das ja auch kaufen kann, Ja, gute Stimmung.
Das da noch bemängelt, dass da irgendwie so, es ist ganz, ganz absurd.
Dass da schon mal so eine Doku erscheint, das ist aber auch wirklich skandalös.
Das verhagelt uns das ganze Fest.
Genau. Hier hört man den Wild, den Capri-Sonnen-Typ.
Ist das Bild, was von Vermögenden in Deutschland existiert, ist das fair?
Das ist ein negatives Bild, würde ich sagen, ja. Mein Vater hat mir,
als er noch relativ jung war, hat er mir gesagt, das größte Problem in deinem
Leben, was du haben wirst, ist die vielen Leute, die auf dich neidisch sind.
Ja, was ist denn so ein hartes Los?
Hier hören wir auch wieder, sein Vater hat die Erfahrung auch schon gemacht,
warum, naja, Startkapital und so, also der Typ kennt es gar nicht anders.
Ich habe dann auch so ein bisschen drüber nachgedacht, wenn er das jetzt so
sagt. Sein Vater sagt eben, die Leute werden auf dich neidisch sein wegen deinem Geld.
Da steckt ja eigentlich die Botschaft drin, du wirst den Leuten egal sein,
nur dein Geld ist entscheidend.
Also du als Person wirst einfach keine Rolle spielen.
Da könnte man ja auch ansetzen und sagen, ich möchte aber als Person eine Rolle spielen.
So, und da gibt es ja auch ein paar Handlungsmöglichkeiten um sich,
obwohl man nur mit einer Capri-Sonne, was ich ja, wie gesagt,
sehr stigmatisierend finde,
ach, Sie haben nur mit der Capri-Sonne, okay, alles klar, sehr gut,
erzählen Sie mal, so, dass man da so ein bisschen Interessanz für sich,
die Person raushaut, auch indem man dann eben sagt, okay, ich engagiere mich jetzt,
aber nicht, indem ich einen Sportclub in Paris finanziere, was wahnsinnig dumm
ist, finde ich, sondern kann auch vor Ort irgendwas machen.
Ich saß in diesem Sommer mit Leuten zusammen,
von denen einer sehr viel Geld
hat und wir haben uns zum ersten Mal getroffen, auch danach nicht mehr,
aber es war so ein ganz heiterer Abend und wir haben uns unterhalten und dann
ging es darum, dann wurde gesagt, dass ich sehr viel ins Kino gehe.
Und aufgrund der Profession aber auch, weil ich dann Leidenschaft habe.
Und dann sagte dieser sehr reiche Mann zu mir, den letzten Film,
den er im Kino gesehen habe, war Wall Street mit Michael Douglas.
Aber ich sagte, ach, haben die den nochmal neu gebracht? Und er sagte, nee, damals.
Das sei auch so eigentlich das letzte Mal gewesen, dass er so einen Film komplett
gesehen hat, woraufhin dann ein Freund neben ihm sitzend zu mir sagte,
naja, und jetzt müssten wir mal die Kontoauszüge vergleichen,
für wen sich das ausgezahlt hat, ob man ins Kino geht oder nicht ins Kino geht.
Und dann würde ich sagen, nee, das hat sich für mich, denke ich, ausgezahlt.
Also wenn ich bedenke, trotz aller Til-Schweiger-Erfahrungen,
wie viele glückliche Stunden ich im Kino erlebt habe, dann würde ich sagen, ist mein Konto praller.
Also wenn ich jetzt nur auf die Zahlen gucke und sage, ja, so und so viel Millionen,
dann, klar, dann habe ich verloren.
Ja, man braucht ja wirklich... Aber wenn ich jetzt sage, ich habe einfach dieses
Jahr 20, 25 gute Filme gesehen, das finde ich ist doch eine tolle Erfahrung, die ich da gemacht habe.
Und das fand ich so interessant, also nichts gegen die Herren,
die waren wirklich sehr amüsant und lustig und haben das auch sehr scherz hervorgebracht.
Aber ich habe gedacht, nee, das ist eigentlich eine sehr gute Rechnung,
wo ich sagen würde, ja, weiß ich nicht, wo da das Vermögen, also das Vermögen
würde ich sagen, ist auf meiner Seite.
Wir haben eben, als du nach meinen Highlights gefragt hast, gesagt,
ja, die Erfahrungen. Klar, ich brauchte das Geld, um diese drei Konzertkarten
zu kaufen und das ist dann schon ein Privileg, das machen zu können,
dass man sich diese drei Konzerte leistet.
Da redet man dann von 60 oder 80 oder 90 Euro die Karte.
Aber wenn wir mal von diesem Sockelbetrag weggehen, also von dem,
was man so haben kann und jetzt über die ganz hohen Summen nachdenkt, würde ich sagen,
naja, du hast ja gar keine Zeit oder konntest dich nicht öffnen dem,
dass dir ein Konzert von Hilary Hahn Freude machen könnte.
Ja, also wir brauchen hier so ein paar Maßstäbe und die Frage ist,
ab wann geht es los, dass man diese Art von Vermögen oder Konsumausgaben anders verbucht.
Meine Erfahrung vom letzten Jahr, als ich ja sehr viel Alfred Adler gelesen
habe und der ganze Kram und so, war,
dass man doch ein bisschen Glück haben muss, Zeit mit Leuten zu verbringen,
die von sich wissen, was ihnen selber Spaß macht.
Also man hat ganz oft das so Was wollen wir tun?
Im Sinne von, wir haben jetzt Zeit Kommt auch nicht oft vor Das ist dann so
ein, ja entscheide du Weißt du?
Es ist einfach, wir haben in Deutschland wirklich so ein Wohlstandsproblem Also
ich meine, wir reden jetzt über die Superreichen Aus einer Ghanischen.
Nigerianischen Richtung sind wir die Superreichen Und zwar auch faktisch,
also wir gehören zur zur Top 5% der Welt, alle hier in Deutschland.
Also selbst Bürgergeldempfänger gehören dazu.
Denn die grundlegenden Sachen, Dach über dem Kopf und so weiter,
wenn auch unter schwierigen Gesichtspunkten im Vergleich zu,
wie es wünschenswert wäre, ist erstmal grundsätzlich geregelt. So.
Und trotzdem haben wir so eine große Orientierungslosigkeit und Unzufrieden,
weil man einfach nicht so richtig, also man weiß, wenn man ganz ehrlich mit
sich ist, einfach nicht so richtig, was man jetzt mit freien Wochenenden macht und sowas.
Ich erlebe auch ganz viele Leute, die haben sich so für Kinder entschieden,
unvorbereitet und wissen einfach nicht, was sie mit diesen Kindern anfangen
sollen. Grundsätzlich.
Und die hat man aber stundenlang jeden Tag.
Gut, ich weiß nicht, ob wir auf dieser philosophischen Ebene am Ende ankommen
sollten. Also man kann Schopenhauer lesen und kann dort nachlesen, so ist es auch.
Das Leben ist Leiden, man kann sich kleine Ziele setzen,
das sind aber nur Auswege, um wieder festzustellen, dass diese Befriedigung,
die man erlangt, wenn man das Ziel erreicht, doch nicht das eigentliche war, was man wollte.
Ja, die Beordnung zur Freiheit ist wirklich sehr quälend für sehr viele Leute.
Volkswirtschaftlich draufgeblickt und jetzt mal es mit allen gut meint,
also wir wollen ja gar nicht eine Neiddebatte, ja wir wollen es ja mit allen
gut meinen und würden jetzt sagen, lieber Herr Wild,
lieber Herr Pscher, glauben Sie nicht, es wäre irgendwie schöner,
wenn man in so einer Gesellschaft leben würde in der sie sich nicht in einer
17.000 Euro Suite abschotten müssten.
Also das wird einem so klar, wenn man zum Beispiel dann in Oslo oder so ist,
ich will das jetzt auch nicht verklären, da wird es sicherlich auch Probleme geben,
ist es auch sehr teuer dort natürlich, das ist ja die Schweiz des Nordens,
wenn man so möchte, aber man erfährt ja doch, wo man Gesellschaft nicht nur als Konkurrenz erlebt,
sondern wo sich eigentlich zeigt, dass man kooperativ sein kann und noch jedem
genügend Freiräume lässt, dort ist ja das Leben angenehmer.
Und das finde ich ja auch so, gerade wenn man jetzt in Frankfurt in der Innenstadt
ist, dass man, wenn man dort durch diese Goethestraße, also durch diese Luxusmodestraße
geht, dort ist es nicht angenehm in dem Sinne.
Also man sieht zwar diese Luxusfassaden und unglaublich teure Sachen und Leute
sind schick gekleidet zugleich, aber erlebst du dort, dass es nicht eine offene
Atmosphäre ist, sondern es ist eine,
man verbarrikadiert sich in diesen teuren Geschäften, da sind Türsteher,
also muss irgendwas bewacht werden, offenbar ist sowas nicht ganz sicher.
Dann fährt die Polizei wieder durch.
Dann sind dort Leute, die betteln, die konfrontieren. Also die sehr reichen
damit, dass man sie gar nichts haben.
Also es ist keine Atmosphäre, bei der man sagt, oh, hier möchte man aber eigentlich verweilen.
Sondern die einzige Möglichkeit, die man hat, ist zu sagen, ich gehe jetzt auch
in so ein Geschäft und zeige denen hier, ich habe ein paar tausend Euro zum
Ausgeben. Also hofiert mich jetzt mal.
Macht mir mal eine Stunde eine gute Zeit hier. Und das ist also kein angenehmes Leben jetzt.
Ja, man fühlt sich da mitten in der Innenstadt wie am Flughafen.
Und am Flughafen, ich habe noch niemanden gesoffen, der mir sagte,
ich fühle mich hier wohl.
Wenn man da durch diese steuerfreien, ich weiß auch gar nicht,
ob die Leute wirklich am Flughafen plötzlich so Luxusgraben,
also diesen kleinen Einzelhandels-Luxusgraben kaufen.
Das wundert mich durchgehend.
Nee, ich bin da auch gar nicht in der Stimmung zu dann jetzt zu sagen,
ich gucke jetzt mal nach ein paar Fragen.
Außer in Stadt Frankfurt, diese Unterschiede zwischen einem Menü für 300 und einem Menü für 30 Euro.
Es kommt nicht selten vor, dass dieser Gag abends nochmal durch die WhatsApp-Gruppen
fliegt mit das war mein Essen für heute Abend, ich hole mir jetzt erstmal einen Döner.
Das ist eh so eine, ob das vielleicht auch mit Absicht ist,
dass man ungenügend Und bespeist wird, wenn man irgendwie für dreistellige Beträge,
also es gibt auch ganz vielen Ebenen, ganz komische Gefüge, die einfach nicht
passen und die aber latent bleiben.
Das ist eigentlich das größte Problem. Wir haben diese Diskussion darum eigentlich nicht.
Wäre es nicht auch in München oder so für alle besser, wenn man Mobilität und
ein restverfügbares Geld noch hat, um jenseits der Miete zu arbeiten.
Die Lage, in der man mietet, zu nutzen. Also einfach nicht alles über Freundschaftsdienste
abdecken, dann nochmal einen schönen Tag am Wochenende auch als Student in so Städten zu haben.
Also es müsste eigentlich alles mal manifestiert werden in eine politische Diskussion.
Kevin Kühnert ist ja leider der einzige Politiker, den wir in dieser ganzen
Doku sehen und auch danach.
Und der sagt nur, dass er wütend ist.
Aber es ist auch keine politische Mehrheit da.
Also er steht nur da und sagt, ich bin wütend, Und das ist ja,
was wir immer wieder erleben, dass die Politiker eigentlich sich jetzt Bürger
verkaufen, die auch wütend sind, aber handlungsunfähig.
Vor allem Kühnert kommt ja auch in der teuren Wohnen-Reportage vor, in dem Podcast.
Sagt aber da eigentlich auch so in etwa dasselbe.
Naja, aber er kommt ja vor allem vor, weil er immer noch auf Wohnungssuche ist.
Ja, er findet ja ewig keine Wohnung.
Dirk Rossmann ist einer der wenigen, der mal so ein leichtes,
wir reden mal offener darüber, so einen Ansatz fährt.
Bei vielen Unternehmern habe ich so das Gefühl, das ist denen so ein bisschen
mulmig, dass sie reich sind.
Also mir ist das gar nicht mulmig. Ich finde das gut.
Dirk Rossmann stammt aus armen Verhältnissen.
Seine Mutter betreibt in der Nachkriegszeit eine kleine Drogerie.
Der geschäftstüchtige Sohn strebt nach Höherem.
1972 hat er eine geniale Idee und eröffnet den ersten Drogeriemarkt in Deutschland.
Heute ist er mehrfacher Milliardär.
Warum traut er sich in die Öffentlichkeit?
In den ganzen Anfangsjahren ging es natürlich darum, wie kriegt man den Namen
Rossmann, den ja niemand kannte, wie macht man den Namen bekannt, ja?
So, er hat also Werbung gemacht. Er saß in irgendwelchen Talkshows und hat gesagt,
hier Rossmann und so weiter, gehen Sie doch mal da einkaufen.
Bis er dann festgestellt hat, reformuliere ich jetzt mal.
Nee, ich sorge ja hier für Grundversorgung. Die Leute brauchen halt Zahnpasta.
Ich muss dafür gar keine Werbung machen.
Die Leute brauchen Zahnpasta. Da kommt eine Lehrerin und sagt,
morgen kommt die Zahnärztin und dann ist sie in der Schule und sagt, ihr braucht Zahnpasta.
Dann kaufen die halt bei mir, so ungefähr. Und das gehört, finde ich,
mit zum Gesamtgefüge, wenn wir feststellen, dass irgendwelche Milliardäre für
Grundversorgung sorgen, wie zum Beispiel auch bei Amazon.
Zuerst vertreibt er Bücher, die man einfach mal nach Hause geschickt bekommt
und dann stellen wir fest, ach in der Pandemie sind es die einzigen,
die noch Versorgungsdienstleistungen anbieten.
Dann müssen wir da auch politisch anders drüber diskutieren,
statt einfach nur, ah, da weißt du mal, eine Welt und so. Dankbarerweise.
Steffen Klusmann, heute Spiegel, damals Manager Magazin, hier nochmal in dieser
älteren Doku von 2018, 19, zu dieser Frage, wo kommt diese Art schlechtes Gewissen
her? Warum fühlen die sich so schlecht, die Superreichen?
Obwohl sie doch eigentlich von allen Leuten angehimmelt und auch in der Politik hofiert werden.
Und ich würde sagen, das korreliert so eins zu eins mit diesem,
bei Dirk Rossmann hören wir, der hat sich das selbst erarbeitet,
klar Mehrwert abgeschöpft seiner Mitarbeiter,
aber es war seine Idee, er hat den ersten Laden aufgemacht und danach hat er
es hochskaliert oder eben ich habe einfach zu viel Startkapital.
Das Interessante ist, wenn man sich unsere reichsten Liste anguckt und die vergleicht
mit den reichsten Listen in Amerika.
Bei uns ist es sehr viel altes Geld, alte Unternehmen, die es seit Jahrzehnten gibt.
Und in Amerika werden halt diese ganzen Jungs, die Facebook,
Google, Snapchat und so weiter, die sind alle hochgespült in diesen Listen.
Das gibt es bei uns in der Form nicht. Und im Vergleich zu anderen Ländern...
Sind die Deutschen auch sehr zurückhaltend.
Das ist ganz gut, dass er das mal sagt, denn hier kommen zwei Dinge hinzu.
Und zwar, wenn wir über die USA nachdenken, dann fällt uns wie ihm auch sofort die Technologie ein.
Man kann nachweisen in Studien, und Milanovic hat das auch getan,
dass Technologie in der Regel neue Kapitalbildungen ermöglicht.
Das heißt, das alte Geld kann zwar auch irgendwann investieren daran wieder,
wird nicht völlig verschwinden,
aber es ist die Möglichkeit, dass viel neues Kapital entstehen kann,
also neue Kapitalisten entstehen und damit der Einfluss des alten Geldes etwas geschwächt wird.
Wo allerdings eine Rezession ist, da lassen auch die Investitionen in neue Technologien
nach, wird das alte Geld also wieder stärker.
Das, was wir jetzt gerade hier in Deutschland erleben, ist zwar so ein mediales
Klagen von irgendwelchen älteren Unternehmern darüber, wie es jetzt so gerade
schiefläuft und damit haben sie sicherlich auch in vielen Punkten recht.
Aber de facto ist es auch so, dass jetzt durch die schlechte Wirtschaftslage
eigentlich das alte Geld nochmal stärker wird, während diese neuen Möglichkeiten,
also Stichwort Startups,
diese werden sehr viel geringer.
Und das würde ich auch nochmal den Leuten ins Gebetbuch schreiben,
die immer so sehr auf diesem Degrowth-Kurs sind und dann aber nicht etwas anderes
anbieten, also eine völlig andere Wirtschaftsweise, ein sozialistisches Plan oder was weiß ich.
Also dass man nur sagt, ich freue mich, dass die Wirtschaft nicht mehr so stark
wächst, denn wir müssen ja eh davon runter.
Diese Vorstellung von Degrowth, das ist ja toll, wenn wir nicht so viel Wachstum
haben, das ist doch auch dann gegen Neoliberalismus.
Nein, man kann sagen, da wo die Wirtschaft stagniert oder sinkt,
da wächst die Macht des alten Geldes.
Das andere schafft ja nicht eine gleiche Welt, aber es wird dann noch hermetischer,
überhaupt selbst eine individuelle Aufstiegsgeschichte auch nur zu schaffen.
Deswegen ist das sehr richtig, was er da sagt.
Und wir haben ja vorher gehört, man fühlt sich unwohl, dieses Geld,
man wird irgendwie so und so schief angeguckt.
Ich glaube, in dem Moment, wo diejenigen, die das Geld haben,
sagen, okay, ich akzeptiere, ich habe es nicht selbst erarbeitet.
Ich hatte den Startvorteil, den hätte wahrscheinlich jeder genutzt.
Also es ist dann nur noch eine Auslese von 1 zu 10 und nicht mehr 1 zu 80 Millionen,
ob man jetzt mit seinem Business Erfolg hat, wenn man einfach,
wenn klar ist, das ist dein Projekt nächstes Jahr, wenn es scheitert,
machst du nächstes Jahr einfach was anderes. Es sind wirklich genug Geld da.
In dem Moment, wo die von ihrem, ich sehe es als eher verletzend an,
dass mir abgesprochen wird aus eigener Leistung und so, umso mehr können die
dann auch versöhnlicher sozusagen ihrerseits von diesen Ansprüchen herabrücken,
dass sie gerne mit Respekt behandelt werden wollen oder wie auch immer.
Also da braucht es so eine große Versöhnung, die in dem Moment,
wo 50% gar nichts haben und dann 1% alles, natürlich erstmal fern liegt.
Aber es ist am Ende, wir haben es vorhin bei Gaza schon betont,
wenn die ökonomischen Unterschiede zu groß sind, hat das politische Folgen.
Auf allen Ebenen. Also wenn die Kommune nicht mehr finanzierbar ist,
dann denkt sich die AfD, ja dann machen wir das einfach, weil uns ist ja egal,
wir hätten eh nicht vor, einen Haushalt zu schreiben, wir wollen ja einfach
nur die Posten besetzen.
So ungefähr. Dann springen die da rein.
Also wir brauchen hier so ein versöhnliches Wiederfalten der ökonomischen Ungleichheiten.
Ja, das klingt alles sehr gut, wenn man von vernunftbegabten Bürgern ausgeht,
aber jetzt bringe ich dir mal unsere neuen, noch nicht Milliardäre,
aber Millionäre, nämlich wir werden ja noch über Twitch sprechen.
Und da sind ja einige sehr reich geworden,
also Millionäre, Multimillionäre geworden dadurch, dass sie Glücksspiele bewerben,
live zocken, dass sie dann Leute locken auch in solche Glücksspiel-Apps zu gehen,
dafür Provisionen erlangen.
Da sind ja ganz erstaunliche Karrieren hervorgegangen und diese prahlen auch
enorm damit, dass sie so sehr reich geworden sind durch Glücksspiele.
Nun ist ja Glücksspiel, wie der Name schon sagt, ein Glücksspiel und zugleich
wird da ja nicht mehr irgendein Narrativ bedient von,
wir haben es uns selbst erarbeitet, sondern es wird ja nur noch dann von den Fans.
Die dann zum Teil diese Apps sich auch dann herunterladen und all das,
wird ja nur noch gefeiert, dass sie es irgendwie geschafft haben, reich zu werden.
Also dass sie die Cleverness besessen haben,
auch wenn dann nur für einen kurzen Zeitpunkt, was auch immer,
sie waren zur rechten Zeit am rechten Ort, dass sie es irgendwie geschafft haben,
Leuten diesen Mist anzudrehen und mit diesem Schrott Millionäre geworden sind
und dafür werden sie von ihrer Community gefeiert.
Also wie erklärst du dir das?
Also da haben wir ja gar nicht mehr dieses Narrativ. Also hier dieses Beispiel
ist dieses Crypto-Casino-Stake.
Das hat so Konditionen für Werbedeals
angeboten, dass beispielsweise ein US-Streamer, Trainwrecks heißt der.
360 Millionen US-Dollar innerhalb von sechs Monaten verdient hat.
Also nur mit Provisionen, mit diesen Werbedeals, die er da abgeschlossen hat.
Und es ist ja nicht so, dass das dann geheim gehalten wird, sondern die prahlen
damit sagen, guckt hier, ich habe jetzt den fünften Lambo mir gekauft und alles ist super.
Und jeder weiß, dass sie es nur mit Schrott gemacht haben.
Also da ist noch nicht mal eine Capri-Sonne mehr, sondern wir haben einfach
nur die Leute spielsüchtig gemacht, um es mal ganz drastisch zu sagen.
Und werden trotzdem dafür von ihrer Community gefeiert und das sind ja auch
dann Leute, die da feiern, die das toll finden, wenn Monte zu Friedrich Merz
auf der Bild-Zeitung-Skala geht und sagt,
du musst mal den Spitzensteuersatz senken.
Also was ist das? Also hier die versuchen ja immer noch den ehrbaren Kaufmann
zu spielen und dann sagt man so, naja, also so ganz kann es ja nicht sein.
Aber hier, die versuchen das ja noch nicht mal mehr.
Ja, ich glaube, das sind die jungen Internetnutzer, die sich immer noch am Anfang
dieses langen Weges sehen, der sie auch dazu führt, also dass Monte für sie
so eine Art Wegbereiter ist.
Siehst du Mama, man kann damit so viel Geld verdienen. Ich muss nicht studieren.
Irgendwann sind sie dann auch über 30 wie Monte und sehen, dass sie aber jetzt
komischerweise nicht so viel Geld haben.
Es geht dann nicht auf. Außerdem, Monte versteht ja seinen eigenen Erfolg nicht.
Das ist ja wie bei Thomas Gottschalk.
Moderiert halt gut. Also man kann einfach irgendwie so reden,
dass es den Leuten gefällt.
Und man kann es aber sich selber nicht erklären. Sondern es funktioniert halt
einfach. Man macht halt, was man so macht und wundert sich darüber.
Dichtet sich dann selber irgendwelche Erklärungen an, so retrospektiv,
warum man jetzt selbst so ein toller Hecht geworden ist.
Und irgendwie muss man ja über sich selbst reden und,
Monta, ich meine, wir machen uns immer lustig im Fernsehpodcast,
wenn die bei Kulturzeit anfangen mit den Künstlern über deren Kunst zu reden,
weil die nicht in der Lage sind.
Was soll man sagen? Man hat halt gestaltet, man hat was gefühlt,
wie auch immer. Und dann soll man es plötzlich so in 90 Sekunden für Oma Erna im Fernsehen aufsagen.
Trotzdem will man ja irgendwie über sein Zeug reden.
Und Monte muss halt auch über sein Zeug reden.
Und man hat aber nichts, außer, dass man halt seine Kontoabrechnung hat.
Es läuft halt einfach so Geld auf.
Und die zeigt man dann. Also das ist ja bei den Streamern und anderen YouTubern
durchaus üblich, dass die dann immer wieder so Videos machen,
in denen sie ihre Einnahmen zeigen.
Das ist das Werk.
Und das ist das Werk, dass man nur noch das Geld angehäuft hat. Das ist die Leistung.
Perfektioniert hat es ja MrBeast, der einfach das Geld, das er durch seine Videos
angehäuft hat, ins nächste Video reinsteckt. und dadurch ist das Geld bei ihm Dauerthema.
Es beginnt ja quasi in den ersten fünf Sekunden, jetzt geht es wieder um 10
Millionen und sowas. Man platzt ja richtig damit rein.
Der hat es so richtig hingekriegt, das zu verschachteln, aber das Geld selbst
ist dann noch mehr als bei diesen Superreichen der Lebensinhalt selbst.
Ja, oder diese Sache, wir hatten, glaube ich, jetzt mal kurz angesprochen mit den Pokémon-Karten,
dass man diese alten Packages sich beschafft, die inzwischen 10.000 Euro wert
ist, sind und dann nimmt man diese Packages und öffnet sie live im Stream,
vernichtet also den Wert von 10.000 Euro, denn nur das geschlossene Package
ist so viel wert, vernichtet den Wert,
hat aber dadurch so viele Zuschauer und so viele Subs wieder gesammelt,
dass man mehr als 10.000 Euro eingenommen hat,
also 20.000 Euro kann man also demnächst das Package für 20.000 Euro kaufen
und noch mehr Publikum generieren und es geht also dann nur noch um das,
Werk als Zahl. Genau.
Ich meine beim Thema, dass viel Geld gut ist, im Sinne dieser Sendelchen mir
geht's gut, ich gehöre zu den Guten, so, dieser alten katholischen Verquickung.
Die protestantische Verquickung.
Das gilt ja auch für die, die das Geld nicht haben. Also die denken ja genauso.
Das haben wir ja bei Steffen Mau.
Das meritokratische System ist ja als Logik nirgendwo so verankert wie ganz
oben und ganz unten auf der Skala und in deren Sicht.
Weiß man...
Stimmt, da haben wir es auch nochmal sehr deutlich, ja.
Ja, also was jetzt für unsere Logik bedeutet, wenn jemand beispielsweise an so einem Familientisch,
ganz erregt davon erzählt, wie superreich der eigene super Twitch-Liebling ist,
weiß man, man hat mit einer ganzen Armsocke zu tun, der also ihn genau spiegelt.
Aber man trifft sich auf diesem Spielfeld zumindest, wo man sich aus großer
Ferne dann mal gegenübersteht.
Und das ist das Thema Ungleichheit.
Ungleichheit nicht nur im finanziellen Sinne, sondern auch in vielen anderen,
wie wir jetzt schon versucht haben, etwas weichere Kriterien,
nochmal andere Maßstäbe und so weiter.
Ungleichheit ist hier ein ganz großes Thema. Wir hören Herrn Wild,
der sich auch vergleicht.
Man kann ja sich in zwei Richtungen vergleichen. Er vergleicht sich nach oben.
Ist es gerecht, dass eine Person mehrere Milliarden besitzt und andere so wenig besitzen?
Ja, das ist auch die Frage, die ganz akademische Frage.
Für mich stellt sich mir natürlich, man könnte auch sagen, drei Milliarden,
warum hat jetzt der Bezos so und so viele Milliarden?
Im Ranking der reichsten Deutschen belegt Hans-Peter Wild Platz 77 mit 3,1 Milliarden Euro.
Ist also noch Luft nach oben da.
Und es ist für ihn eine akademische. Ja, das ist natürlich interessant,
weil akademisch ist ja immer die Ausflucht von journalistischen Debatten.
Dass man selbst gar nicht weiter weiß. Ich kann es nicht erklären.
Das müssten die Wissenschaftler mal machen. Die machen doch das mit dem Wissen.
Ich mache ja nur Neuigkeiten.
Also er weiß es selber nicht genau. Und für ihn ist auch dieses,
ob ich jetzt drei Milliarden habe oder fünf Milliarden, ist ja eigentlich egal, so ungefähr.
Das Leben ist ja soweit geregelt.
Also wir haben es hier mit wirklich unklaren Maßstäben zu tun.
Plus, nicht nur wissen die Superreichen nicht, wie reich sie jetzt eigentlich sind.
Also sind sie jetzt drei Milliarden mal reicher als die ärmsten Deutschen oder
nur fünf Prozent so reich wie Jeff Bezos.
Ist ja ein großer akademischer Unterschied, der da drin steckt.
Man weiß einfach grundsätzlich so ganz wenig über diesen Reichtum.
Deutschlands Milliardäre haben noch viel mehr Geld als bisher vermutet.
Und zwar 500 Milliarden Euro mehr.
Damit könnte man dieses Haus hier 500.000 Mal kaufen.
Oder ganz Berlin. Also fast alle Wohn- und Geschäftshäuser.
Das finde ich so gut. Es kam leider nur in diesen drei Sekunden vor.
Aber wir haben jetzt häufiger gehört, 500 Milliarden.
Mehr als wir dachten. Ein latentes Vermögen, von dem wir feststellen,
achso, das gibt es auch noch. Und die wahrscheinlich auch.
Und dann sagt sie hier in dieser Doku, das ist so viel wie alle Immobilien von Berlin.
Das hieße ja, wenn wir das Geld, von dem wir gar nicht wussten,
dass es da ist und dass auch niemanden fehlen, wenn wir es jemandem wegnehmen,
nehmen, um die ganzen Berliner einfach mal Eigentumsübertragungen zu finanzieren.
Dass jeder an seinem eigenen, was würde eigentlich mit der Stadt passieren,
wenn alle plötzlich doppelt so viel Einkommen im Monat hätten, wenn nicht mehr. mehr.
Berlin wäre die lebenswerteste Stadt der Welt in 10 Jahren.
Wenn wir da einfach, ein bisschen wie in Wien,
wenn die Leute da für 5,80 Euro den Quadratmeter mieten, weil Wien als Stadt
die größte, der größte Vermieter der Welt die Leute nicht auszehrt,
sondern so ein Gesamtprogramm mit Binnenwirtschaft Wien unterhält,
dann ist das Lebensgefühl einfach anders. Und das merkt man dann auch.
Also in der Hinsicht, dem Ding hätte man mal nachgehen können.
Also kann man ja immer noch, angegliederte Journalisten mit Investigativ-Kapazitäten haben wir hier.
Nun gut, aber wir haben nur dieses Geld, also Leute wissen nicht,
ja, drei Milliarden, ja, und es gibt Leute, die sind reicher, die sind ärmer.
Es spielt also nur das Geld selbst eine Rolle als Maßstab.
In Zahlenwert ausgedruckt, gedrückt.
Wir haben es also, wie das hat ja Precht auch nochmal im letzten Podcast mit
Lanz betont, ich glaube, das war ein Spruch von Georg Simmel oder so,
Also Geld ist das Einzige, dessen Qualität sich komplett in der Quantität ermisst.
Mehr Geld ist einfach mehr und weniger ist weniger und mehr kann man mehr machen, wie auch immer.
Also spielt nur noch die Logik der Zahlen selbst eine Rolle und die muss man
dann entweder als Vermögen hochtreiben oder als Belastung durch Staat und Verantwortung runter.
Und dieses Spiel hat ja sehr gut funktioniert.
Bei welchem Steuersatz kann ich denn mit aggressiver Steuergestaltung landen?
Bei aggressiver Steuergestaltung, insbesondere unter Zuhilfenahme grenzüberschreitender
internationaler Strukturen, kann man bei Gesamtsteuerbelastungen von bis zu
einem Prozent oder weniger landen.
Ganz ehrlich, ich bin kein Steuerexperte, aber weniger als ein Prozent,
das kann nicht fair und nicht legitim sein.
In rechtlichen Kategorien gedacht, gibt es den Begriff fair nicht.
Das Gesetz regelt, was erlaubt ist.
Genau. Gesetze, Fairness, sittliche Regeln, das spielt alles keine Rolle.
Geld ermischt sich in seiner Quantität vollumfänglich, darüber hinaus gibt es nichts zu sagen.
Und man versucht das dann auf 1% zu kriegen. 1% heißt, in Sachen sozialer Verantwortung
hat man sich komplett rausgenommen.
Also man bezahlt einfach gar nichts für die Infrastruktur, die man nutzt.
Das ist natürlich hochgradig asozial und jetzt gab es hier eine ganz interessante Wortwahl.
Ich will das nochmal deutlich unterstreichen, warum das asozial ist.
Es ist nicht nur asozial im Sinne eines Gerechtigkeitsempfinden,
aber anderen geht es so schlecht oder man muss doch auch den armen Kindern helfen.
Sondern es ist ja so, dass deren Besitz hier steht, beziehungsweise in anderen
Ländern steht, wo sie sich überall nicht sozial einbringen durch Steuerzahlungen.
Und du hast immer dieses schöne Beispiel gebracht mit Frankfurt.
Irgendwelche Investoren aus London oder sonst wo kaufen sich eine Luxuswohnung
in Frankfurt, können dann bei Google Maps oder über andere Dienste jeden Abend
nachgucken, naja steht ja immer noch da.
Warum steht eigentlich diese Luxuswohnung noch da?
Ja, weil Deutschland enorm viel Geld ausgibt für Sicherheit,
dafür, dass Polizei überall ist, dass man Militär hat, dass man davon ausgehen kann,
dass dann nicht morgen ein Volksaufstand ist, dass dort irgendwelche Brände
nicht gelöscht werden, weil keine Feuerwehren vorhanden etc.
Das heißt also all das ist das, was der Steuerzahler leistet,
dass also diese Luxusimmobilie in der Nähe der Frankfurter Oper absolut geschützt
ist und man keine Sorgen haben muss.
Denn sonst könnte man ja fragen, ach warum kaufst du die denn da,
kauf dir doch lieber Wohnungen in, sagen wir Indonesien.
Da ist vielleicht schon ein bisschen heikler, ist da alles so gut abgesichert.
Das heißt also die Steuerzahler zahlen also doppelt in gewisser Weise,
sie sorgen mit ihrer Steuerzahlung dafür,
dass die Profite der Immobilienbesitzer hoch bleiben,
dass die Werte hoch bleiben, weil diese ganze Infrastruktur,
die wir finanzieren, dafür sorgt, dass in den tollen Luxusapartments nie etwas passiert,
weil der deutsche Steuerzahler dafür sorgt, dass alles geschützt ist.
Also wenn ich hier in Frankfurt eine Wohnung miete, wir sitzen ja gerade in einer,
Dann bezahle ich Steuern darauf und sorge mit, keine Ahnung,
nehmen wir mal meine Gesamtsteuerbelastung von, so wie sie eben sagte,
48 Prozent ist so der deutsche Steuersatz. Das sind nicht Sozialabgaben.
Bezahle ich so von meinen 48 Prozent die Sicherheit dort mit.
Der chinesische Immobilienfonds, der sich diese Wohnung da gekauft hat,
Stockwerk 17 bis 35 oder so in irgendeinem Haus, bezahlt ein Prozent.
Also nichts. Ich bezahle quasi doppelt für den mit, die nicht.
Und die gucken aber dann in den Börsenberichterstatten, ob ein aktuelles Bild
von Frankfurt eingeblendet wird.
Sie sehen ihre Stockwerke 15 bis 37 und beschadet und sagen,
Ich muss nicht mal für Sicherheit sorgen, im Sinne von, dass man mal hinfährt
und nachschaut, sondern ich sehe es ja am Fernsehen.
Also bei 1% Steuer heißt das, die nehmen sich einfach komplett raus.
Jetzt haben die für ihre Diskussion intern eine ganz interessante Wortfindung,
wie sie mit diesen Geldern umgehen.
Vermögen auf das Steuern anfallen, wird hier schädliches Vermögen genannt.
Und dieses schädliche Vermögen muss unschädlich gemacht werden.
So heißt das hier. Heißt steuerfrei.
Deswegen kann man darüber nachdenken, Cashboxen zu installieren.
Wir können die Unternehmensbeteiligungen jetzt ohne schädliches Verwaltungsvermögen
und damit ohne Schenkungssteuer auf die nächste Generation übertragen.
Das Geld, das Sie noch nicht gesichert haben vor steuerlichem Zugriff durch
den Staat, nennen Sie schädliches Vermögen.
Obwohl das ja aus unserer Richtung nützliches Vermögen ist, weil davon kriegen wir ja was ab.
Diese Wortwahl ist ja kurz vor Bürgerkriegspamphletschreibung.
Ja, ich finde, dass diese alle, wie man sie da so erlebt, in so einem Bürgerkriegsmodus sind.
Nur können die das ein bisschen feiner austragen. Die laufen jetzt nicht wie
wild geworden mit Transparenten am Reichstag rum,
sondern die können das über kurze Dienstwege oder Beamte aus dem Finanzamt sich regeln lassen.
Denn das ist ja so eine Tagung, auf der man hier zu Gast ist.
Also Preyer ist da zu Gast und erlebt, wie die Reichen sich dort treffen,
um sich beraten zu lassen, wie man diese Steuern noch weiter für sich reduzieren kann.
Wie man sein Geld noch weiter asozialisiert kann.
Also einfach rausziehen aus dem Verantwortungsgefüge. Breyer diskutiert das vor Ort ganz clever.
Sie finden es aber okay, dass andere das machen und dass es ganze Kanzleien
gibt, die sich darauf spezialisiert haben?
Das ist ein netter Versuch. Ich weiß schon, was herauskommt.
Es geht übrigens genau in die Richtung, wenn wir jetzt mal ein bisschen direkter
werden, in dem ein Bild suggeriert werden soll, die Reichen versuchen sich zu
optimieren, zu Lasten derjenigen, die nicht so viel haben.
Da kann ich Ihnen sagen, ich kann nur für mich sprechen. Auf mich trifft es nicht zu.
Und was andere machen, die Beispiele müssen Sie mit denen diskutieren.
Wir insinuieren auch gar nicht, dass die irgendwas Verbotenes tun.
Sondern das sind nur Beispiele dafür, für die Frage, geht es in Deutschland steuerlich gerecht zu?
Ich will jetzt nicht vor laufender Kamera und dann noch live im Fernsehen über
solche Themen diskutieren.
Wenn ich das gewusst hätte, hätten wir das Interview nicht gemacht.
Und wenn Sie nicht so nett wären, würde ich es jetzt auch abbrechen.
Wir besprechen es ja ganz offen. Also wir versuchen ja gar nicht in irgendeine
Richtung zu gehen, sondern wollen Ihre Meinung dazu hören. Keiner,
der Geld hat, muss in diesem Land bleiben.
Und die, die da sind, die wollen da sein. Die zahlen auch ihre Steuern.
Die tragen auch Risiken.
Aber mir ist einfach wichtig, das Signal zu setzen. Und ein Bild als Unternehmer
auch zu zeichnen, wo nicht die Stigmatisierung, die werden morgens wach mit
Steuersparmodellen und gehen abends ins Bett mit Steuersparmodellen.
Ich sage Ihnen, ich denke gar nicht über Steuersparmodellen. Es ist mir egal.
Mir ist es wichtig, dass etwas passiert in diesem Land und dass Unternehmer
und Vermögen, Menschen mit Wohlstand, Verantwortung übernehmen,
Haltung zeigen, sich einbringen. Das habe ich dazu zu sagen.
Investieren heißt natürlich immer die direkte eigene Entscheidung,
wo geht man rein, auch immer mit einem Renditeversprechen.
Wir ziehen ja natürlich auf verantwortliches Zahlen von Steuern,
sodass demokratisch entschieden wird, was mit diesem Geld passiert und so weiter und so fort.
Man hört bei ihm, das schlechte Gewissen ist da, selbst bei ihm,
der von sich nach sagt, ich bin mit weißer Wäsche, ich zahle meine Steuern,
ich mache keine aggressive Steuergestaltung, ich zahle mehr als ein Prozent.
Also egal, wie weit man es treibt, die Qualität aus dem Geld hinauszutreiben
und alles nur in Zahlen zu definieren.
Reste von schlechtes Gewissen machenden Gedanken bleiben.
Zumal er ja mit der bestehenden Rechtsordnung schon sehr gut dran ist.
Das ist ja jetzt nochmal diese Spezialfälle, dass es Leute gibt,
die sagen, ich will eigentlich gar keine Steuern zahlen.
Aber generell ist es ja so, dass Einkommen viel höher besteuert wird als Kapitalerträge.
Das hat man ja irgendwann mal so entschieden.
Warum muss jemand sein Arbeitseinkommen höher versteuern als irgendwelche Aktienportfolios,
die ständig Gewinne ausschütten?
Warum kann man mit Immobilien so herumtricksen, dass man dann GmbHs bildet und
all das? Das heißt, diese Ordnung ist ja schon einmal geschaffen.
Das heißt, wenn wir jetzt über diese Leute reden, die da Grauzonen ausnutzen,
die kriegen dann gar nicht mehr den Hals voll.
Aber an sich ist das System schon darauf angelegt, dass wer mehr Geld verdient,
viel bessere Möglichkeiten hat, Steuern zu sparen. Es ist ja kein an sich progressives System.
Ich würde sagen, ja klar, bei den Leuten, die jetzt eine Karriere durchlaufen,
von angefangen von 20.000 Euro im Jahr bis hin zu 120.000 im Jahr,
die erleben das progressive Steuersystem.
Die können das dann so erleben und sagen, ah ja, jetzt muss ich noch mehr Steuern zahlen.
Aber alles darüber hinaus ist ja, oder dann ab einer halben Million,
einer Million, da ermöglichen ja die Gesetze, die schon da sind,
beste Wege, um wenig bis keine Steuern zu zahlen.
Wir können ja das Bild so aufmachen, wenn er so da sitzt und sagt,
naja, mich betrifft das ja nicht, ich bezahle ja meine Steuern.
Haben wir ja eben schon gelernt, seit Helmut Kohls Zeiten ist ja die Belastung
von Dividenden einkassieren schon von 61% auf 24% gesunken.
Da kann er natürlich jetzt mit gutem Gewissen sagen, also die 24% bezahle ich.
Darüber hinaus mache ich keine aggressive Steuergestaltung.
Diejenigen, die das machen, gibt es aber doch. Die verdingsen sich dann irgendwie
international und kommen auf 1%.
Jetzt können wir ja die, die zwischen diesem 1% und 24% sich irgendwo hineinarbeiten,
sagen, okay, die befinden sich irgendwie in einem Bürgerkrieg gegen uns.
Schon allein, weil sie das Geld, was sie auf ihrer reinen Seite haben wollen,
als schädlich deklarieren, solange
es noch in Gefahr steht, auf der gemeinwohl-nützlichen Seite anzulanden.
So, es gibt also diesen Bürgerkrieg, der stattfindet zwischen Arm und Reich.
Und jetzt positionieren sich einige, wählen also eine Seite.
Und da kommt jetzt das Finanzministerium ins Spiel.
Das Eckpunktepapier, in dem die Verschonungsbedarfsprüfung zum ersten Mal auftaucht. 2015 war das.
Es stammt aus dem Bundesfinanzministerium, Abteilung Vermögens- und Erbschaftssteuer.
Geleitet wurde diese Abteilung damals von ihr, Ministerialrätin Gerda Hofmann.
Sie ist bis heute in diesem Amt.
Und ganz ehrlich, wir hätten nie gedacht, wo wir ihr wieder begegnen würden.
So, wir haben alle gehört, wo sie war. Nämlich da, wo das schädliche Vermögen ausgeflaggt wurde.
Auf dieser herrlichen Konferenz in dem Luxushotel.
Und dass sie jetzt aber als Verwaltungsbeamtin zuständig fürs Erbschaftssteuerrecht,
also im Finanzministerium zuständig für Vermögen und Erbschaftssteuer,
sich in diesem Bürgerkrieg positioniert und nicht sagt, das stimmt,
Steuerzahlungen sind nützliche Zahlungen, die sind nämlich für das Allgemeingut,
für das Gemeinwohlzahl,
sondern dass sie sich auf die Seite schlägt, wo das als schädliche Geldzahlung thematisiert wird.
Das ist eigentlich so ein krasser Skandal, dafür müsste eigentlich ein Finanzminister zurücktreten.
Das geht gar nicht, dass unter der eigenen Verantwortung, in der eigenen Verantwortung jemand so handelt.
Ich glaube nicht, dass das Große in der Tagesschau aufgegriffen wurde.
In der Hinsicht, das ist wirklich ein ganz großes Drama. Der Breyer fasst uns das alles mal zusammen.
Also nur um das nochmal zusammenzufassen. Die Frau, die hier hinter mir im Bundesfinanzministerium
die Abteilung zu Vermögens- und Erbschaftssteuern leitet, eine Staatsdienerin von uns allen bezahlt,
spricht auf einer Konferenz von denen hier.
Flick Gocke Schaumburg, bekannt für aggressive Steuergestaltung,
vor allem für Vermögende.
Und diese Top-Beamtin aus dem Bundesfinanzministerium warnt die Berater davor,
dass sich ein Steuerschlupfloch schließt, sagt aber, keine Sorge,
ich habe da meine Werkzeugkästen.
Also, mehr und besseren Journalismus zum Thema kann man da nicht machen.
Nee.
Wenn jetzt die Leute nicht in ihre Traktoren steigen und sagen,
ich hab da was dagegen, ich fahr nach Berlin, weiß ich auch nicht so richtig weiter.
Ja, aber spiel den Clip hier, Kevin Kühnert.
Ja, jetzt kommt Kevin Kühnert. Die einzige politische Reaktion,
die überhaupt, die Superreichen sind verschlossen, aber die Politiker zum Thema
Superreiche, da sind sie richtig verschlossen.
Das ist ein dickes Ding.
Also, Wut ist ein zu kleiner Ausdruck für das, was ich da gerade gehört habe.
Ich kenne jetzt nur diesen Ausschnitt, aber ich fand das klar genug.
Und wenn das alles so belastbar ist, wie ich es gerade gesehen habe,
dann kann das nicht ohne Konsequenz bleiben.
Ja, aber es bleibt ohne Konsequenz, denn diese Doku ist ja jetzt auch schon
raus seit drei Wochen und es ist nichts geschehen, es gab keine Skandalisierung
in den Medien dieses Vorfalls, es gab ein paar Berichte, aber wirklich kein Skandal.
Denkt an die Greichen-Affäre, da ging es ja um ein paar tausend Euro am Ende
oder so kleine Karrieren, die da ermöglicht wurden und hier geht es um sehr
viel mehr und das ist nicht passiert.
Und da fragt man sich auch, wie viel sind es, 48 Jusos in der SPD-Fraktion und sowas.
Und ich hatte auch so eine E-Mail bekommen, wo gefragt wurde,
ja, aber die jungen Bundestagsabgeordneten, da passiert ja gar nichts.
Hier hatte jemand geschrieben, in den 29er habe ich eine Diskussion über die
jungen Abgeordneten gehört.
Die Analyse aus der Ferne, dass die jungen neuen Abgeordneten wie Kevin Kühn
und eine aktivistische Außensicht haben, würde ich ja zutreffen mit Zeichen.
Also dass die immer nur sagen, ich bin jetzt wütend, aber sehen sich nicht als Politiker.
Und da, also ich arbeite in dem Bereich und erlebe,
Die gar nicht so frischen Frischlinge im Parlament als entfremdet vom politischen
System, schreibt dieser Mensch mir.
Sie versuchen mit nicht ernstzunehmenden Maßnahmen Politik im Innern des Apparats
zu machen und werden darum von den Alten schnell übertölpert.
Es ist ein Verfall des Wissens um die politische Funktionsweisen in diesem Land.
Viele der Abgeordnete sind nicht entsprechend gewillt, die Dinge durchzusetzen,
weil es aufwendig und komplex ist.
Gleichzeitig gibt es keine Allianzen unter ihnen.
Also das ist also jetzt jemand, der einen sehr engen Umgang da hat und da einen
sehr direkten Blick auf all das hat.
Und ich habe nochmal darüber nachgedacht, also wir haben ja in Deutschland das
Modell Berufspolitiker.
Das haben wir ja in vielen Ländern. Und wenn man jetzt mal, und das meine ich
jetzt gar nicht so despektierlich, wie ich es sage, aber ich will es trotzdem auch mal so sagen,
also Leute wie Kevin Kühnert, Ricarda Lang oder Emilia Fester,
diese ganzen jungen Wilden, die würden ja in der freien Wirtschaft niemals 10.000 Euro verdienen.
Sehr wahrscheinlich nicht, formulieren wir es mal so ganz.
Ja, also da 10.000 Euro Top 1% ist und wir dann noch 99% andere haben,
ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass die da landen schwierig.
Aber auch wenn man sich sowas ansieht, die wären ja jetzt sonst nicht Notare
oder Zahnärzte geworden.
Naja, und dann denke ich mir, das ist ja so eine tolle Summe,
die man da hat und da gibt es ja sicherlich auch ein Anliegen,
die Summe jetzt mal zu behalten oder vielleicht noch zu steigern mit anderen politischen Ämtern.
Ja, ist nicht doch eigentlich besser, wenn wir Politiker hätten,
die einen Beruf, also es gibt die ja im CDU, du hast ja den Gauweiler genannt,
für den ist natürlich das Abgeordnetengehalt, ist für den ja ein Kleckerbetrag.
Aber wäre es nicht sinnvoll, jetzt nehmen wir mal an, jetzt wären diese 48 Jusos
und diese anderen jungen Abgeordneten bei den Grünen und so,
die hätten jetzt alle Jobs, bei denen sie keine Sorge haben müssen,
wenn sie die wieder machen,
dass sie da eine kleine Wohnung ziehen müssen.
Dann könnten die sich ja jetzt total investieren dort, also könnten auch auf
Risiko gehen, weil sie sagen, na dann mach doch den Mist allein.
Also eigentlich wie der Gemeinderat sagen kann, nee dann nicht,
beziehungsweise könnten sie jetzt sich anlegen und wenn es dann zu irgendeinem
Koalitionsbruch kommt, dann ist das halt so, dann können die sagen,
ja ich verdiene ja auch in der freien Wirtschaft mein Geld, also kann da wieder sein.
Aber die, wenn sie dort Berufspolitiker sind, müssen ja mit aller Gewalt da dran, da drin bleiben,
irgendwie sich auch solidarisch gegenüber den Höheren in der Partei zeigen,
denn wenn sie das verlieren, dann haben sie einen solchen Einkommensverlust,
dass man sagt, gut, will ich jetzt mit 1400 netto rumkrebsen und Theaterpädagogik
wieder aufnehmen am Stadttheater.
Ja, das ist eigentlich das eigentliche Problem.
Oder will ich diese 10.000 Euro weiter haben?
Und ich würde sagen, diese 10.000 Euro sind für Leute, die kein Kapital im Hintergrund haben,
ein guter Anreiz zu sagen, naja, dann bin ich jetzt mal wütend,
das müsste eigentlich Konsequenzen haben, aber ich mache jetzt doch nichts.
Ja, ein Arbeitsvertrag bedeutet, jemand ist bereit, dir monatlich Geld zu geben für Gegenleistung.
Und jetzt gibt es ja einige Hürden, die zu überspringen sind.
Man muss eine Gegenleistung am Angebot haben.
Ja.
Wenn man promoviert hat und dann ein Bundestagspandat hatte,
sind das aus ganz vielen beruflichen Richtungen Lücken im Lebenslauf,
bei denen wirklich erklärungsbedürftig ist, was haben sie denn da gemacht?
Wie können sie denn das jetzt hier einbringen?
Weil als Hinterbänkler im Bundestag hast du faktisch gar nichts zu tun.
Die Geschäfte sind ja geregelt. Wir haben ja besprochen dieses Jahr,
wie sich die Minister am Kabinettstisch gegenseitig nötigen müssen.
Sie wissen, der Kompromiss, ich, Lisa Paus, mache ihr Wachstumsschancengesetz
nur, wenn sie mir die Kindergrundsicherung geben, dann kommt es vielleicht mal dazu.
Es ist also völlig egal, was 500 Leute im Hintergrund des Bundestages noch dazu
irgendwie an Schriftstücken anfertigen, Anträge schreiben, wie auch immer.
Also in der Hinsicht ist ein Bundestagsmandat selber schon eine Lücke im Lebenslauf.
Da muss man sich noch überlegen, was bedeutet das jetzt für diese kommunalen
Engagements, über die wir am Anfang gesprochen haben.
Also, dass die keiner mehr machen will, erst recht, wenn da auch keine Budgetentscheidungen
mehr getroffen werden, ist ja dann völlig klar.
Also wir haben es eigentlich mit komplett entwerteter Politik zu tun,
in der ein Kanzler sich verstrickt in irgendwelchen, nicht mal seinen eigenen Bankgeschäften,
um irgendwelche Leute, die auch schon aggressive Steuergestaltung machen,
die sogar noch mit einem Minus davor zu Lasten des deutschen Staates,
also Cum-Ex und so weiter.
Und die einzige Konkurrenz, die er hat, ist Blackrock in Form von Bundeskanzler Merz.
Also wir haben es eigentlich mit einer wirklich ziemlich entleerten politischen
Klasse zu tun, was das angeht. Und das sieht man ja auch hier.
Kevin Kühnert sitzt da und sagt, das ist ja ein dickes Ding.
Und wir sitzen hier und sagen, naja, aber das ist ja auch ein ziemlich dickes
Ding, dass Sie als Politiker da gar nichts machen können.
Das ist doch jetzt ein Skandal in Ihrem Felde.
Sie sind doch der Generalsekretär der Regierungskanzlerpartei.
Sie sind kein Podcaster.
Ja, klar ist das ein dickes Ding. Nur wir wollen jetzt hören, was jetzt daraus folgt.
Wir sind dafür zuständig zu sagen, also das ist ja ein dickes Ding,
dass jetzt jemand im Finanzministerium gegen den Auftrag des Finanzministeriums
arbeitet, der ist, Steuern einzutreiben. Das ist eigentlich irre.
Mein eigener Steuerberater, ich weiß nicht genau, wie die grundsätzlich so drauf
sind, aber meiner ist so in dem Tenor,
Eine Billion Euro und es ist ihnen nicht genug. So, weil die natürlich auch
merken, dass die Finanzämter, wir kriegen sie auch mit auf viele Ebenen,
dass die Finanzämter selber eine ganz schön aggressive Steuergestaltung gerade machen,
in denen sie nämlich wirklich jedem Arsch hinterher gehen und da nochmal und so weiter.
Und man gar nicht mehr dagegen argumentieren kann, es sei denn,
man kommt wirklich mit Anwaltsbriefköpfen und so.
Also der Staat ist ziemlich gut darin, Steuern einzutreiben.
Ja, aber nur bei denen, die sich nicht juristisch dagegen wehren können.
Und gleichzeitig ist der Staat hier
auf Seiten der Superrechte.
Ich glaube, wir brauchen Berufstätige, die Politiker werden und nicht mehr Politiker,
die Berufspolitiker sind.
Du willst eigentlich wieder die Ständerepublik?
Nee, das hat nichts mit Ständerepublik zu tun.
Warte, ich will es nochmal durchdiskutieren. Viele kennen ja das Prinzip nicht,
aber man könnte ja sagen, wir wählen ja den Bundestag nicht als Bundestag,
sondern in 16 Bundesländern.
Wir haben also einen regionalen Proport. Proports.
Warum eigentlich nur in Regionalen? Warum nicht in Berufsfelder Proports?
Dass man einfach sagt, also im Bundestag hier sitzen die Raumpfleger.
So. Wenn wir keine finden, bleiben die Sätze leer.
Also wir müssen innerhalb der Raumpfleger eine Besetzung, weil wir haben festgestellt,
Statistisches Bundesamt, so und so viele Leute pflegen Räume,
die müssen repräsentiert werden.
Und da müssen sie hin. Da kann ja nicht einfach ein Anwalt kommen und sagen,
ich würde gerne auf diesen Posten. Nein, dieses Mandat ist dieser Berufsklasse vorgesehen.
Und wir haben sowas historisch schon mal gehabt. Also wir hatten ja in der Welt
mal sehr viel mehr nach Zünften und so weiter eingeteilt.
Aber das könnte man durchaus nochmal revitalisieren.
Wir haben ausreichend Anwälte und Lehrer im Bundestag. Was ist mit den anderen Berufen?
Die Yvonne Hofstetter hat damals vor zehn Jahren ungefähr so ein Buch gemacht
über Silicon Valley und so weiter und so fort.
Und meinte, 600 Leute im Bundestag, sechs davon haben einen naturwissenschaftlich-technischen Hintergrund.
Sind also Ingenieure, Wissenschaftler oder wie auch immer. Alles andere nicht.
Während gleichzeitig die ganze Zeit darüber geredet wird, dass man das mal mehr
bräuchte in der Zukunft.
Und so. Und dieses Gesamtgefühl. Also wir können, ich finde auch 2024,
das würde auch das Denken sehr verändern.
Wir können das Jahr 2024 mal ausflaggen
als das Jahr, in dem wir mal das Gesamtgefüge wieder besprechen.
Und würde zugleich eine Unabhängigkeit bedeuten, da meine ich jetzt gerade,
also wir wissen von CSU, CDU Leuten, da sind Landwirte, die gehen in den Bundestag,
um für sich Gesetze durchzubringen.
Die gehen als ihre eigenen Lobbyisten da rein.
Die gehen als Chefs der Molkereien, die Milliardenumsatz machen.
Die gehen da rein, nur in eigener Sache.
Das ist völlig klar. Auf der linken Seite, will ich jetzt mal so rubrizierend sagen,
haben wir es mit Leuten zu tun, die durchaus, bevor sie in Amt und Würden sind,
ambitionierte Ziele haben.
Sobald sie aber da drin sind, machen sie nichts mehr in diese Richtung und sagen
dann höchstens noch, oh, das war ein dickes Ding, ich bin wütend.
Und das liegt daran, dass sie in diesem System bleiben müssen,
wenn sie weiterhin diese lukrativen Stellen und alles haben möchten.
Sonst müssten sie dann nochmal schauen, was man mit diesen geisteswissenschaftlichen
Studien, die wir ja auch, wir gehören ja auch zu diesen Leuten,
was man sonst noch machen kann.
Ich hoffe nicht, dass sie jetzt auf die Idee kommen, Podcasts aufzunehmen.
Aber die sind also sehr eng daran gebunden, dass sie da irgendwie ihr Geld verdienen
und müssen sich deshalb in großem Maße anpassen.
Und wenn man aber eine Unabhängigkeit will, wäre gut, wenn das Leute wären,
die auch noch durchaus mal so
sehr auf Konfrontation gehen, dass das möglicherweise deren Stelle kostet.
Aber dann können die wieder in den richtigen Job zurückgehen.
Das ist ja ein bisschen, wie wir das auch beschrieben haben,
also dieser hohe Anpassungsgrad bei vielen jungen Journalisten im Zuge der Ukraine-Berichterstattung,
dass man weiß, okay, es gibt eh kaum noch Stellen hier bei der Zeitung.
Wenn ich jetzt noch quer schlage zu der allgemeinen Losung mehr Waffen an die
Ukraine, dann werde ich auf keinen Fall Chancen auf die Stelle haben.
Und diese finanzielle Abhängigkeit sorgt natürlich auch für eine Meinungsabhängigkeit.
Und ich glaube, dass wir auch eine hohe politische Abhängigkeit deshalb haben,
weil wir es mit sehr vielen Leuten dort zu tun haben, die sagen,
ja, ich verdiene jetzt gut Geld, ich will jetzt das aber auch nicht so schnell wieder verlieren.
Also diese Frau im Finanzministerium, wir gehen jetzt mal, das ist vielleicht
eine Filmidee, so fünf einzelne Szenen, die erstmal nichts miteinander zusammen
zu tun haben, bis man am Ende des Films versteht, wie doch.
Ja.
Wir stellen uns jetzt einfach die Frau im Finanzministerium vor,
die einen klaren Arbeitsauftrag hat, Steuern gestalten, dass der Staat Einnahmen
hat. Sie macht das Gegenteil.
Jetzt stellen wir uns eine Filmszene vor mit einer Kindergärtnerin,
mit einem Kantinenkoch, einem Polizisten, einem Sportlehrer und noch irgendwas.
Wie sähe das aus im Alltag, wenn sie, ohne dass es jemand weiß,
genau das Gegenteil machen?
In der Kantine die Leute vergiften, Kindergarten, die Kinder in den Schlaf singen,
einfach so lange den Hals zu halten, bis sie halt still sind.
So ungefähr. Also das müsste man sich mal visualisieren, was das eigentlich
bedeutet, was hier ein ganz dickes Ding ist, wie Kevin Kühnert sagt.
Ich würde ja sagen, okay, wenn das ein dickes Ding ist, stellt er irgendwie
fest, das ist irgendwie das Gegenteil von dem, was Sinn macht.
Vielleicht macht es Sinn, wenn man das jetzt mal, wenn sie ihren Job wieder
ernst nehme, Vermögenssteuer, Erbschaftssteuer, Reichensteuer.
Auch Christian von Bechtholzheim sieht in höheren Steuern für Reiche vor allem eine Gefahr.
Also von der sogenannten Reichensteuer halte ich aus zwei Gründen nichts.
Erstens ist es allein schon aufgrund seiner Begrifflichkeit eine Stigmatisierung,
die wir in Deutschland uns sparen sollten.
Und zweitens ist es so, dass die Reichensteuer absolut nichts bringt,
sondern genau im Gegenteil. Die wird an dem Rückgrat der deutschen Wirtschaft
sägen, weil der deutsche klassische Reich ist ein mittelständischer Unternehmer.
Das ist der Backbone der deutschen Wirtschaft.
Ja, das ist völlig falsch.
Aber er hat einen sehr schönen Anzug an, oder? Den könnte ich so eins zu eins übernehmen.
Immer wenn es so grün schimmert, bei ihm sieht es auch noch so ins Leder gehende aus.
Toll.
Ist ganz gut. Ja, die Leute wissen halt, ihr Geld auszugeben.
Aber eine Reichensteuer ist stigmatisiert.
Wir würden die ja als reiche ausflacken.
Das ist ein bisschen wie beim Bürgergeld, ne?
Ne, das Bürgergeld, wie Carsten Lindemann sagt, geht auch begrifflich in die
falsche Richtung. Wir zahlen es ja auch an Nichtbürger. Also sind wir auch wieder
kurz vor dem Ungeziefer.
Achso, ja.
Ja. Ja. In letzter Clip eine Doku von Dreisat.
Ich habe einfach eine Mediathek, was gibt es zum Thema Superreiche.
Bei Dreisat gab es eine ganz interessante, wo auch mal den Milliardären so gefolgt wurde.
Und dann stehen sie in irgendwelchen Schulen und kriegen da quasi eine Privatvorführung,
weil sie ja das Orchester finanzieren und solche Sachen.
Also da, wenn der Staat ausfällt, hat man halt zum Glück dann immer mal noch
einen Milliardär an der Ecke, der da wohnt und sich kümmert.
Wo haben diese Leute ihr Geld her? Die reden jetzt mit dem Hapag-Lloyd-Chef,
also Reederei, Hamburg und so weiter.
Der so, weil wir jetzt immer denken, die haben ihre Steuern ja so gestaltet,
aggressiv Steuer gestaltet und so.
Wir hören ihm mal zu, wie er darüber
redet, wo sein ganzes vom Staat nicht eingesacktes Vermögen herkommt.
Kritiker sagen, das sei obszön wenig, was da in die Steuerkasse fließt.
Bei den derzeitigen Erträgen von Alper Lloyd ist das völlig richtig.
Das heißt, sie finden es selber gerade so ein bisschen schwierig,
dass sie so viel verdienen daran. Ja, das ist richtig, ja. Ach, das ist zu viel.
Das ist zu viel. Wesentlich zu viel. Ich habe mir das ja nicht ausgedacht.
Ich war selbst überrascht, als ich so erstmal dahinter kam, wie diese Tonnagesteuer
abgerechnet wird. Das ist ein Anachronismus.
Da es das in allen anderen Branchen nicht gibt, finde ich es auch ein bisschen
komisch, sage ich ehrlich.
Ja, da freut sich einer.
Da ist halt einfach so ein Steuerloch. Als ich das gesehen habe,
habe ich auch gedacht, das ist ja pervers.
Aber er ist ein großer Opernfan und er wirkt aber von allen,
die wir jetzt da gehört haben, wirkt er sympathisch, oder?
Er kann sich's halt eingestehen.
Vielleicht kannst du dich mit ihm mal austauschen, wie er Martha findet.
Oh ja. Meinst du, wir sind auf einer Wellenlänge?
Möglicherweise.
Der gute Kitsch.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass ihr beide...
So eine Kitsch-Aversion.
Ich sehe euch da beide demnächst in der Oper Frankfurt in Reihe eins sitzen
und da freut ihr euch an Martha.
So, ich hab noch noch zwei Clips, nur um noch dieses Thema mal abzubinden, wie man so schön sagt.
Wir hören, auch hier ist wieder die Reihenfolge entscheidend,
wir hören mal zuerst Robin Alexander.
Robin Alexander macht in seinem Podcast,
Machtwechsel am 14.12. Er fädelt das einfach so ein, als Wortlaut.
Ich würde sagen, wir sind hier kurz vor dem latenten, wahre Denken von ihm.
Wir haben immer noch im Hinterkopf Gemeinwohl. Was ist das Gemeinwohl?
Wer hat was davon und so weiter? Brauchen wir so allgemeine Investitionen,
das Allgemeine an alle Denkende oder nur noch partikularistische Interessen?
Und bei Robin Alexander klingt das hier, wenn er einfach so dahin redet, so.
Deshalb glaube ich auch, ist Habeck einer der Sieger dieser Verhandlungen.
Das Verfassungsgericht hat ja seinen Etat gekürzt. Die 60 Milliarden,
die die gestrichen haben, sind ja 60 Habeck-Milliarden, nämlich in diesem Klima-
und Transformationsfonds.
Also der Meteorit ist bei ihm eingeschlagen.
Wenn man sich jetzt anguckt, hat er ja gleich zwei Wege gefunden,
diesen Klima- und Transformationsfonds wieder aufzufüllen.
Und so diese Idee, dass...
Das Bundesverfassungsgericht ein Torpedo auf Habecks, weil der ja für Klima
zuständig ist, statt dass das Klima einfach uns allen zugutekommt, wenn wir es retten.
Und dass es auch wenig Sinn macht, im Buchungsgefüge Bundeshaushalt und Sondervermögen
zu unterscheiden zwischen,
nee, das sind ja die völlig unantastbaren 110 Milliarden für die Rente und hier
ist ja das kleine Beiboot fürs Klima, das können wir einfach weg nuken,
weil da haben wir also Möglichkeiten,
das Urteil so zu beschreiben, dass es unterscheidet zwischen Kernhaushalt und
Sondervermögen und so weiter. Und es hat ja das Sondervermögen getroffen.
Das sagt ja selbst Christian Lindner. Das sind nur Buchungsfragen gewesen.
Wir hätten genauso gut sagen können, nee, Klima ist so wichtig,
kommt natürlich in den Kernhaushalt.
Rente, so elementar, so speziell, Sondervermögen. Dann hätte das Bundesverfassungsgericht
eben auf die Rente geschossen.
Also wie man hier überhaupt bei einem politischen Thema wie dem Klima ein partikularistisches,
naja, das ist halt Habecks Ding, kommen kann, zeigt schon, mit diesem Journalismus
ist auch nicht viel Start zu machen, in diesem Sinne.
Also fast wortwörtlich so gemeint, mit diesem Journalismus ist kein Start zu machen.
Und da wir hier von einem Springer-Journalisten sprechen, müssen wir noch kurz
anmerken, der Vollständigkeit halber, dass ja Springer nun kooperiert mit OpenAI.
Um es noch döfer zu machen, das ist Akzenterismus, glaube ich.
Also man kann jetzt auch dann dann davon ausgehen, dass es dann bald bei ChatGPT
so einen Springer-Bias geben wird,
dass man also dort in verschiedenen Fragen, zum Beispiel Fragen der Umverteilung,
wenn man die dann ChatGPT stellt, vermutlich,
sehr Springer-konforme Antworten bekommt.
Und Springer ist ja nicht nur die Bild-Zeitung, liebe Leute.
Also Springer expandiert ganz stark in den USA.
Die haben ja Politico aufgekauft. Also wir haben uns im Frühjahr,
wir ja hier auch selbst selbst im Salon, mit den Fragen beschäftigt,
welcher Chefredakteur bei Bild mit Redakteurin XY was hatte.
Das ist was für Boulevardfernsehen. Aber die wirklich entscheidenden Dinge sind
gerade dort zu beobachten, wenn man sieht,
welche Führungsrolle Deutschland gerne einnehmen möchte in Europa und ja auch
die stärkste Volkswirtschaft in Europa ist.
Dann kann man sich ausmalen, dass also Springer hier einen guten Punkt sieht,
um wirklich international einflussreich zu werden in der Meinungsbildung.
Also ich glaube, diese ganzen Abgesänge, das kommt ja dann immer alle drei Monate,
wenn es diese neuen Statistiken gibt über Auflagenschwund bei allen Zeitungen.
Haha, die Bild-Zeitung hat wieder an Auflage verloren.
Lasst doch bitte mal diese Kinder rein und guckt euch mal an,
wohin dieser Konzern expandiert, was diese Verbindung mit KKR denen gebracht hat.
Also das ist das Interessante, was man recherchieren muss und nicht,
ob da irgendwelche Affären nicht so ganz sauber gelaufen sind.
Ja und dazu kann man auch eine Schreibung machen.
Um eine Redakteurin, die war bei dem Chefredakteur.
Und dabei war der Chefredakteur schon längst weg.
Der Skandal war eigentlich schon abgefrühstückt. Gut, letzter Clip.
Achim Truger bei unseren Freunden im Corporate Therapy Podcast,
der uns nochmal auf jüngste historische Entwicklung und was sie uns verdeutlichen.
Welche Lehre steckt in Corona?
Die Corona-Pandemie und jetzt auch die Energiekrise, die haben doch eigentlich
nochmal gezeigt, zeigt, worum es geht.
Denn da waren tatsächlich die Dinge, die wichtig sind, nämlich die Gesundheit,
jetzt das Heizen, materielle Lebensgrundlagen, das schien plötzlich nicht mehr gesichert.
Da gab es einfach die wichtigen Dinge, Medikamente, die kamen nicht mehr.
Und das ist genau der Punkt. Ich glaube, dass man da eine Rückbesinnung braucht
und in einem viel breiteren Sinne eine Wohlfahrts- oder Wohlstandsorientierung
braucht und sich da ganz klare Kriterien macht, was ist wichtig.
Und da gehört übrigens diese öffentliche Daseinsvorsorge auch zentral dazu.
Ja, Daseinsvorsorge, Allgemeinwohl, Gemeinwohl, alles so schwammige Begriffe.
Ich bin ja bei Balance auch dafür geworben, die soften Begriffe nochmal in den
Grundbegriffskatalog aufzunehmen.
Ist ja auch wieder nötig, damit man mal wieder richtige Diskussionen führt und
auch weiß, wo so eine superreiche Doku eigentlich zu verorten ist.
Die traf ja irgendwie so auf so eine Gesellschaft, schafft die schon völlig,
ja, haben die echt so viel Geld und cool und so.
Sondern nee, da muss man ja nochmal das, das hat ja Aussagekraft.
Ich finde das immer so schade, es gibt ja diese wirklich herausragende Doku,
wir empfehlen sie noch einmal ausdrücklich und dann geht aber so wenig davon los.
Ja, gar nichts.
Also man hätte gerne das als den Aufschlag und jetzt geht's weiter, aber nein.
Und dann sagen auch viele dann, ja, gut, dass wir die mal gesehen haben,
und dann kann man sich erhoffen, dass Julia Friedrichs in einem Jahr wieder
eine schöne Doku macht, aber ich hätte gerne mal, dass da ein wirklicher Impact vorausgeht.
Und das bedeutet, Christian Lindner muss weg.
Zum Beispiel.
Wegen staatsschädlichem Verhalten.
Wir sprechen über die Ukraine und ich beginne mal mit einem Text in der FAZ
erschienen, einem Kommentar von Reinhard Müller, darüber ein Wort, Pflicht vergessen.
Moment mal, Reinhard Müller ist doch der Typ, der mir im Presseclub gegenüber
saß, der ist aus der Wirtschaftsredaktion. Was hat denn der jetzt mit der Ukraine zu tun?
Schreibt wieder jeder, was er will in der FAZ.
Er schreibt, wie soll man das verstehen? Zitat, dass wir nun Menschen gegen
ihren Willen zu einer Wehrpflicht oder zu einem Kriegsdienst zwingen,
das wird nicht der Fall sein, sagt Bundesjustizminister Marco Buschmann.
Zunächst ist es Deutschland ohnehin
kaum möglich, jemanden zu einem Kriegsdienst im Ausland zu zwingen.
Im Fall der Ukraine geht es aber auch nicht darum, dass eine Diktatur junge
Männer in einem mörderischen Vernichtungsfeldzug verheizt, hier müsste man nach
Russland blicken, sondern darum,
dass ein demokratisches Land seine Bürger in einem Verteidigungskrieg in die Pflicht nimmt.
Eine Pflicht ist eine Pflicht, selbst wenn sie nicht immer durchgesetzt werden kann.
Schreibt man aus dem FAZ-Büro, wo man sicher sein kann, ich muss nicht mehr an die Front.
Das ist, wenn der Capri-Sonn-Milliardär sagt, das ist eine akademische Debatte,
ob jetzt hier 25% der Kinder Armut oder so. Das ist hier auch.
Landesverteidigung, akademische Sache, ich schreibe das mal so auf.
Eine Pflicht ist eine Pflicht und ich habe mir gedacht, wir gehen diesem Diskurs
mal nach, denn er ist im Dezember sehr laut geworden.
Wir hören jetzt zunächst hier ein Interview, Paul Ronsheimer hat das geführt
mit dem ukrainischen Verteidigungsminister Umjerov.
Herr Minister, gestern hat Präsident Zelensky mehr Rekruten gefordert.
Gleichzeitig sehen wir, dass es viele ukrainische Männer gibt,
die nicht zum Wehrdienst eingezogen werden wollen.
Und ich habe gehört, dass Deutschland auch Ausbildungen durchführt,
aber das sind nur 50 Prozent der Menschen.
Die eigentlich zur Ausbildung hätten kommen können. Was machen Sie als Minister,
wenn die Menschen nicht mehr weiter kämpfen wollen?
Erst einmal sollten die Menschen verstehen, dass Präsident Zelensky gesagt hat,
wo sie hingehen, wie lange sie dort bleiben müssen und wann sie dort wieder wegkommen.
Wir legen diese Regeln fest, gemeinsam mit den Streitkräften und mit allen.
Diese Regeln sind noch gar nicht festgelegt und wir werden jetzt erleben,
dass Mirov permanent ausweicht.
Also ich habe jetzt nur ein paar Clips davon mitgebracht. Das Interview geht
über 20 Minuten, aber eigentlich beantwortet er nicht eine Frage konkret,
sagt aber doch relativ ausschlussreiche oder beängstigende Dinge.
Wie viele mehr Soldaten benötigen Sie? Es gibt einen Bedarf für diejenigen,
die wir jetzt rotieren müssen.
Und da es ja einen laufenden Krieg schon gibt, eigentlich seit zehn Jahren,
und dann die vollumfängliche Invasion in den letzten beiden Jahren,
muss es auch einen Dienst geben.
Die Frage war also, wie lange wird jemand, der jetzt in diesen Dienst gerufen
wird, dann dort bleiben muss, um dann wieder entlassen zu werden?
Oder geben wir ihm vielleicht nach zwei, drei Jahren erst einmal Zeit zur Erholung?
Oder soll es ein Fünfjahreszeitraum oder Sechsjahreszeitraum sein?
Das ist alles noch in der Diskussion. Wir bemühen uns aber, dass wir jeden in
diese Diskussion mit einbeziehen.
Ja, jeden mit einbeziehen ist natürlich auch eine Lüge, da man ja weiß,
wie diese Entscheidungen gefällt werden.
Und wir reden also jetzt darüber, dass man zwei, drei, fünf oder sechs Jahre
in einen Krieg ziehen soll.
Also diese Normalisierung des Krieges, des großen Kampfes, das ist schon wie
in dieser Literatur eigentlich.
Dass man dann schon so Rotierungs-, Rotations-, Urlaubsplanung und so weiter,
das schon als Mitarbeiterführungsproblem ausflagt, wie beim letzten Mal besprochen. Ja.
Wir hören mal noch weiter.
Dann eingezogen werden soll, unter Vertrag genommen werden soll,
mobil gemacht werden soll.
Ja, russische Propaganda soll das dann sein. Nun ja, es ist ja definitiv so,
dass viele Ukrainer nicht kämpfen wollen, aber sie gar keine Stimme bekommen.
Ronsheimer werden wir jetzt gleich nochmal dazu hören. Er ist ja einer der wenigen, muss man ja sagen,
der trotz all dieser Nähe, die er da hat zu der politischen Führung in der Ukraine,
immer wieder auch mal erwähnt hat,
dass es da Leute gibt, die nicht kämpfen wollen und auch immer das in die Öffentlichkeit
gebracht hat, während das bei den anderen ja völlig unthematisiert blieb und
wenn man sich das mal klar macht, also wir reden jetzt darüber,
dass dort Männer, die sich entschieden haben oder es irgendwie geschafft haben,
dieses Land zu verlassen, Dass man jetzt über die reden will,
wie man die wieder an die Front bekommt oder überhaupt an die Front bekommt
und wie man auch die Männer, die im Land noch sind in der Ukraine und nicht
kämpfen, wie man die auch da einziehen kann und es gibt keinen Aufschrei.
Also ich finde das, ich meine wir wundern uns jetzt seit Monaten darüber,
aber das kann doch alles gar nicht sein.
Also es kann doch nicht sein, dass wir diese Diskussionen über neue Männlichkeit die ganze Zeit führen.
Dass wir all diese Sensibilitäten da an den Tag legen und die sind ja mitunter
auch berechtigt wegen mir.
Aber dass man dann hier völlig unsensibel ist oder gilt es dann am Ende doch,
dass man sagt, naja, aber am Ende sind es auch nur Männer.
Also das ist ja so ein bisschen mein Verdacht. Ich klinge jetzt natürlich wie
ein Männerrechtler, aber das macht mir gar nichts.
Ich finde es sehr interessant, dass wir zumindest mediale Diskurse hatten, wenn Leute….
Wenn mit Leuten irgendwas angestellt werden sollte von Seiten des Staates,
dann hat man immer wieder internationale Aufschreie produziert.
Jetzt geht es hier um Männer, die kämpfen sollen und offenbar sich nicht zum
Kampf bereit erklärt haben.
Und es gibt da keinen internationalen Aufschrei.
Ich würde schon sagen, dass das damit zusammenhängt, dass man jetzt einen sehr
starken Diskurs hat, naja, aber Aber die Männer können ja jetzt auch eh nie
Opfer von irgendwas sein.
Und deswegen thematisieren wir die auch jetzt gar nicht als Opfer.
Also ich glaube schon, dass es so eine, ich traue mich das zu sagen,
dass es das Unbewusste bewusst in vielen Leuten gibt, dass man sagt,
naja, es sind auch nur Männer.
Oder, naja, am Ende müssen das ja wohl auch Männer tun.
Also warum müssen es eigentlich Männer tun? Also könnte man ja auch mal feministisch
drauf blicken und sagen, Ich meine diese Hightech-Sachen oder so bedienen,
können Frauen gleichermaßen gut.
Ich will jetzt aber nicht dafür anstiften, dass man jetzt noch die Frauen an
die Front schickt, sondern ich will eher mal darauf aus sein,
dass man doch das als etwas eigentlich mal vollkommen breit akzeptiertes gesehen
hat, dass man niemanden zwingt in den Krieg zu ziehen.
Also das war die ganze Diskussion 2015, dass wir sagten, natürlich sollen die
aus Syrien und sonst woher zu uns fliehen können.
Da waren es nur AfD-Leute, die sagten, ja wenn Krieg ist, dann hat man zu kämpfen,
dann hat man nicht in andere Länder zu fliehen.
Ich finde auch im Verhältnis zu dieser Gemeinwohldiskussion,
du hast es ja mal am Beispiel des Volksbegriffs, dass da plötzlich so ein,
weil klar können wir jetzt sagen, die Männer, aber wir können auch sagen,
es ist sowieso ein komisches Gefüge,
dass die Frage ungeklärt ist, für was die da eigentlich kämpfen und dann ja auch sterben sollen.
Und dann heißt es irgendwie, ja für die Zukunft der Ukraine.
Für die Ukraine in der Europäischen Union oder was auch immer.
Weil, was heißt denn das alles? Also das, was denen da fehlt und wofür die auf
die Straße gegangen sind und
diese ganze EU-Anbandelung ist doch beispielsweise Thema Freizügigkeit.
Und individuelle Lebensfindung, so wie wir das halt ganz selbstverständlich hier machen.
Und weshalb wir ja auch sagen, hier gibt es so viel zu verteidigen im Vergleich
zu China oder was auch immer.
Und der Weg dahin ist aber, denen genau das zu nehmen. Und das passt einfach nicht zusammen.
Denn wir sehen ja auch an Olaf Scholz dieser Spruch, die Ukraine darf den Krieg nicht verlieren.
Ja.
Ohne auszusprechen, soll sie ihn deswegen gewinnen oder was.
Und da hört man ja bei Olaf Scholz auch nur so ein ganz großes historisches
Verständnis von nein, in Europa darf nicht der Präzedenzfall dafür geschaffen
werden, dass Grenzen wieder verschoben sind.
Also darf die Ukraine nicht verlieren. Das Verlieren wird festgemacht am vollzogenen
Kretzverlauf. Also eine Verschiebung eines Grenzverlaufs. So.
In diesem Gedankengang ist der Einzelne komplett ausgeblendet.
Also spielt einfach gar nichts eine Rolle. Es ist einfach nur,
also historisch darf einfach, Grenzen dürfen nicht verzogen werden und wenn
das der Weg ist, dann muss das der Weg sein.
Und dann individuell handelt er aber ganz anders. Also da kommt dann diese Kritik
an ausbleibender Finanzierung.
Dann heißt es ja, Deutschland finanziert am meisten nach Amerika.
Ja, Deutschland ist ja auch das größte Land und am Ende sind es doch nur 8 Milliarden.
Und die werden nicht mal im Haushalt irgendwie besonders gewürdigt,
weil Friedrich Merz, also nicht mal da setzt er sich dann durch,
um seine große, die Grenzen dürfen nicht verschoben werden, Doktrinen durchzusetzen.
Also in der Hinsicht haben wir eh ein ganz komisches Gefüge.
Und ich meine dieses Gebiet, um das es da geht in der Ukraine.
Und das kann man mir jetzt, was ich sage, ganz falsch auslegen.
Aber das ist nicht verteidigungswürdig.
Also da würde auch niemand leben wollen. Niemand will in ein Gebiet,
das so weit entwickelt, so fortentwickelt ist, dass da die...
Sachen noch mit Eseln über die Straße gezogen werden. Das ist einfach nicht
unser Lebensstandard und da kann man doch erstmal sagen, okay,
uns geht erstmal nichts verloren, wenn für diese Landstreifen nicht nochmal 100.000 Leute sterben.
Ja und über solche Zahlen reden wir ja. Wir wissen zwar keine konkreten Zahlen
aus der Ukraine, aber wir können jetzt mal hochrechnen, dann wären wir wahrscheinlich
auf russischer und ukrainischer Seite auf, weiß ich nicht, sind das 250.000 jetzt inzwischen?
Viele, viele, man weiß es ja auch nicht. Es wird halt ausgeblendet.
In dem Maße, wie der Verteidigungsminister hier nicht sagt, wie viele Männer er noch braucht.
Er sagt dann zum Rotieren, ich würde sagen zum Sterben. Er ist ja auch nicht
bereit zu sagen, wie viele Tote müssen denn ersetzt werden.
Wir sind hier bei Im Westen nichts Neues.
Wenn der David Striesow da in seiner Rolle sagt, wenn wir jetzt noch bis März
durchhalten, dann ist Frühling, dann kommt der neue Jahrgang.
Und jetzt nochmal, Ronsheimer hakt jetzt sehr gut nach bei dieser Sache,
das ist halt russische Propaganda.
Sie haben gesagt, dass die russische Propaganda sich richtet und dass sie behauptet,
die russischen Soldaten, die ukrainischen Soldaten möchten nicht dienen.
Aber wir haben auch mit Menschen gesprochen, die gesagt haben,
dass sie Angst haben, dass sie Geschichten hören von Menschen,
die von der Straße weggefangen werden und dann direkt in die Ausbildungslager
gesteckt werden und an die Front geschickt werden. Das ist eine Realität.
Ja, sehr gut, dass er das macht.
Ja, nicht nur Realität, sondern das ist ja der Kern, um den es eigentlich geht.
Einzelschicksale, aufsummiert in ganz viele, aber die trotzdem Einzelschicksale bleiben.
Und wenn jetzt so ein Ukrainer mehr Angst hat vor der eigenen Regierung als
vor der russischen, ist das auch ein echtes Problem in diesem Gesamtgefüge.
Und man muss auch sagen, die europäische Verantwortung, wenn Russland die Ukraine
nicht angegriffen hätte, wäre das für uns weiter, ja, dann bauen die halt unser
Getreide an, ohne dass wir auch nur ein Euro aus unserem hunderten Milliarden
EU-Haushalt für Bauern da ausgeben.
Hat uns nie interessiert. Genau, es hat uns nie interessiert.
Wir haben das in einen Zustand gebracht und gelassen, dass es eigentlich nicht
verteidigungswürdig ist.
Und jetzt soll irgendwer da für uns sterben. Also diese Anspruchshaltung Europas
gegen die Randgebiete hat auch diese literarische Qualität.
Also das liest sich wie in diesen Horrorbüchern.
Ja und zugleich sind wir so sensibilisiert, was Gewalt angeht.
Also wir haben eine riesen Debatte gehabt über Will Smith.
Er steht auf und haut dem anderen eine runter, weil die Frau von Will Smith beleidigt wurde.
Und dann sagt man, das geht nicht. Also in einer Zivilisation,
die es so weit gebracht hat, kann man jetzt nicht immer auf Bühnen stürmen und
Leuten eine runterhauen.
Und das ist also schon so ein Punkt, bei dem man sagt, dass das gegen unser
Empfinden, also diese Gewalt haben wir nicht mehr.
Es gibt zwar strukturelle Gewalt und es gibt Institutionen, die dafür sorgen,
dass Gewalttäter auch dann vielleicht eingesperrt werden, all das haben wir.
Aber dass ich jetzt mit dir rede und wir gleich eine Auseinandersetzung haben
und dann schlagen wir uns mal kurz und dann setzen wir uns wieder zusammen, wäre völlig undenkbar.
Das ist völlig undenkbar, also da ist man hoch sensibilisiert und das würde
ich als einen großen Fortschritt ansehen.
Und zugleich haben wir diese abstrakten Zahlen plus paar Einzelschicksale,
wenn sie uns mal in Reportagen gezeigt werden, 100.000 Tote,
also einfach ganz Koblenz tot.
Das ist auf einer Seite und auf der anderen Seite dann auch nochmal.
Es ist so unglaublich. Naja und dann hört man solche Sätze hier.
Ich habe ja gesagt, das war die Verantwortung unserer Streitkräfte.
Und da sie sich auf den Krieg konzentriert haben, waren keine guten Vorbereitungen
getroffen worden für die Einstellungsverfahren und Rekrutierungsverfahren.
Als Minister musste ich mich natürlich für einen Volleinsatz vorbereiten.
Möchten Sie die Menschen zwingen, an die Front zu gehen?
Nein, was wir sagen ist, das ist
ja keine Strafe, für das eigene Land einzutreten und dem Land zu dienen.
Das ist eine Ehre. Wir möchten aber auch dafür sorgen, dass jemand,
der in die Streitkräfte kommt,
in die Verteidigungskräfte aufgenommen wird, auch versteht, wie er ausgebildet
wird, wie er ausgerüstet wird, wie er dient, wo er dient und wann er dann auch
wieder entlassen wird aus dem Dienst.
Im Live-Salon haben wir eine Umfrage gemacht, wer ist bereit im Verteidigungsfalle
für Deutschland zu kämpfen.
Anderthalb Leute.
Und es haben sich zwei Leute gemeldet und wir sind 200 gewesen in der Case.
Das heißt ein Prozent wäre bereit. Das ist allerdings nicht repräsentativ, muss man sagen.
Wir hatten diese Sternenumfrage, da sind etwa, ich habe die Zahl nicht ganz
genau im Kopf, 18 Prozent würden auf jeden Fall kämpfen.
18 Prozent oder 19 Prozent sagen wahrscheinlich ja und dann nochmal 18,
19 Prozent unschlüssig und dann so 40 Prozent, die sagen auf keinen Fall und
das finde ich schon besorgniserregend viel.
Ich will auch einen Artikel kurz zitieren aus der FAZ, da schreibt Julian Steib über Finnland.
In Finnland wird regelmäßig die Bevölkerung zu ihrer Verteidigungsbereitschaft befragt.
Da sieht es anders aus. aus im Herbst 2022.
Da gab es auf diese Frage im Falle eines Angriffs auf ihr Land würden auf jeden Fall zur Waffe greifen.
83 Prozent.
Höher war die Zustimmung nie. Am niedrigsten war sie 1970, da lag sie bei 42 Prozent.
Finnland hat ja diese Grenze zu Russland, die ja jetzt auch zum NATO-Beitritt
wurde. Und ich könnte mir auch vorstellen, dass man sehr gut weiß,
dass bei solchen Umfragen der Russe mithört.
Das mag sein.
Die Frage ist ja konkret, willst du uns gegen Russland verteidigen?
Ja, ja, im Prinzip schon.
Und dann sagt man natürlich ja.
Ich würde das auch machen. Wenn ich Binde wäre, würde ich jemanden fragen und
ich würde sagen, natürlich.
Du bist da optimistisch.
Das ist sozialkonformes Antworten, das steckt in jeder Umfrage drin.
Da ist sicherlich ein Punkt da, aber ich befürchte auch, das wird uns über die
nächsten Jahrzehnte begleiten.
Mal sehen, ich bin mir nicht so sicher. Ich sage es nochmal,
vielleicht ist der Klimawandel nicht unser drängendstes Problem.
Die Debatten werden sich verändern. Wir sehen das schon bei Gaza,
wie über einfache Zerstörung demnächst anders gesprochen wird.
Einfach weil einfach dieses Ausmaß so monströs ist. Bei der Ukraine werden wir auch dran reden.
Wir haben es jetzt auch mit einer demografischen Wende zu tun.
Wir werden in den kommenden Jahren diese alte Losung von Krieg heißt mit einem
Panzer Raumgewinne machen, werden wir komplett aussortieren.
Es wird in Kriegen um andere Sachen gehen, insbesondere wenn wir dann diese
digitalen, also wir werden ja sowieso durch die ganze AI-Wende jetzt 2024 so
einen ganz großen Schwenk im Denken haben, weil das einfach an jedem Arbeitsplatz eine Rolle spielt.
Solange man am Computer sitzt und arbeitet und das machen 100% der Deutschen
so gefühlt, spielt das einfach eine große Rolle.
Und unter der Fragestellung, was ist hier eigentlich Gefahr?
Wie verteidige ich mich? Kann ich mich alleine verteidigen? Bin ich auf jemanden
angewiesen? Und so weiter und so fort.
Werden wir, glaube ich, ganz neue Bedrohungs- und Kriegsdiskussionen führen.
Aber hier geht es ja noch um Menschen.
Genau, aber mit dem Ukraine-Krieg werden wir dieses alte Bild vom Krieg,
glaube ich, wirklich aussortieren.
Mögest du recht haben oder ersetzen sich Leute wie Roderich Kiesewetter von
der CDU durch, der Folgendes im Interview sagte.
Und wenn wir jetzt mehr tun als nur wir unterstützen so lange wie es nötig ist,
sondern mit so viel wie möglich, so rasch wie möglich auch unserer Bevölkerung
deutlich machen, dass das eine Rückversicherung ist für uns selbst.
Dann hat die Ukraine jede Chance, diesen Krieg zu gewinnen.
Und das sollten wir auch deutlich machen und anerkennen, was die Ukraine hier
bisher geleistet hat. Wir sollten ihr auch vertrauen.
Und wir müssen auch an einen Faktor denken, dass hunderttausende männliche Ukrainer
im wehrfähigen Alter ihr Land verlassen haben.
Hier gilt es auch zu appellieren, dass sie mithelfen, dass nicht die Menschen
an der Front verbluten, sondern dass sie entlastet werden.
Dass frisch ausgebildetes Personal an der Front unterstützt.
Allein in Deutschland leben über 200.000 wehrfähige junge ukrainische Männer
oder junge Wehrfähige zwischen 16 und 60.
Hier geht es also auch darum, dass wir mithelfen, dass diese in ihr Heimatland
zurückkehren und dort beispielsweise bei Feuerwehr helfen im Katastrophenschutz.
Sie müssen ja nicht an die Front, aber sie müssen mithelfen,
dass die ukrainische Gesellschaft das Ganze übersteht.
Wir können es nicht aus der Westentasche leisten und wir müssen auch deutlich
machen, dass es mit einer bestimmten
Haltung zu verbinden, nämlich der Wehrfähigkeit und Wehrhaftigkeit.
Das bedeutet doch jetzt, wir werden demnächst Kriegsflüchtlinge haben,
die beispielsweise in England, Amerika oder Spanien aufschlagen und sagen,
sie sind vor dem Ukraine-Krieg geflüchtet.
Dann wird man fragen, ah kommst du aus der Ukraine? Ne, aus Deutschland.
Das ist doch die Diskussion, die wir hier bekommen. Das ist doch völlig absurd, diese Idee.
Ich meine, diese CDU kommt auf Ideen beim Thema Menschen und Raum zuordnen.
Und ab 16 Jahren jetzt schon. Also wir gehen nochmal zwei Jahre runter.
Also man kann schon minderjährig, man kann nicht wählen, man kann tausend andere
Dinge nicht machen, aber man darf schon mal sterben oder dann nur so an der Front arbeiten.
Man müsste ja nicht unbedingt kämpfen, meint dann der Oberst.
Was stellt er sich denn vor, dass die ukrainischen Flüchtlinge männlich hier
ganz akkurate Staatsbürger im Sinne der CDU sind, denen also nur noch der Brief fehlt,
den sie lesen, wo drin steht, sie müssen jetzt in die Ukraine fahren und dann
kaufen sie sich ein Ticket und fahren in die Ukraine.
Man müsste die doch hier genauso von der Laterne, an die sie sich klammern,
wegfischen, sie in ein Auto verfrachten und dann nonstop in die Ukraine fahren,
damit die überhaupt da ankommen. Das ist doch absurd.
Das ist genau wie diese Idee von Kriegsflüchtlingen aus aller Welt.
Nee, die werden ab sofort nur noch über Uganda nach Deutschland einreisen.
Und das wissen auch alle.
Und die werden dann nicht mehr die Flüchtlingsströme wie bisher und im Mittelmeer
und so, sondern die werden alle nach Uganda gehen, wenn sie nach Deutschland wollen.
Einfach nur, also das ist so dieses magisches Denken.
Wir denken uns eine Realität aus, die im Fernsehen gut funktioniert,
aber das ist völlig hanebüchig.
Worum es ihm eigentlich geht?
Wenn die Ukraine zerfällt, sind die Folgekosten viel größer,
als wenn wir jetzt viel stärker reingehen.
Und wenn Europa die Energiewende vollziehen will, braucht es die eigenen Lithiumvorkommen.
Die größten Lithiumvorkommen in Europa liegen im Donetsk-Luhansk-Gebiet.
Deswegen will Russland diese auch, um uns abhängig zu machen von der Energiewende
mit Blick auf Elektromotoren.
Also wir haben hier auch ganz andere Ziele noch im Hintergrund.
Und deshalb brauchen wir eine vereinte Anstrengung der Bürgerinnen und Bürger,
damit unsere Politik die Rückendeckung hat, mehr für die Ukraine zu tun und
dass kein Gelände an Russland geht.
Ja, also die Ukrainer sollen sterben.
Und wir sollen unser Geld sparen für die Autoakkus.
Denn das soll nicht den Russen zufallen. Also man sieht es ja in schönster Transparenz.
Es sind keine investigativen Interviews, weil jetzt ARD und ZDF,
die fragen einfach so nach, was wäre denn jetzt zu tun?
Und dann kommt das alles so. Also das kommt alles so raus.
Lässt sich vielleicht aber noch steigern durch Ulrich Reitz,
das ist der Chefredakteur vom Fokus, der auch dann in so einer Videokolumne
immer wieder mal zu uns spricht,
und er hat sich auch gestört an diesem Satz von Buschmann, dass man jetzt nicht
Menschen gegen ihren Willen in den Krieg schicken kann.
Ulrich Reitz ist jetzt Chefredakteur vom Fokus?
Ich meine schon.
Ich war, der war ja auch mal mit mir im Presseclub, wo ich ihn festlegen wollte
auf was ist denn jetzt die Schuldenbremse und dann sagte er der Markenkern der
CDU, von dem kann Kann sie nicht abrücken.
Und das war die Erklärung. Ja, das sind die verantwortlichen Leute in Deutschland.
Sehr gut. Ja, ich bin gespannt, was sie da sagen.
Unser Bundesjustizminister Marco Buschmann, der hat gesagt, wir werden doch
Menschen nicht in den Kriegsdienst zwingen.
Das machen wir ja in Deutschland nicht.
Also warum sollten wir das mit Ukrainern machen, die hier sind?
Ich finde, so einfach geht es nicht.
Wie würden wir uns dann verhalten, wenn Russland uns angreifen würde?
Oder was ja immerhin bei Militärstrategen ein mögliches Szenario ist in 6 Jahren.
Also Ulrich Reitz würde einfach seine Kolumne weiterschreiben,
vermutlich dann aus dem Ausland.
Oder 7 Jahren. Würden wir dann auch sagen, wir zwingen keine Menschen in den
Kriegsdienst, wenn ein Land angegriffen würde.
Das ist aber genau die Situation in der Ukraine.
Also wir haben ja eine ganz wichtige Diskussion, die wird ja von sehr vielen
immer da hinsichtlich abgeschottet.
Die Ukraine entscheidet über Schicksal selbst. Wann sie verhandeln,
welche Waffen sie einsetzen, wie auch immer. Wir unterstützen nur.
Wir schicken halt, was wir können und so weiter und so fort.
Üblicherweise haben wir Probleme damit, wenn andere Länder plötzlich Polizeifilialen
bei uns aufmachen und sagen, wir setzen mal unser Recht bei euch durch.
Wie zum Beispiel die Chinesen. Die dann einfach mal flächendeckend die Leute wegsortieren.
Die in die Vorlesung kommen und gucken.
Plötzlich ist in Fulda so eine Polizeizentrale und da werden auch Verhöre stattgefunden.
Was ist jetzt das Szenario, Herr Reitz? Dass die Ukraine zwar ganz alleine entscheidet,
wie das ukrainische Schicksal, wir unterstützen nur.
Und die Ukraine ist die ukrainische Regierung, ist das Volk.
Und die Unterstützung heißt dann, Amtshilfe, also deutsche Polizei,
kassiert dann Ukraine ein auf deutscher Straße und entführt die dahin,
damit die dann auf ukrainischen Gebieten, der ukrainischen Polizei und so weiter, das ist doch...
Ich dachte, man braucht auch Leute, die vielleicht eine gewisse Sinnhaftigkeit,
Verständnis, wie auch immer, deswegen ja dieser ganze Propaganda-Apparat.
Das scheint mir jetzt schon im Sinne von, ja die Russen tricksen ja ihre Soldaten
alle mit Propaganda rein.
Wir machen gar keine Propaganda mehr. Wir zwingen sie einfach mit Waffengewalt
in den Krieg. Das ist so ungefähr.
Das ist doch wirklich, also in welche Richtung das hier diskutiert wird.
Ja, aber da kann man sich ja vorstellen, wie wir dann auch an die Kandare genommen
werden. Da deutet es ja schon an, wenn hier Krieg ist, dann werden wir ja wohl
auch die jungen Männer zwingen, dass sie in den Krieg ziehen.
Also das ist für die alles selbstverständlich. Es ist halt Krieg. Wir hören weiter.
Es handelt sich um Deserteure. Das kann man nicht anders nennen als das.
Und außerdem wäre es doch im deutschen Interesse. Es wird immer gesagt...
Das ist immer das Wichtigste, das deutsche Interesse. Am Ende sterben in aller
Welt alle nur immer für ein deutsches Interesse.
Kriegsflüchtlinge sind jetzt alle Deserteure.
In unserem Interesse ist, dass die Ukraine diesen Krieg nicht verliert gegen Russland.
Manche sagen sogar, es ist in unserem Interesse, dass die Ukraine diesen Krieg gewinnt.
Und gleichzeitig antworten wir auf den Appell des ukrainischen Verteidigungsministers Umirow,
Doch bitte dafür zu sorgen, dass die in Europa sich aufhaltenden ukrainischen
Männer in die Ukraine zurückkommen.
Damit, dass wir sagen, nö, da machen wir nichts dran. Wir tragen noch nicht mal diesen Appell mit.
Wäre das nicht auch im deutschen Interesse, das zu tun?
Das deutsche Interesse. Jetzt hast du schon schön skizziert,
wie würde das dann aussehen.
Naja, es gibt da ja vielleicht doch eine Möglichkeit. Und man hat das auch schon
aus CDU-Kreisen gehört. Und bei so Leuten, die da so rumtwittern, reizt, spricht es aus.
Und was ist eigentlich mit dem Bürgergeld, das Ukrainern gezahlt wird?
Wäre es nicht an der Zeit, das wenigstens für die ukrainischen Männer im wehrfähigen Alter zu kürzen?
Wollen wir mal sehen, ob die Regierung uns darauf Antworten gibt.
Einfach dieses Thema wegzuspurbeln, das wird nicht länger funktionieren.
Also können wir sie finanziell erpressen, dass sie bereit sind,
in den Krieg zu gehen. Oder alles andere ist Geschwurbel.
Und wir haben da keine Minderheitsmeinung jetzt, glaube ich, gehört.
Übrigens, Thema Bürgergeld. Weil wir hatten ja beim letzten Mal thematisiert,
dass Verfassungsgerichtsurteil gegen Verfassungsgerichtsurteil steht.
Wenn jemand sagt, beim Bürgergeld kürzen, weil das ist ja auch Verfassungsgericht.
Wir haben juristische Hinweise bekommen aus der Hörerschaft,
während die Schuldenbremse im Grundgesetz steht, weil eine Mehrheit des Bundestags
gesagt hat, soll da rein und genauso gut sagen könnte,
kann wieder raus oder anders reingeschrieben werden, ist tatsächlich das Bürgergeld
mit einer Ewigkeitsklausel versehen.
Also der Grundbedarf, ja ja, die Grundversorgung des wir lassen dich nicht sterben
ist auch nicht durch Bundestagsmehrheit, also 66% verfassungsgebende Mehrheit, aussetzbar.
Sondern Artikel 1 greift da tatsächlich. Also wir haben es hier mit…,
sehr harten Bandagen zu tun auf der einen Seite.
Und gilt das auch für ukrainische Männer?
Glaube ich nicht. Wahrscheinlich ist die deutsche Staatsbürgerschaft da schon
entscheidend an dem Punkt.
Aber es ist trotzdem ein absurder Gedanke, finde ich, wenn du jetzt jemandem,
der aus dem Krieg geflüchtet ist, einen Brief schreibst mit Wir nehmen dir das
Bürgergeld, außer du gehst und dann Aber ich habe ja dann kein Bürgergeld mehr, wenn ich zurückgehe.
Also es macht ja eh keinen Sinn. und die Idee, dass man mit dem Entzug von Bürgergeld
jemanden an der Front motiviert.
Oh Gott.
Aber uns geht es um die Menschen in diesem Krieg. Das wollen wir natürlich nie
vergessen. Darum ging es von Anfang an.
Wir springen jetzt zu einem anderen Thema und es ist, ich weiß gar nicht,
wie ich es einleiten soll. Also du kennst die...
Es ist ein Streamerkrieg, ja.
Es ist ein Krieg mit Mit, ja, ich weiß gar nicht, Verlierern,
Gewinnern, wird alles schwer zu entscheiden sein.
Also man verliert Zeit, wenn man sich da hineinbegibt. Deswegen sollte man das
jetzt nicht nachmachen.
Und zwar geht es vor allem um den Streit zwischen der Twitch-Streamerin Shuryoka und KuchenTV.
Ich kenne beides nicht. Beide Streamer, also KuchenTV ist ein sehr erfolgreicher Streamer bei Twitch,
der aber schon ein Jahr so Just Chatting Kram vor allem, der wird auch mal was spielen,
der ist mir immer wieder aufgefallen bei Twitter, schon vor Jahren,
weil es immer wieder irgendwelche Sachen gibt.
Also ich will es mal so sagen, also man muss sich hier jetzt auch rechtlich
so ausdrücken, dass man nicht auch Teil dieses ganzen Abmahnsystems wird.
Deswegen würde ich jetzt mal sagen.
Dass bei ihm als antifeministisch zu wertende Äußerungen sehr regelmäßig in
seinen Streams vorkommen.
Zugleich kommen noch andere Protagonisten dort vor.
Scarroffs wäre zu nennen und Montana Black.
Montana Black springt also diesem Kuchen-TV immer wieder bei.
Shouyoka ist eine Streamerin, die Just Chatting Formate macht und auch Gaming Formate macht.
Sie ist im Mai ausgezeichnet worden mit dem Deutschen Computerspielpreis als Spielerin des Jahres.
Dies hat die Community um KuchenTV und MontanaBlack in helle Aufruhr gebracht,
denn diese Shouyoka würde gar nicht so viel spielen und sei eigentlich nicht
für Gaming bei Twitch bekannt.
Und das sei nur eine linke Entscheidung gewesen.
Also wir merken schon, dass es geht um Kulturkampf. Dann kommt hinzu,
also wir versuchen es ein bisschen klar zu machen.
Es ist so diffus, je weiter man sich reinarbeitet. Ich hatte das gestern soweit
dann sortiert und dann sage ich, ach,
KuchenTV hat Heiligabend auch nochmal ein Video rausgebracht und dann gibt es
noch ein Video dazu und dann guckt man nochmal so eine Stunde und ist aber auch
eigentlich nicht klüger, sondern hat nochmal Zeug gesammelt.
Also man muss sich das so vorstellen, bei Twitch streamen ja Leute live,
die sitzen dort vier, sechs, acht, neun Stunden, reden die mit anderen,
mit sich selbst, mit ihrer Community.
Schauen sich Streams von anderen oder Videos bei YouTube an und reagieren wieder auf die.
Und es ging alles los, dass diese Twitch-Streamerin, Shua Yoka….
Anfang des Jahres dazu aufrief, das Harry Potter Spiel Hoggarts Legacy zu boykottieren, weil J.K.
Rowling transfeindliche Äußerungen immer wieder getätigt hat.
Dies war ein größerer Kulturkampf auf Twitch, der dort lief und sie war eine
dieser Leute. Um das klar zu machen, ich bin gegen solche Boykottaufrufe,
bin auch für eine Trennung von Autor und Person, bin aber zugleich gegen die Äußerungen, die J.K.
Rowling getroffen hat, sehe aber jetzt
nicht Handlungsbedarf im Sinne von Boykottaufrufen, wie dem auch sei.
Nun kann man ja da unterschiedlicher Meinung zu sein,
aber Twitch ist keine Plattform, wo man jetzt sagt, dann treten wir doch mal
miteinander in den Austausch, sondern dann haben sich also diese Leute um KuchenTV
und MontanaBlack und vor allem ihre sehr,
sehr große Community permanent an Shoyoka abgearbeitet, Sodass es jetzt hunderte Videos.
Würde ich sagen, bei YouTube gibt, in denen sie die ganze Zeit angegriffen wird.
Zum einen von diesen genannten Streamern, zum anderen haben die natürlich eine
Fanbase, die extremst frauenfeindliche Äußerungen tätigt auf allen Plattformen,
die man sich vorstellen kann.
Ich habe bei Twitter Screenshots und sowas dazu gefunden.
Ich kann nichts davon hier vortragen, weil das wirklich unter allem ist,
was man sich vorstellen kann.
Also wird diese junge Streamerin dort angefeindet in einem Maße,
wie man sich das kaum vorstellen kann und will.
So und dieser Beef geht jetzt seit Monaten, die Amadeo Stiftung hat sich da
auch schon eingeschaltet,
wir haben eine Presse, die inzwischen sogar darauf reagiert hat,
man redet davon, ist das jetzt so ein zweites Gamergate,
wir hören hier kurz mal drei Clips vom Deutschlandfunk, da hatte Schniederjan
sogar mit Shoyoka sprechen können.
Videos gegen Shoyuka lohnen sich. Das zumindest behauptet Marcel Ehres in diesem Video.
Da listet er seine angeblichen Einnahmen durch Videos gegen die junge Frau auf.
3.000, 4.000, 3.000, 4.000, ein Düsenjäger vielleicht, nochmal ein Düsenjäger,
nochmal ein Düsenjäger.
Also das schmeckt echt gut, Shoyuka. Kannst immer gerne so weitermachen.
Den finanziellen Segen nehme ich mit.
Ehres Künstlername ist Montana Black.
Er ist einer der erfolgreichsten deutschen Streamer. Seit einigen Monaten veröffentlicht
er auch Videos gegen die 26-jährige Pia Scholz, die unter dem Künstlernamen
Shuyuka ebenfalls als Streamerin unterwegs ist.
Das heißt, man hasst sich auf dieser Plattform?
Und produziert immer wieder neue Hass.
Aber profitiert sie auch davon finanziell so?
Ja, dazu kommen wir jetzt gleich. Also ich würde sagen nein,
also nicht in dem Maße, wie sie Hass abbekommt.
Aber es ist so, dass man dort jetzt einen Dauercontent produzieren kann,
weil es jetzt nicht so ist, dass es einmal Shoyoka in einem Stream gab und die
hat sich dazu geäußert und das war es dann.
Sondern sie äußert sich selbstverständlich auch permanent wieder dazu in sehr
langen Streams, worauf die anderen wieder reagieren.
Und wir hatten das so schön gelesen bei Taylor Lawrence,
wie dort eigentlich mit diesen Beefs plötzlich das so die neue Form von Boulevard-Journalismus
ist, beziehungsweise die generieren ihren eigenen Journalismus.
Muss. Und das ist sehr interessant, wenn du das dann darfst.
Der exklusiver Content.
Ja, das exklusiver Content und du musst auch dabei bleiben, um noch mitzukommen.
Also wir hatten jetzt vor wenigen Tagen war Thomas Anders in einer Talkshow,
und hat erzählt, ja, der Bohlen war ja bei Modern Talking so eine Notlösung,
ja, hat wieder irgendwie gelästert über Bohlen.
Daraufhin natürlich Bohlen gleich wieder via Instagram, was,
ich bin der Produzent dieses Liedes und geht dann so.
Und das, was wir dort so kennen, in Form von kurzen Schnipseln,
müssen Das müssen wir uns jetzt einfach vorstellen, so dass man jeden Tag stundenlang
nur Streams und YouTube-Videos gucken kann zu dem Fall Showyoka,
KuchenTV, Montana Black.
Sehr gut.
Du brauchst nichts mehr anderes machen, als nachzuvollziehen,
was hat wer wieder über wen wann gesagt.
Da gibt es bestimmt so Leute, die YouTube-Playlist in chronologischer Reihenfolge und sowas machen.
Ja, ja, es ist absurd. Es gibt dann natürlich auch ganz viele kleine YouTuber,
die jetzt hoffen, auf dieser Welle mitzuschwimmen und auch so ein bisschen nach
vorne zu kommen, die also jetzt auch das als ihren primären Content gesehen haben.
Wir hören jetzt mal Shoyoka.
Ich glaube, gerade an den Kommentaren merkt man, dass der Anteil der Zuschauerschaft,
der auch wirklich Hass empfindet, nicht so gering ist, wie man vielleicht vermuten würde.
Und ich finde, das Level an Eskalationsbereitschaft in diesen Communities hat
mich selbst dieses Jahr sehr schockiert.
Also ich habe nicht damit gerechnet, dass man so einfach Menschen mobilisiert
bekommt, um gegen eine andere Person vorzugehen.
Und wir hören jetzt mal aus so einem Stream von KuchenTV. Das hat auch Deutschlandfunk
jetzt hier rausgesucht.
Wenn ich mit dem Fahrrad unterwegs bin in der Innenstadt und jemand schreit
mir Arschloch hinterher, habe ich bessere Möglichkeiten, da mit einer Anzeige
durchzukommen, als wenn jemand zehn Videos zu mir macht.
KuchenTV, einer der Hauptakteure, wurde inzwischen auf Twitch gesperrt.
Zuvor hatte er noch im Spenden für sich gebeten, um einen Anwalt bezahlen zu können.
Es ist also unwahrscheinlich, dass die Kampagne damit beendet ist.
In seinem letzten Stream kündigte er aber an, weiter gegen Shoyuka hetzen zu wollen.
Das hört sich dann so an. Ich will, dass Monte zu mir kommt,
seine Zunge in mein Arschloch steckt und mir sagt, Digga, du hast Shoyuka so
krass gebrochen, du bist so
ein geiler Typ, bitte sei meine Japje heute Nacht. Und das ist mein Ziel.
Und das werde ich dir beweisen. Ich werde weitermachen.
Ja, jetzt hat KuchenTV angekündigt, nicht nochmal ein neues Video zu machen,
aber wahrscheinlich, wo ich es gerade ausspreche, fällt schon wieder das Neueste.
Jedenfalls merken wir ja so schon, welcher Ton dort angeschlagen wird.
KuchenTV so 200.000 Follower auf Insta und Pia Schurjoka so 70.000.
Das ist jetzt gar nicht so die Mega, ich hätte jetzt gedacht,
dass man da, also solche selbstlaufenden Systeme.
KuchenTV ist riesengroß bei YouTube, also Monte auch.
Und Monte und KuchenTV agieren die ganze Zeit zusammen.
In den Livestreams sind dann oft nur 1500 Leute bei Shoyoka oder so.
Allerdings dann auch ganz viele Hater, das muss dann wieder moderiert werden.
Naja und dann gab es diesen Höhepunkt am 6.
Dezember, Showyoka hat Twitch wohl markiert bei Twitter und hat jetzt dafür gesorgt,
dass zumindest bislang KuchenTV gebannt ist von der Plattform.
Das heißt also, er hat jetzt auch da eine große Einnahmequelle verloren,
denn bei Twitch verdient man ja sein Geld vor allem damit, dass man entweder
Mikrospenden erhält oder und oder durch Subs, also durch Abonnenten Geld bekommt
und das ist ja gekoppelt Twitch an Amazon.
Also Amazon hat Twitch gekauft und dann geht das über den Prime Account sozusagen dann an die Streamer.
Das heißt, worüber reden wir jetzt
eigentlich und warum machen wir das eigentlich jetzt hier im Podcast?
Also mir geht es jetzt ja nicht darum, haarklein nachzuvollziehen,
wer wann wo was gesagt hat.
Jetzt würde ich schon gerne wissen.
Naja, wir gehen schon. Ich habe dir schon Material hier bereitgelegt, keine Sorge.
Wir machen jetzt schon Klatsch und Tratsch. Aber wir versuchen es jetzt mal so zu betrachten.
Ja, KuchenTV ist die republikanische Partei und Showyoka ist die demokratische
Partei in den USA und wir wissen, was da jetzt gerade so passiert,
man versucht sich gegenseitig zu de-plattformen, ja, also man versucht gerichtlich
vorzugehen, dass jemand wo nicht antreten kann.
Also diese ganze Gemengelage, die wir da erleben, also man redet nicht miteinander
um zu einem dann vielleicht Kompromiss oder irgendwas Neuem zu kommen,
sondern es geht eigentlich nur noch darauf,
läuft es darauf aus, dass man über das Gericht arbeitet,
über die Öffentlichkeit arbeitet und dass man eine Fanbase hinter sich hat,
die wieder irgendetwas dann in Gang setzt.
Da ist natürlich die Fanbase bei Monte und KuchenTV viel größer,
deswegen können die eher dann die Kommentarspalten fluten mit irgendwelchen Hassbotschaften,
während Shoyoka auch versucht mit ihrer Community einzelne Werbepartner zu kontaktieren
und wollt ihr noch mit KuchenTV zusammenarbeiten etc.
Wir hören jetzt mal hier uns an, wie KuchenTV spricht aus einem YouTube-Stream zu seinem Bann.
Jo Freunde der Lügen, Shoyoka hat in zwei Streams mal wieder super lange über
uns geredet, gelogen, gehetzt und einfach nur Müll erzählt.
Und aus dem Grund bin ich jetzt auch einfach auf Twitch gesperrt.
Sie hat nämlich gefühlt 500 Tweets gemacht, wo sie Twitch markiert hat,
nachdem sie mich schon meldete, was jetzt dafür gesorgt hat,
dass Twitch anscheinend erstmal eingebrochen ist und mich von der Plattform gesperrt hat.
Ist ja auch die deutlich bessere Möglichkeit, als selbstkritisch zu seinen Fehlern zu stehen.
Nachdem ich auf Twitch gesperrt worden bin, habe ich natürlich angefangen bei
YouTube zu streamen. Auch das hat Shoyuka nicht ganz so gut gefallen,
weswegen sie in den nächsten Tweets dann direkt YouTube markiert hat,
in der Hoffnung, dass die Mächte anscheinend auch die Plattformen.
Überlegt mal, wie krank das einfach ist. Das, meine Freunde,
ist die Cancel Culture. Ich gehe natürlich rechtlich dagegen vor.
Ja, wir haben also schon den Schlagwort Cancel Catch.
Also hier ist auch das Buch von Steffen Mau, da ist alles so diffus bei denen.
Also man muss sagen, da sind einige dabei, dazu zählt jetzt nicht KuchenTV,
aber andere, die da mitmachen, Skurros und noch jemand, die sind sehr reich
geworden durch diese Casino Games.
Und dann hat Twitch das ja stärker eingeschränkt.
Das heißt, diese Superdeals sind nicht mehr zu machen mit so ganz dubiosen Anbietern,
weil die einfach auf Twitch nicht mehr stattfinden.
Dann gibt es so eine andere Plattform, ich glaube die heißt Kick.
Dort kann man dann noch alles bewerben, aber die ist nicht so beliebt bei den Fans.
Also man ist irgendwie auf Twitch angewiesen. Und es ist so,
dass man, also wenn man da mit Casino-Spielen reich geworden ist,
ja kein anderes Thema hatte. Was soll man dann jetzt stattdessen machen?
Das wäre ja wie, wenn man jetzt uns verbieten würde, über Politik zu reden,
dann müssten wir uns was Neues einfallen lassen.
Und bei denen war das so, dass da so eine Lehre entstand und dann gab es aber schon diesen Kurs,
Kulturkampf über Vogue, über Cancel Culture und dann kam diese Sache mit dem
Spiel, mit diesem neuen Harry Potter Spiel und dann hatte Kronk bei.
Twitch schon gesagt, ja, interessiert ihn eigentlich nicht so, was J.K.
Rowling sagt, jetzt so sinngemäß wiedergeben, ist ihm eigentlich egal,
ihm geht es jetzt um das Spiel.
Daraufhin wurde er dann von einigen Transaktivisten als transfeindlich angegriffen,
woraufhin wieder der Parabelritter reagierte und das auch nochmal und dann hat
Shoyoka darauf reagiert und so hat sich das hochgeschaltet, woraufhin die,
die mit diesen Casino Games mal groß geworden sind, dachten,
das regt ja richtig viele Leute auf, da ist echt immer Action.
Wenn ich mich da jetzt so als Anti-Vogue-Krieger inszeniere,
dann kann ich die sehr gut einfangen
für meine sache und dadurch hat das jetzt sofort aufgenommen
über twitch und diese biefs eignen sich noch
viel besser als die casino spiele für diese zweitauswertung auf youtube die
entscheidend ist das stimmt man kriegt das ja immer als zusammenfassung bei
youtube so geliefert ja was so ein ewig langen streams da lief ja ja und dann
erklärt der parabelritter was was man da gesehen hat. Ja.
Und ich meine, wir hatten jetzt ja vor ein paar Wochen auch den Beef zwischen
Leroy, diesem YouTuber,
der jetzt aufhört und dann noch einige Vorwürfe an andere richtete,
an andere YouTuber, woraufhin die auch wieder alle reagiert haben.
Also das ist, es ist unglaublich, es ist nur noch Reizreaktion,
permanent und eine unglaubliche Masse an Fans, die sich nur damit auseinandersetzt
und nichts mehr anderes sieht.
Also man hat es dann mit Leuten zu tun, die wahrscheinlich nicht allzu große
ökonomische Perspektive haben und die jetzt nur noch in diesem Kulturkampf,
sich befinden und sich glauben, auf irgendeine Seite schlagen zu müssen und
dann ja auch zum Teil sich selbst so.
Radikalisieren, dass sie dann dort Kommentare schreiben, bei denen sie sagen,
gut, also vielleicht mag es mal ein bisschen rabiat auf dem Schulhof zugegangen
sein, aber sowas hättest du niemals gesagt, was du jetzt hier einen Kommentar schreibst.
Und da sind natürlich die Frauen dann besonders die Opfer dieser ganzen Geschichte.
Wir sehen jetzt aber mal auch, bei Kohentopf haben wir jetzt schon gehört,
der äußert sich zwar manchmal so ganz vulgär, aber dann so auch als eine Stimme
der Vernunft taucht auch Monte immer wieder.
Ach ja, und nur fürs Gutmenschen-Bingo, so fasst sie den dunklen Parabelritter zusammen.
Erzähl uns was, womit wir nicht gerechnet hätten. C ist Heteromon.
Ja, das war jetzt Shoyoka wirft jetzt dem Marbelliterator wiederum vor,
ein Zizet-Roman zu sein.
Ach wirklich?
Dir ist es egal? Who would have thought? Schöner Take.
Ja, war ja klar. Aber ich finde, genau hier zeigt sich halt die Doppelmoral von Shoyoka.
Du beschwerst dich ja gerade darüber, dass es dem Paraberitter egal ist,
eben weil er nicht betroffen ist. Mit anderen Worten, wenn man von Diskriminierung bzw.
Von den Nicht-Einheiten von Menschenrechten mitbekommt, dann muss man aktiv
werden und es darf einem nicht egal sein.
Dass ihr das Thema wichtig ist, das sagt sie auch hier im Stream.
Nicht jeder, der initial nicht eurer Meinung ist, ist auch potenziell euer Feind.
Der dunkle Parabelretter. Quote of the day. Dankeschön.
Kontext. Wir reden über Menschenrechte. Ich habe das Ganze ja schon in meinem
letzten Video gesagt, aber die Frage bleibt halt trotzdem.
Wenn dir das Thema so wichtig ist, warum nutzt du dann TikTok?
Was aus China kommt und wo die chinesische Regierung mit drin hängt?
Du weißt schon, China, ein Land, was selber super wenig LGBTQ-Rechte hat und
was dazu die Menschenrechte mit Füßen tritt.
Und das am schlimmsten, die machen gerade einfach einen Völkermord gegen die
Uiguren. Wenn Menschenrechte für dich nicht diskutabel sind und sowas schon
ausreicht, um Hogwarts Legacy zu boykottieren und zu sagen, spielt das nicht.
Also sorry, dann müssten deine moralischen Grundsätze doch auch so weit gehen,
zu sagen, ich unterstütze TikTok nicht, denn das, was China macht,
geht einfach gar nicht fit.
Wir sind hier eigentlich bei unseren normalen politischen Debatten angekommen.
Werte geleitete Ausbildung, gibt es das überhaupt? Wie kann es durchgesetzt werden?
Sind wir da nicht mit Doppelstandards?
Passt, denn die Frage ist ja, macht man ein Argument und illustriert darum oder
illustriert man nur noch?
Denn das läuft ja alles nur noch unter, also es muss sich für den Konflikt eignen,
der selber gar nichts mit Politik zu tun hat,
sondern nur dieses Bespaßungs, man programmiert halt Videos hintereinander weg
und muss dann immer warten, was der andere liefert, um darauf wieder zu antworten.
Und damit wird eigentlich die ganze Welt nur noch zur Kulisse.
Weil ihm ist ja China auch egal. Für ihn ist es ja nur ein wahlloses Argument
jetzt einfach das auch nochmal anzuführen und diese Art von also wir wissen
ja Konflikten, sie generalisieren.
Also wie so ein Stoppsauger, sie saugen einfach alles ein und so weiter.
Dafür bräuchte man eigentlich nochmal so ein Argument für diese Entgrenzung von Debatten.
Wenn jemand einfach nicht beim Punkt bleiben kann, sondern so wie Rainer Hank,
ach ich habe gerade das Wort und es wurde mir auch eine Frage gestellt,
ich glaube ich habe die jetzt beantwortet, komme ich mal zum nächsten Punkt
und dann ist ja da auch noch und so weiter und so fort.
Man denkt sich irgendwie, also wir hatten das einmal als Joke,
als Casey Newton zu Kevin Roos sagte, stop generating.
Und er hat ihn wie so eine Maschine quasi angesprochen. Ja, jetzt hör mal auf
zu generieren, hör auf zu fabulieren.
Eigentlich brauchen wir noch mehr aus der Technik abgeleitete Begriffe,
um hier solche Diskussionen mal irgendwie zu fassen, dass wir das vom Phänotyp her mal verstehen.
Die machen das auch systematisch, also dieses, sie sagt was, wenn ich es jetzt,
Nicht ganz missverstehe, aber so ein bisschen überdehne, dann kann ich daraus
wieder was produzieren, worauf sie wieder sagt, ja, aber das war aus dem Zusammenhang
gerissen und das ist auch interessant,
das ist auch so, also neben YouTube und Twitch ist die dritte wichtige Plattform
in diesem ganzen Streit Twitter, also X,
weil dort immer dann kurze Clips entstehen.
Also man da nochmal so ein paar schlaglichtartige Eindrücke von den einzelnen Streams bekommt,
woraufhin dann wieder Debatten losgehen, dass das alles aus dem Zusammenhang
gerissen sei und man sich doch bitte mal den gesamten neun Stunden Stream ansehen soll.
Das ist faszinierend und es gibt diese Obsession jetzt da mit den Woken.
Genauso das hier. Ich habe auch nicht damit gerechnet, dass jemand so obszessiv mit mir sein kann,
dass er einfach ein Jahr lang Videos zu mir macht, alle drei Wochen und sein
ganzes Leben nach mir abstimmt und so eine Fixierung auf eine Frau hat,
mit der er nichts privat zu tun hat und nie zu tun haben wird.
Was hat das Ganze damit zu tun, dass du eine Frau bist?
Ich verstehe es halt nach elf Monaten immer noch nicht. Und sie kann mir das
Ganze auch nicht erklären.
Dazu bin ich auch nicht obsessiv zu dir. Bruder, ich mache einfach Videos zu
Themen, die sich aktuell gut klicken.
Und diese Woke-Bubble-Thematik hat schon immer gute Aufrufe gegeben.
Und natürlich nehme ich dann die Vorlagen, mit die ich mitnehmen kann.
Egal ob Young Feltz Salat, Dara oder halt eine Shoyoka.
Ja, Dara, da war ich ja auch schon mal im Podcast zu Gast.
Fast. Also da gibt es so ein paar, die jetzt Transrechte mehrmals thematisieren
oder auch andere Themen.
Was interessant ist, dass aber die ja fast alle, also da würde ich dann vielleicht
ausnehmen, ich verfolge aber nicht genau, was er da macht, aber ich würde sagen,
dass fast alle ja gar nie die ökonomischen Themen als das große ansehen.
Also die wollen die ganze Zeit, gibt es Streams darüber, kann man Hogwarts Legacy
spielen oder nicht oder ist man dann transfeindlich oder nicht.
Das ist schon erstaunlich, dass die so diese schon für uns jetzt langsam zu
lahme Kritik, ja die Identitätspolitik konzentriert sich nur auf diese Partikularkämpfe,
dass das bei denen noch absolut zutrifft.
Und deren, glaube ich, die erleben so viel Aggressivität dann von Leuten,
von antifeministischen Streamern, dass sie natürlich sagen, ja,
aber seht ihr, es ist aber wirklich ein Riesenproblem.
Also das heißt, das schaukelt sich immer weiter hoch.
Und man kann gar nicht in eine Gelassenheit kommen, weil es tatsächlich diese
hart reaktionären Streamer gibt mit einer großen Fanbase,
die sich dann darauf einschießen und dann kommt auch hinzu, dass die natürlich
mitunter auch ihre Argumente, also die identitätspolitischen Standpunkte nicht
übermäßig klug vortragen.
Ich würde mal sagen, wer acht Stunden am Tag streamt, hat wenig Zeit,
nochmal ein Buch dann zwischendurch zu lesen.
Und dadurch verstricken die sich auch dann selbst in ihren Argumentationen Widersprüche.
Aber das haben wir doch auch bei Steffen Mau. Diese identitätspolitische Arena
ist super attraktiv, obwohl, wenn man nur eine Nachfrage dazu stellt,
alle extrem indifferent antworten.
Ja. Eigentlich ist es mir egal, aber.
Ja, also wir haben es ja jetzt nicht bei, also bei KuchenTV weiß ich es nicht,
aber bei Monte habe ich jetzt einige Sachen gesehen.
Ich würde, Monte ist sicherlich kein Vorzeige-Feminist und hat auch in der Vergangenheit,
kann man alles ja nachlesen und gucken, viele Dinge gemacht.
Aber das wäre jetzt ja niemand, der harte Propaganda macht in dem Sinne von
Schwule und Lesben sollen man nicht heiraten dürfen oder sowas.
Also das haben wir in dieser Form nicht.
Allenfalls ein paar Jokes, aber dann können wir wieder hin.
So, also man hat, sobald man eins tiefer geht da, also man, eigentlich müsste
man die jetzt mal alle packen, diese reichweitenstarken Streamer und mit Steffen
Mau so in so ein Kongresshotel für drei Tage setzen.
Und dann versucht er denen das mal alles so klar zu machen, aber dann wäre das Geschäftsmodell weg.
Er hat's ja jetzt gerade genau gesagt, naja, mit der Vulkan Bubble kann ich
Klicks machen und deswegen mache ich das dann auch.
Wir hören hier mal einen Zusammenschnitt bei KuchenTV?
Wo über mich gemault wird und die Kommentare darunter voll sind mit,
oh mein Gott, die gehört vergewaltigt, die braucht mal einen Schwanz,
die gehört mal getötet. Und weißt du, worum es in dem Video geht?
Um zwei andere Leute. Auch das ist halt einfach nachweislich gelogen.
Ich habe in meiner YouTube-Kommentarsektion einfach mal nach den Wörtern Vergenusswürzelung
und die Einzahl von Cocktail gesucht.
Und es gibt halt wirklich keinen einzigen Kommentar, wo sowas jemand über Shoyoka geschrieben hat.
Gut, das gebe ich zu. Ich kann jetzt natürlich keine 10.000 Kommentare oder sowas durchgehen.
Aber das kommt nicht in einer Häufigkeit vor, die du hier beschrieben hast.
Mag sein, dass das mal irgendein Idiot gepostet hat. Aber auch das nutzt sie
wieder, um sich vor der Kritik zu entziehen, weil sie dann sagen kann,
boah, die hätten ja alle so mies in den Kommentaren gegen mich,
da muss ich gar nicht drauf eingehen.
Ja, also man kann in den Kommentaren schon sehr deutlich diese Dinge finden
und gerade auch bei Twitter.
Also wenn ich das schon nach rumklicken, also ich bin ja überhaupt erst darauf
aufmerksam geworden, dass plötzlich dieser Name Show Joka und KuchenTV laufend
bei Twitter in der Timeline mir vorkam und dann mit entsprechenden Kommentaren versehen waren,
dass ich dachte, gut, wenn das jetzt hier schon mit drei Minuten Recherche ersichtlich
wird, wie massiv dieser Hass ist,
dann würde ich mal sagen, hat sie da schon einen Punkt,
aber für KuchenTV irgendwie alles kein Problem.
Stundenlang im Stream darüber zu fantasieren, ob ich attraktiv genug bin,
um mit mir zu schlafen, ist misogyn.
Stundenlang haben wir also darüber geredet, ob du...
Also wir merken aber jetzt, wir wollen jetzt gar nicht in diese Debatte reingehen
inhaltlich, aber wir merken jetzt, also sie sagt jetzt stundenlang reden die
darüber. Jetzt seine Antwort.
Attraktiv bist. Okay, dann gucken wir uns diese ganze Stunde jetzt mal an.
Ich finde, sie ist eine gut aussehende junge Frau, aber Charakter macht auch
hübsch oder nicht hübsch.
Attraktiv und unattraktiv. Und bei ihr ist das Problem, dass ihr,
also, da knallt es charakterlich aus allen Ecken und Kanten.
Das Ganze waren halt original 20 Sekunden bei Monte.
Und in meiner Reaction ging das Ganze dann vielleicht eine Minute oder sowas.
Und ich lasse hier auch nicht zählen, dass man sagt, naja, komm Tim,
dir ist doch klar, dass das umgangssprachlich halt so gesagt wird.
Denn sie übertreibt hier absichtlich. 20 Sekunden oder Stunden lang ist ein
riesengroßer Unterschied.
Man will jetzt, also man macht Streams, in denen man neun Stunden labert.
Und dann kommen danach wieder Leute und sagen, ja Moment, da war aber eine Ausführung,
eine Aussage, die ist nicht ganz korrekt.
Also wenn wir zum Beispiel jetzt sagen würden, die Disney-Filme propagieren
alle die Familienideologie, Dann könnte man jetzt juristisch sagen, na, also,
Es gibt da aber auch Disney-Filme, die machen das und das oder machen die das
permanent? Naja, permanent auch nicht.
Es sind ja die Videos von Rezo, wie er sich von den Medien missverstanden fühlt.
Ganz richtig.
Da werden ja einzelne Kommasetzungen plötzlich als und da lügt sie wieder und so weiter.
Ja und das ist der neue Diskurs, also zum einen haben wir dieses Rumlabern, dummes Zeug machen,
ich meine Riso und Aldi sitzen ja die ganze Zeit nur am Computer,
gucken sich irgendwelche Clips an bei YouTube oder TikTok und reden dann darüber.
Und dann soll aber bitte, wenn man über sie redet, alles so rechtssicher sein,
dass ich jetzt nicht sagen kann, Stefan Schulz ist YouTuber und Journalist.
Nein, ich bin Podcaster und Journalist. YouTuber ist völlig falsch. Genau, ganz falsch.
Theoretisch auseinandergesetzt habe, dass dann nach Interviews oder so schon
mal dann eine Influencerin schrieb, ja, das findet sie aber nicht gut,
dass ich sie da erwähnt habe, ob ich nicht mal mit ihr darüber reden will.
Und ich denke, nee, ich möchte nicht, du brauchst nicht in meine DMs zu kommen,
ich mache hier eine Äußerung dazu,
aber ich will auch nicht am Ende sagen, dass ich mit dir toll Pizza essen kann
und du ein netter Mensch bist, interessiert mich nicht. Das war eine Aussage zu etwas.
Man denkt immer, die kommunizieren viel, weil die neun Stunden Twitch machen.
Ja.
Aber dieses hintenrum noch.
Permanent, glaube ich.
Wollen wir uns nicht nochmal reden? Also müssen wir uns nicht nochmal besprechen? Ja.
Das macht genauso viel Inhalt abseits der Öffentlichkeit wie das.
Ja.
Wenn sie mit mir redet, höre ich auf, Videos über sie zu machen.
Aber wenn sie sich weigert, kommen noch 20 Videos.
Das ist die Narrative, die da spielt. Es geht um Kontrolle. Es geht um Macht.
Menschen, die reaktionären Content machen in der Szene, haben versucht,
mich dazu zu zwingen, mit ihnen in private Gespräche zu gehen,
zuzugehen, um Kontrolle und Macht über eine Frau auszuüben, an die sie sonst nicht rankommen.
Und es wurde ganz klar kommuniziert, wenn ich mit ihnen privat rede,
hören sie auf und wenn ich es nicht tue, dann machen sie weiter.
Also wieder die Frage, was hat das damit zu tun, dass du eine Frau bist und
ich will jetzt natürlich nicht angeben, aber ich habe bei Tinder über 700 Likes,
also an Frauen mag ich das mir nicht.
Na gut, wenn man die Fetten abzieht, sind es halt noch zwei, aber das passt schon.
Also komme ich an Frauen wie dich ran? Okay, nein, das ist natürlich auch gelogen,
Alle diese 700 Likes haben deutlich besseren Charakter als du.
Wenn wir doch angeblich alles aus dem Zusammenhang reißen und überall lügen
oder irgendwas hinzufügen, was eine Shoyoka hier ja nachweisbar noch gar nicht
gemacht hat, dann verstehe ich trotzdem nicht, warum man sich nicht einfach
privat hinsetzen kann, um das Ganze zu klären.
Offensichtlich sind doch dann die Fronten einfach verhärtet,
man redet aneinander vorbei und um wieder eine normale Basis zu haben,
könnte man doch einfach mal miteinander reden.
Aber nein, dann müsste nämlich Shoyoka ihre Opferrolle verlassen,
müsste nämlich dann auch Fehler zugeben, weil sie nicht einfach irgendwas aus
dem Zusammenhang reißen kann.
Und das ist natürlich das Schlimmste, was sich eine Shoyoka so vorstellen kann.
Ja, das ist natürlich völliger Unsinn. Man muss es sich ja so vorstellen,
der Klitschko hat einen Gegner, gegen den er boxen muss.
Und dann wird er zwei Tage vorher sagen, also ehrlich gesagt wäre doch viel
besser, wenn wir uns mal zusammensetzen und reden, dann können wir am Samstag
den Boxkampf ausfallen lassen.
Ja, dann gehen halt leider die ganzen Millionenflöten und wenn jetzt es hier
tatsächlich darum ginge, dass man einfach nur Frieden haben will,
könnte man es ja sein lassen, lässt es sich darauf bewenden, ist ja egal.
Nein, es ist das Prinzip, dass man es immer weitermacht und zwischendurch aber
sich immer als der Vernünftige gibt, der sagt, naja, ich wäre für Verhandlungen gewesen.
Ich glaube auch, das ist die eigentliche Triebfeder des Ganzen,
dass er privat zurückgewiesen wurde, was ihn kränkt, weshalb er das jetzt öffentlich ihr zeigt.
Und deswegen ist es auch eine Machtfrage, da hat sie glaube ich auch recht.
Diese 700 Likes bei Tinder, das meint er ja sehr ernst.
In gewisser Weise schon, ja.
Und ich will kurz Rechercheergebnisse, die natürlich dann im Familienbuch drinstecken,
um auf 700 Likes bei Tinder zu kommen.
Ja, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt.
Und bei Tinder muss man ja, damit man sieht, es ist ein erfolgreicher Like,
also ein Matching, muss man ja selber erstmal diejenige Person vorher schon auswählen.
Also positiv swipen.
Um auf 700 Likes zu kommen, 700 Matches, erfolgreiche Matches,
muss man im Schnitt 15.000 Frauen entsprechend positiv markiert haben,
weil Karteileichen, grundsätzliches Verhalten von Frauen auf Tinder und so weiter,
Quote von 5% ist jetzt mal sehr wohlwollend.
Also mit 15.000, der Typ sitzt wahrscheinlich monatelang da und zweibt die ganze
Zeit auf Tinder irgendwelche Profile durch.
Und da ich ihm die 700 jetzt einfach mal abnehme, weil da sind solche Typen,
die versuchen das dann mit einem Witz noch zu retten. Aber meins,
wir ernst, würde ich sagen, 15.000 positive Swipes von seiner Seite.
Die Frustration ist hoch, würden wir also da sagen. Die Frustration ist hoch.
Jetzt kommt bestimmt wieder auch bei uns so ein, ja wegen diesen 15.000,
können wir mal darüber reden.
Ich glaube, du liegst da ganz, oder im Sinnfall, das war eine Lüge über mich.
Antworte mir, sonst komme ich mit meinem Anwalt so ungefähr.
Ja, ja, so läuft das immer. Da kommen wir gleich nochmal zu.
Nun war ja Montes Weihnachtsfest mit Stream und weiß ich nicht was.
Und jetzt gibt es aber diesen Bann gegen KuchenTV. Was bedeutet das?
Ich kann dadurch natürlich nicht zu Montes Event fahren.
Der hat ja am Sonntag sein Ski-Event und ich war da ja mit eingeladen.
Dadurch, dass ich gesperrt bin, darf ich halt aber in dem Stream nicht vorkommen.
Wir hatten zwar erst überlegt, ob ich vielleicht den ganzen Tag eine Maske trage,
aber da ist sowohl Monte als auch mir das Risiko einfach zu hoch.
Wenn ich irgendwie mal was trinke an der Seite und man sieht mein Gesicht,
könnte Twitch theoretisch direkt den Stream sperren und das wäre ein absoluter
Downer während dem Event. Dazu streamen ja auch andere Leute.
Das heißt, ich müsste durchgehend aufpassen, dass ich diese Maske trage.
Ich könnte nicht mal zur Seite gehen und die fünf Minuten ablegen oder so.
Deswegen bin ich nicht beim Event.
Das ist dann, wie man jetzt versucht, gerichtlich irgendwo zu verhindern,
dass Trump antreten kann. Wird man das noch schaffen?
Wird man ihn auch de-plattformen können? Also wir erleben jetzt eigentlich so eine Zeit, in der wir...
Ich meine, wir waren ja jetzt nie Habermas-Fans in dem Sinne,
dass wir sagten, das vernünftige Argument wird sich schon durchsetzen.
Aber wir erleben jetzt so eine Zeit, wo man diese Argumentation nur noch als
Illustration hat, wie du das jetzt eben geschildert hast.
Man macht nicht ein Argument, das passt, sondern versucht immer weiter,
weiter zu generieren, um den
nächsten Stream zu befüllen und stattdessen verlagert man das Ganze jetzt.
Also man hat dieses De-Platforming und sowas findet ja dann auch statt.
Trump versuchte in seiner Amtszeit Leute zu De-Platformen.
Jetzt wollte er dann auch am liebsten Biden De-Platformen, dass er gar nicht
Präsident werden kann. Die Plattform.
Ein Stream das Gesicht zeigt, dann würde auch dieser Stream gewonnen.
Also das ist ja etwas, was gar nichts mit Grundgesetz, Meinungsfreiheit oder
so zu tun hat, sondern es ist nur AGBs.
Das heißt, wir haben so eine Welt aus Gerichten und Konzernen.
Ja, also es ist schon interessant, finde ich, dass man hier nicht,
also dass Twitch nicht nur Twitch-Accounts sperrt, sondern ganze Personen.
Weil die Person erstreckt sich ja über das, was die Person auf Twitch macht.
Und dieses Dieses Hinausgreifen in die Welt finde ich schon interessant.
Ja.
Denn wäre durchaus problematisch gewesen, wenn man sagt, okay,
der Account ist weg und damit nur die Follower schafft und dann ist man aber
drei Tage später wieder, holt über Twitter, Instagram, wo auch immer,
seine Leute wieder zusammen, das Publikum und macht dann einfach weiter.
Bei YouTube hat sowas ja stattgefunden, dass dann zum Beispiel Adlersson mal
Strikes bekam wegen irgendwas, weiß ich gar nicht genau und dann aber im Stream
seines Vaters regelmäßig auftauchte.
Genau, das ist ja auch eine Frage, wie geht man mit Arbeitsverträgen um,
Sponsoring-Verträgen, wenn dann ein Account so juristisch abgeriegelt ist,
Also sagen wir mal durch Regelungen wie und so weiter, du musst hier so und
so häufig streamen und so weiter und dann macht das derjenige nicht und lässt
dann einfach den Account hinter sich und macht als Person dann woanders weiter
und baut alles neu auf, das hatten wir ja auch lange.
Hier haben wir jetzt gehört sehr wirkmächtig, Twitch sperrt einfach die ganze
Person und die Frage ist dann bei Marketing kann man einen ganzen Streamer an
sich binden oder nur dessen Account unter Vertrag nehmen hatten wir in der Musikbranche auch,
Taylor Swift sagt halt einfach naja ihr habt ja nur die Rechte an meine Aufnahme
wenn ich die einfach nochmal mache habe ich eine neue Aufnahme die ist dann
rechtlich entbunden, obwohl für den Kunden genau das gleiche Produkt dahinter steht.
Also das sind wirklich die ganz heißen Fragen.
Wir hören mal hier weiter.
So wurde beispielsweise der zweite Teil von unserem Shoyoka-Stream,
wo wir da zu viert waren, gesperrt. YouTube hat mir halt gesagt,
dass es in einigen Ländern nicht mehr aufgerufen werden kann.
Tim, das Video geht aber gar nicht. Wir müssen das jetzt leider sperren.
Ich habe das dann aber selber zur Sicherheit runtergenommen,
denn jetzt auch noch bei YouTube gestrikt zu werden, das wäre wirklich ein Downer
vor der Weihnachtszeit.
Aber ich werde natürlich ansonsten genauso weitermachen wie vorher,
denn ich mache nun mal einfach nichts falsch.
Dazu will ich aber nochmal sagen, die Cancel Culture existiert natürlich nicht.
Das ist nochmal ganz wichtig. Also das ist erfunden, dass es das gibt.
Man versucht sich jetzt so gegenseitig zu canceln. Also ich muss sagen,
ich war auch immer gegen De-Platforming von irgendwelchen Leuten,
weil ich immer sagte, ja, das kann immer ein Boomerang sein.
Also wenn man anfängt, Leute von der Plattform runter zu nehmen,
überträgt man es sehr auf die Konzerne.
Und ich würde schon noch dieses Ideal hochhalten wollen, dass man eigentlich
in einem diskursiven Raum das regeln kann, ohne dass man was sperrt.
Also es gibt, du siehst ja auch, dass man jetzt versucht, wenn irgendwelche,
gemeinnützigen Vereine Journalismus betreiben, dass natürlich dann immer die
Gegenseite versucht, deren Gemeinnützigkeit in Frage zu stellen,
damit die nicht an Gelder kommen.
Gut, ich bin eh nicht dafür, dass man das über so eine Sache regeln muss,
aber generell merke ich, dass man nicht mehr mit Argumenten angreift,
sondern man versucht jetzt immer an das Ökonomische ranzugehen.
Man versucht also immer über diese Gerichte Fakten zu schaffen,
wo am Ende nicht mehr irgendein Argument relevant ist, sondern das wissen wir
ja bei so Gerichten, auch einfach die finanziellen Möglichkeiten dagegen zu klagen.
Aber das ist nicht neu, das war schon immer so. Es kommt nur jetzt in einem
Metier, wo grundsätzlich mehr Aufmerksamkeit drauf liegt.
Aber im Markenrecht und so weiter wurde schon immer mit solchen Bandagen.
Aber wenn wir jetzt von der freien Meinungsäußerung reden, die freie Meinungsäußerung
ist ja zwar dann garantiert, nur wenn du dann Leute hast, die mit großen Schreiben
da von Anwaltskanzleien kommen, bist du ja eingeschüchtert.
Das heißt also, diese Art des Angriffs kann ja nur starten, wer auch viel Kapital
im Hintergrund hat und sich auch wieder entsprechend wehren kann.
Und das sorgt schon dafür, dass das Internet ein sehr unfreier Ort wird,
dadurch, dass also die Leute, die in einer marginaleren Position sind,
dann auch Angst haben müssen, irgendwo nicht mehr stattfinden zu können.
Klar, jetzt so ein Kuchen-TV hat da alle Möglichkeiten dagegen zu klagen,
aber bei kleineren wird das schon schwieriger.
Und ich merke schon, dass wir so eine Art Kultur des Denunzierens haben,
also dass man mal gleich noch den Arbeitgeber dazu schreibt.
Also dass man so einen Tweet macht und dann sagt hier, ach der arbeitet aber doch auch bei euch.
WDR, Edeka, Siemens oder was auch immer.
Geht das denn? Und genau, die Bild-Zeitung macht das ja auch ganz stark,
dass sie sich irgendjemand rausfischt.
Zum Beispiel war das ja bei Jean-Philippe Kindler so, dass er macht ein Video,
in dem er sich polemisch und komödiantisch zur CDU äußert,
woraufhin die Bild-Zeitung gleich eine Kampagne daraus macht,
WDR-Mitarbeiter, weil Jean-Philippe da mal auch eine Radiokolumne oder so hatte.
Und das finde ich wirklich schlimm, wenn man in diese Ecke immer weiter kommt
und alles deutet darauf hin, dass wir dahin weiter gehen.
Ich will nur eine kleine Pointe machen, ich war ja einmal beim MDR zu Gast und
die lassen einen ja einen, nur weil man mal eine Dreiviertelstunde mitternachts
am Wochentag zu Gast ist.
Gleich einen Mitarbeitervertrag unterschreiben, weil sie sich so juristisch
absichern, dass man dann sieben Seiten zugeschickt bekommt, die Geburtsnamen
der Eltern und deren Beruf mit eintragen muss.
Sehr gut, ja.
Kann man natürlich auch einfach alles durchstreichen, fragt eh keiner nach dann.
So, aber die schicken einem einfach einen Mitarbeitervertrag.
So, und das ist natürlich eine Einladung für jemanden wie die BILD zu sagen,
der Typ wird jetzt da vereinnahmt.
Der ist inkorporiert, das ist quasi der Intendant.
Ja.
Dann wird das Ganze oben aufgehangen. Da müssten dann auch, ich meine,
Weil die öffentlich-rechtlichen Häuser müssten eh mal anders mit Leuten,
die sie zeigen, umgehen, so insgesamt.
Aber hier insbesondere.
Ja, aber da sehen wir einfach, wohin das geht, wenn man dieses De-Platforming betreiben will.
Also man sagt nicht mehr, wir haben jetzt da eben über Ulrich Reitz vom Fokus gesprochen,
jetzt ist er der Chefredakteur, aber selbst wenn er jetzt Redakteur wäre,
man würde ja jetzt nicht hier sitzen und sagen, so liebe Leute,
jetzt müssen wir mal alle Briefe schreiben am Fokus, damit der Ulrich Reitz
seinen Job verliert oder so. Das würde man ja niemals machen.
Man würde sagen, dies ist eine Argumentation, die ich überhaupt nicht teile.
Und dann teilt man seine eigene Position mit und dann ist gut.
Aber was wir jetzt erleben ist, oh, das ist aber ein Journalist,
der ist ja wie ein Putin-Troll.
Geht das dann überhaupt, dass der da und dort auf einer Plattform ist?
Da müssen wir mal dagegen sein und und und. Das geht dann von allen Richtungen,
nur sind wir damit in einem heillosen Krieg, in dem immer nur die Kapitalseite
dann am Ende gewinnt, weil die Leute, die wenig Kapital im Hintergrund haben,
werden auch in der Regel solche Prozesse gar nicht anstreben können oder sie verlieren.
Ja, oder wenn Leute so geflaggt werden als Mitglieder eines Hauses, wie Jean-Philippe WDR.
Und dann haben wir ja gesehen, wie der WDR damals den Kinderchor,
der das Lied über die Oma mit dem Hühnerstall und so weiter,
komplett über die Klippe springen lässt, die quasi ausliefert. Ja.
Also vielleicht sollte man das auch in Arbeitsverträge, also Arbeitsverträge
im Sinne von, mit reinschreiben.
Wenn ich, Jean-Philippe, jetzt für Sie beim WDR arbeite, geht damit nicht nur
Honorarzahlung einher, sondern auch Rückendeckung.
Ja.
Falls hier irgendwelche Shitstorms kommen und so langsam ist ja auch juristisch definiert.
Es ist sozusagen nicht nur, ach, sie fühlen sich unwohl, er tut uns leid und
so, sondern nee, dass man dann auch eine gewisse Rückendeckung bekommt.
Beispielsweise auch finanziell oder so von diesen Häusern.
Ja, und ich finde, generell bin ich gegen De-Platforming, also jetzt außer in,
extremen Fällen, wo jetzt wirklich zum... Zu straftat oder so.
Nein, so Sachen natürlich jetzt Es gibt ja rote Linien und wir haben ja auch
ein Grundgesetz und so weiter.
Aber ich bin sehr dagegen, dass man jetzt so wie das stattfindet,
ständig jetzt mit Abmahnungen rechnen kann,
nur weil sich irgendjemand nicht ganz klar ausgedrückt hat oder ein bisschen
metaphorisch gesprochen hat oder sonst was.
Und das ist aber das Interessante, ich glaube, das ist im Zuge dieses ganzen
Faktenchecks und MyLab weist das mit Riso zusammen nochmal genau nach,
ist das so eine generelle Stimmung, dass man zwar sagen kann, es ist 15 Uhr,
aber sobald ich sage, es ist strahlender Sonnenschein, wird man schon, naja,
also wenn man mal genau am Himmel nachguckt, da war auch noch eine Wolke.
Und diese Art des Listen to the Science ist eigentlich,
also das Listen to the Science ist eigentlich, so her dieser Ansatz vielleicht
mal war, ist eigentlich der Türöffner für jede Abmahnkanzlei, die es gibt.
Ja, ich meine, nur noch ein Wort zu Alex Jones, der jetzt zurück ist auf Twitter, was ich crazy finde.
Das ist wirklich dieser ganz irgendeine.
Ja, vor allem, er wurde ja für diese Lügen, für die man ihn auch gebannt hat,
wirklich verurteilt zu mehreren hundert Millionen Dollar Schadensersatz an die Betroffenen.
Das war der, der den Amoklauf an der Schule als eine Inszenierung ausgab.
Das ist einfach erfunden, die Kinder hat es nie gegeben und die Eltern spielen
da einfach nur das Spiel der Demokraten, sollen sozusagen für die Demokraten
Unterstützung mobilisieren.
Und wie Elon Musk da auf die Idee kommt, nee, der muss gehört werden öffentlich.
Und am besten macht er den ersten Auftritt direkt bei Tucker Carlson in der Twitter-Show.
Heißt nur umso mehr, Twitter ab 2024 ist wirklich nur noch Verlautbarung eigener Angelegenheiten.
Also du teilst da so Termine, solche Sachen.
Aber nicht mehr Diskussionsplattformen. Bitte keine politischen Diskussionen mehr auf Twitter.
Wenn man irgendwas sagen will, irgendwo anders schreiben oder einen Podcast
aufmachen und das alles da vortragen oder wie auch immer aber keine innerlichen,
also von mir wird es auch keine mehr geben,
ich werde keine innerlichen Tweets, die irgendwie und so sonst wird nur noch Termine fertig.
Wo du gerade Taka Carlson ansprichst. Lass uns mal gerade dazu springen.
Ich habe nämlich zwei Clips mitgebracht von Taka Carlson.
Ich glaube, ich habe noch nie eine Sendung oder so von ihm geguckt,
aber diese Clips wurden mir aus Gründen an Weihnachten angezeigt und du ahnst
wahrscheinlich, was es ist.
Ich habe es nicht gesehen. Du hast es noch nicht gesehen, aber du weißt,
was da jetzt auf uns zukommt. Ich habe davon gehört. Und zwar,
Takakatsu hat da also eine Sendung, ich weiß nicht, bei Fox ist er ja rausgeflogen.
Die gibt es nur noch bei Twitter.
Die gibt es nur noch bei Twitter, okay. Er hat Millionen Aufrufe.
Er hat Millionen Aufrufe und dieser Clip ging dann viral.
Wir hören uns jetzt mal das an.
Also ich verrate mal nicht, wer da kommt, aber manche werden an der Stimme dann
erkennen, wer dort zu Gast ist. Und man achte auch darauf, dass er nicht mit Namen genannt wird.
Weder mit seinem Schauspielernamen noch mit seinem Charakter aus der Serie.
Well, that's really a decision for the people, Tucker. It's not something that
I really think about or want to do.
And Merry Christmas to you too. But I've always believed that nothing should
be off the table in life or in art.
Kevin Spacey sitzt jetzt bei Tucker Carlson und das finde ich so unglaublich
schade. Denn es gab ja diesen langwierigen Prozess gegen Kevin Spacey.
Er ist dann freigesprochen worden und ich dachte, das ist ein wunderbarer Schauspieler.
Jetzt hat er diesen Freispruch und jetzt muss man irgendwie schauen wird diese
Karriere nochmal in irgendeiner Weise weitergehen,
Und ja, dies ist aber nicht,
also es gibt offenbar keine Einbettung mehr von Kevin Spacey in den,
ich nenne ihn jetzt nicht negativ, sondern wirklich ganz wertneutral, in den Mainstream.
Also es ist einfach nicht vorhanden, sondern er kann jetzt nur noch bei Tucker Carlson sein.
Schließe ich jetzt daraus, sonst würde man das ja vermutlich nicht machen.
Und das ist doch auch unglaublich traurig und sagt ja dann vielleicht auch etwas
über unsere Gesellschaft. Denn, gut, ich bin jetzt in dem Fall Kevin Spacey
nicht drin, aber ich muss ja jetzt auch einen Freispruch zur Kenntnis nehmen.
Und dann muss ich sagen, ja, aber wie kann das sein? Also ich kann zum einen
sagen, gut, was hast du auch da verloren?
Aber zum anderen kann ich ja
auch sagen, ja, was hat ihn denn dazu gebracht, dass der jetzt da sitzt?
Also man kann durchaus davon ausgehen, dass jemand, der so eine jüngste Geschichte
erlebte wie Kevin Spacey, daraus private Radikalisierungserkenntnisse zieht.
Was grundsätzlich bedeutet, es gibt ja sowieso gar kein Canceln.
Man kann sie halt nur den anderen in die Arme treiben und da werden sie dankbar
aufgenommen. Das hat man in Deutschland auch.
Alle Leute, die wir so rauscanceln, tauchen ein halbes Jahr später auf Seiten
der AfD wieder auf. Ob das irgendwelche alten Börsentypen sind oder hier und
da und so Medienleute, Schauspieler.
Jeder, der weggecancelt wurde, hält das genau ein halbes Jahr aus,
nicht stattzufinden und danach ist die Bühne ja und die wird ja wirklich bereitet.
Die Leute werden ja weich gequatscht, die werden ja da dankend aufgenommen.
Ja und das ist das große Problem und jetzt werden manche sagen,
ja wie wollt ihr jetzt etwa sagen, es gibt eine Cancel Culture.
Naja es gibt nicht eine Cancel Culture in dem Sinne, dass Leute nie mehr wo
stattfinden, wie man ja sieht.
Kevin Spacey hatte ja ein Millionenpublikum, mehr als seine letzten drei Filme
zusammen werden genau diesen Clip jetzt hier gesehen haben. Wir hören uns jetzt
gleich noch einen zweiten Clip daraus an.
Aber die Sache ist, dass er dann woanders gar nicht mehr sein kann.
Und deswegen nur noch da jetzt diese, bei den Rechten dann unterwegs ist.
Beziehungsweise ja, die haben jetzt ja nur darauf gewartet, kriegen wir den.
Ja, genau.
Sehr stark mitunter eingeschränkt wird in Meinungen, die noch in manchen Sendungen kundzutun.
Also wir vertreten ja zum Beispiel, wenn wir das hier mit den ukrainischen Soldaten
oder so sagen, auch eine absolute Minderheitenposition, die kaum stattfindet.
Ist ja mal so eine Frage, wo nicht, denn diese Minderheitenposition wird vor
allem in den Medien nicht vertreten, wenn sie in der allgemeinen Bevölkerung
ja durchaus, also die Kriegslust ist nicht besonders groß.
Es gab nie eine Mehrheit, die Waffenlieferungen für die Ukraine befürwortet
hat und so weiter und so fort.
In deren Sicht ist da viel zu überdenken von denjenigen, die journalistisch dazu tätig sind.
Ja, gut, wir hören noch den zweiten Clip.
When are you getting back to work, by the way? Oh, I've been back at work from
the moment we started talking, Tucker.
So does that mean this is like an episode or is it real?
Well, it's probably a little of both. I mean, Tucker, what's true, what's false?
What's life, what's art? What's real, what's performance?
I love it when these things intersect, because then it gets interesting.
Wir haben History Has Begun gelesen von Bruno Marquez. Das ist die These von
Bruno Marquez in Kurzform.
Ich habe ja noch diesen etwas irren Vorschlag gemacht, sollten die Linken nicht
lieber mal professionelle Schauspieler einsetzen, die Linken Politiker in Talkshows
spielen, damit die Repräsentation stimmt.
Und hier leben wir das eigentlich alles schon und bekommen es dann von Francis
Underwood beziehungsweise Kevin Spacey vorgestellt.
Ja, also Niklas Luhmann ist jetzt 25 Jahre tot und seine Abschiedsvorlesung,
was ist der Fall und was steckt dahinter? Die Antwort, nichts.
Der Fall wird auf der Vorderbühne durchgespielt.
Klaus Japp, der damals meine Diplomarbeit bedrohte und einer dieser Hardcore-Lumanianer
in Bielefeld war, hat mit einer zweiten Autorin, Kusche, glaube ich,
weiß gar nicht genau, so einen Text damals geschrieben,
sozusagen rausdestilliert aus Lumans politischer Systemtheorie.
Gibt es einen Unterschied zwischen Politik darstellen und Politik herstellen?
Und die Antwort ist nein.
Es gibt kein, okay, hier hat der Ausschuss getagt und mehrheitlich entschieden
und dann gehen wir vor die Presse und verkünden, stellen dar,
was drin hergestellt wurde.
Dieses Bild so verständlich, intuitiv, plausibel und nah an der Leberwurst es ist,
aber es wird nicht einfach wie beim Essen danach garniert, was vorher hergestellt
wurde, damit es in der Darstellung überzeugt und so weiter, sondern das ist einfach eins.
Und selten hat das jemand hier natürlich spielerisch mal kurz dargestellt,
denn, ja, wer sitzt denn jetzt da?
Ist es Frank Underwood, ist es Kevin Spacey oder, dritte Entscheidung,
ist es egal. Und es ist einfach egal. Egal.
Ich meine, damals hat, auf diese Geschichte komme ich ja immer wieder gerne
zu sprechen, weil sie so eindrücklich ist, aber,
Aiken, wie heißt er, Sorkin, Dingsdabums, der Drehbuchautor,
Aaron Sorkin, genau, hat damals West Wing gemacht.
Also Bill Clinton war amerikanischer Präsident,
dann hat man diese Fernsehserie gemacht, in der Chad Bartlett diese Art Bill-Clinton-Regentschaft
nochmal aufs Idealtypische hochlevelt und den Leuten verkauft,
so machen wir hier Politik.
Und zwar ganz klar, das ist ein demokratischer Präsident.
Das hat natürlich mit zu dieser Lagerbildung, das will ich nicht,
ich möchte den Gegenentwurf, den Gegenentwurf gab es nie als Fernsehserie,
Donald Trump hat es dann einfach so gespielt, hat das Angebot gemacht,
ich verhalte mich genauso wie ihr das wollt, auch im Amt und dann haben sie genau das bekommen.
Und in dieser Fernsehserie West Wing, als noch der weiße amerikanische Mann,
Politiker und so weiter idealtypisch verherrlicht wurde, spielt in den letzten
zwei Staffeln ein hispanischer junger Abgeordneter für Familie,
der in feuernden Reden und so weiter die Leute in seinen Bann schlägt.
Und dann stellt man später fest, krass, das ist ja wirklich eins zu eins bis
auf Hope and Change und Yes We Can und so weiter.
Die Obama-Wahlkampf- und Präsidentschaft nur Jahre bevor Obama Präsident wurde.
Und dann sagt Sorkin, ja, aber ich kannte ja den jungen Senator.
Und hab mir gedacht, wie wär's, wenn der antritt? Und dann hab ich genau das gestaltet.
Und da geht alles so eins in eins über, Lieber, wie wir ja auch grundsätzlich uns hier fragen,
wenn Tucker Carlson ihn fragt, ob er noch in den Wahlkampf einsteigt,
also nicht, ob er dann Präsident ist, sondern in den Wahlkampf.
Ja, was ist denn Wahlkampf? Ist Wahlkampf eine Fernsehshow oder Politik?
Das kann niemand beantworten.
Niemand bei Verstand kann einfach sagen, nee, das ist Politik.
Das ist keine Medienarbeit. Sondern, nee, es ist nur Medienarbeit, aber trotzdem Politik.
Was ist es eigentlich? Es ist beides. Und er sagt ja einfach, es ist doch egal.
Und wir sind uns einig, dass wahrscheinlich er der Einzige wäre,
der amtsschlagen könnte.
Das könnte natürlich auch immer sein. Es hängt auch Tucker Carlson an,
noch Präsident werden zu wollen für die Amerikaner.
Ja, aber dafür ist er glaube ich ein bisschen zu cringe.
Ja und ich muss leider sagen, das war einer der klügeren politischen Clips,
die wir dieses Jahr hier gespielt haben.
Was er bei Tucker Carlson sagt, ist doch egal.
Ist verrückt, oder?
Es ist wirklich dramatisch. Also wir sind dramatisch auf unserer Seite dieser Unterscheidung.
Ja, und jetzt hören wir nochmal Monte und wir haben ja jetzt gemerkt, FDP,
CDU und AfD sowieso gehen auf diesen Kulturkampf, die Linken sind das große
Problem und nun ist jetzt Monte und KuchenTV, die würden immer sagen,
wir sind ja unpolitisch, aber dann kommen solche Äußerungen.
Hat sie dann...
Einen Tweet gemacht. Warum hast du mich auf Twitter blockiert? Grund 3812.
Ihr müsst jetzt wirklich starke Nerven haben, lieber Leihstream-Chat.
Ihr müsst jetzt wirklich starke Nerven haben, weil das ist so weit weg von der
Realität, dass es mir wirklich schon Angst macht. 3, 2, 1.
Shoyoka hat nichts in der Kategorie zu suchen. Nichts. Auch rein gar nichts.
Und dass sie dort drin ist, zeigt einfach, wie linksversifft auch mittlerweile
hier diese ganze Szene ist. Digga, ist widerlich. Es f***t einfach nur noch ab.
Also halten wir fest, ich sage da, ich rege mich darüber auf,
dass sie den Spielepreis gewonnen hat und sage, dass sie sich das...
Man muss das erklären, also Monte reagiert jetzt auf Clips, die er gemacht hat
schon zu Schujoka. Also Monte reagiert auf Monte.
Den, der die Stern binden soll, durch die Stadt laufen soll und ich klatsche.
Das ist ihr Grund, warum sie mich auf Twitter blockiert hat. Grund Nummer 3812. 12.
Um dann nochmal ihre Meinung zu verstärken, schreibt sie da drunter.
Oh Gott, sie hat mich jetzt, nein.
Liebe Shoyoka, du hast mich nicht jetzt wirklich auch noch mit Gönner G live
gerade gebannt. Och nein, Shoyoka.
Mensch, das ist aber so, ach man, Shoyoka.
Das ist wirklich so ein erwachsenes Verhalten von dir.
Also für Shoyoka einmal Clap in den Chat, die gerade auch live zuschaut.
Das ist wirklich ganz großes Kino von dir.
Das ist wirklich, wirklich, Shoyoka, das ist ganz großes Kino.
So geht das nonstop.
Man kann es nicht ganz ausblenden, wenn man minimal soziologisch aufgeklärt
ist, dass Interaktionen noch nie stattfanden, weil etwas zu besprechen war,
sondern Interaktionen finden statt und suchen sich dann ein Thema. über.
Egal welches, deswegen ja auch alle möglichen Coachings zum Thema Smalltalk,
Smalltalk mit dem Chef, Smalltalk mit der Familie, über was reden,
um das Wetter zu vermeiden und zwar nicht, weil das Wetter ein unattraktives
Thema ist, sondern weil man, wenn man über das Wetter redet,
zu erkennen gibt, wir sind ja gerade in einem Smalltalk,
wir gestalten hier gerade und so sitzen die auch da, füllen ihre Streams,
man merkt ja richtig, wie sie händeringend nach Themen suchen und dann,
zum Glück, das nächste nächste Video von dir ist da, ich kann heute Abend streamen.
Und wenn man das nicht ausblendet, ist es wirklich erbärmlich,
das zu hören und man hält es ehrlich gesagt auch nicht gut aus.
Also es ist, es hat so ein gewisses Fremdschäden- Potenzial,
wie wenn man auf der Bühne so Performance-Künstler sieht, von denen alle wissen,
die müssen jetzt irgendwie performen und dann klappt es aber nicht.
Und man kommt aber aus der Nummer nicht raus, weil sie geht noch fünf Minuten.
Wir springen jetzt mal gerade dahin noch noch, dass es um die Werbepartner von
KuchenTV geht, denn es war so, dass jetzt bei Twitter diese Werbepartner markiert wurden,
von Shoyoka, dass sie doch mal überlegen sollen, ob sie noch mit KuchenTV zusammenarbeiten.
Darauf reagiert dann auch wieder KuchenTV.
Und das Ganze geht sogar so weit, dass sie jetzt auf Twitter meine Werbepartner
markiert, in der Hoffnung, dass ich die verliere.
Was sowieso nichts bringt, weil das war ein einmaliges Placement,
das ist draußen und bezahlt werde ich trotzdem.
Das Lustige ist, dass dieses Placement ja nicht mal in dem Video war, wo es um sie geht.
Ja, also da regt er sich unglaublich auf. Er sagt dann auch,
dass er gegen die Plattforming sei in einem anderen Stream.
Und dann hört man aber folgendes.
Jo Freunde der staatlich finanzierten Hetze. Immer wenn man denkt,
ja okay, das Shoyoka-Freiraum-Re-Thema wird jetzt so langsam enden,
kommt immer irgendjemand, der nochmal einen drauflegt.
Die Amadeo Antonio Stiftung hat jetzt nämlich einen langen Twitter-Thread hochgeladen,
wo Mia, Skurrus und Monte unter anderem Rechtsextremismus und Frauenfeindlichkeit vorgeworfen wird.
Unsere gesamte Kritik gegen Shoyoka und Freiraum-Re wird als neues Gamergate
bezeichnet. Das war 2014 mal so ein Skandal, wo viele Frauen sich darüber beschwert
haben, online sexuell belästigt zu werden.
Bevor wir allerdings anfangen, eine kleine Bitte. Und zwar wird die Amadeus-Antonius-Stiftung
teilweise durch unsere Steuergelder bezahlt.
Genau genommen vom Bundesministerium für Familie, Senioren, Frauen und Jugend.
Diese kann man auf deren Seite per E-Mail erreichen.
Ich würde mich mega freuen, nachdem ihr das Video geguckt habt und wenn ihr
die gleiche Meinung habt wie ich, dass ihr denen eine wirklich sachliche und
konstruktive E-Mail schreibt, wo ihr denen auch zeigt, warum man die staatlichen
Zuschüsse vielleicht einstellen sollte.
Denn das, was sie hier gemacht haben, ist krass. Das kann ich euch sagen.
So Joka will, dass der KuchenTV keine Werbegelder mehr bekommt.
KuchenTV will, dass die Amadeo-Stiftung keine Gelder mehr bekommt.
Jetzt werden die Horden losgeschickt. Jeder soll mal eine E-Mail schreiben. Es ist unglaublich.
Werden diese E-Mails demnächst von GPT geschrieben?
Man hat so eine Standard, was innerlich drin vorkommt und dann mit dem Download-Button
wird direkt ein Prompt ausgelöst, der das ausformuliert, aber individuell.
Ja, aber man merkt hier, die reden, aber ich habe das jetzt mal nicht mitgebracht,
noch ganz stark darüber,
wer wie viel Steuern zahlen muss, wer Kosten mehr jetzt hat durch all diese
Anwaltssachen oder auch wer Verluste hat bei den Subs,
also bei Shoyoka hat wohl Subs verloren,
warum, das wird dann diskutiert, ist sie nicht selbst daran schuld.
Also es ist interessant, dass diese Ökonomie ein permanentes Thema ist,
weil wie wir ja schon mal eben sagten bei dem Thema Reichtum und Erben,
für die ist die Zahl, die Summe, das ist der eigentliche Inhalt am Ende.
Und es ist aber auch interessant, wie sehr alle dieses Spiel verstanden haben.
Also Shoyoka hat dann in einem Stream, die wird da jetzt mal ganz kurz eingeblendet,
so Geschwindigkeit erhöht, überlegt, ob irgendjemand Böhmermann kennt.
Denn sie hätte so viele Screenshots und Mitschnitte aus den Streams von KuchenTV und Co.
Und wir hören jetzt mal an uns, wie KuchenTV wiederum darauf reagiert.
Falls jemand von euch Jan Böhmermann kennt, ich kann ihm alles schicken.
Wir haben aus dem ganzen Jahr Streams, Videos, Clip-Ausschnitte,
Podcasts, Aussagen von den Leuten.
Wenn Jan Böhmermann Bock hat, ein Zerstörungsvideo zu frauenhassenden Influencern
zu machen, für ZDF mit Neomagazin und Royal, ich lege ihm alles offen.
Ja, Shoyoka ist eine komplett gesunde, ganz normale Person, alles in Ordnung, gar kein Problem.
Jetzt will sie Jan Böhmermann vorschicken, der ein Video über mich macht.
Das Geile ist, ey, ich würde mich sogar freuen darüber, sage ich euch ganz ehrlich,
das wäre ja so ein krasser Push.
Imagine, Jan Böhmermann macht ein Video zu mir und ich mache ein Video zurück.
Jetzt spielen sie so ihr eigenes dreidimensionales Schach.
Und wir hören jetzt zum Schluss noch Christian Solmecke,
der Anwalt, der sich in YouTube-Belangen sehr gut auskennt und Streamer-Belangen
und der ja auch mit all diesen Influencern offenbar,
oder nicht mit allen, aber mit einigen doch vernetzt ist und der dann auch schon
mehrere Videos zu dem Fallkuchen-TV und Show-Yoka gemacht hat.
Denkt man sich auch, will man das, wenn man Anwalt ist?
Also ich habe jetzt schon die Nase voll davon.
Ich habe ein wahnsinnig interessantes Interview mit ihm gehört.
Ich hatte dir auch so einen Ausschnitt geschickt.
Nicht für heute, aber das hören wir uns nochmal an, weil das ist auch zum Thema,
wie arbeitet man eigentlich und so. Ganz interessante Sachen.
Ja, jedenfalls geht er jetzt darauf ein, dass bevor dieser Bann kam,
KuchenTV ein Abmahnschreiben erhalten hat von Shoyoka.
Und da werden verschiedene Punkte jetzt durchgegangen. Wir greifen jetzt mal
einen Punkt heraus, was da vorgeworfen wurde.
Christian Solmecke ordnet das dann für uns ein.
Aber der Anwalt hat ja noch ein paar Sachen mehr in petto gehabt.
Mal gucken, was wir hier noch finden. Unsere Mandantin lässt keine andere Meinung zu.
Unsere Mandantin steht seit...
Also das ist der Vorwurf, KurenTV muss in einem Stream mal gesagt haben,
Shoyoka lässt keine andere Meinung zu und das soll jetzt abgemahnt werden.
Jeher für einen Diskurs, sowohl mit ihrer Community als auch gegenüber Kritikern.
Also er hat gesagt, sie lässt keine andere Meinung zu und das missfällt ihr und ihrem Anwalt.
Was steht da?
Ja, also ich weiß nicht, das ist halt, also Bruder, die hat Bilal 2K geblockt,
weil der gefragt hat, ob sie Lust hätte, in ein Twitterspace mit mir und Monte zu gehen. Ja.
Aber okay, also was hier angegriffen wird, ist die Aussage, sie lässt keine andere Meinung zu.
Und sie sagt jetzt, ich lasse natürlich andere Meinungen zu, was soll das denn?
Und da muss man sagen, naja, KuchenTV will natürlich damit sagen,
sie spricht sehr viel ihre Meinung, sie lässt keine Widerworte vor und er begründet es ja auch.
Auch sie blockt Leute, die andere Meinungen sind und insofern,
ja ehrlicherweise ist das eine Meinungsäußerung und die ist nicht mal besonders
abwertend gemeint. Das kann man ja über jemanden sagen, er lässt keine anderen Meinungen zu.
Das ist auch eine absolut zulässige Meinungsäußerung.
Ja und auf diesem Gebiet sind wir jetzt angekommen, dass man jetzt einfach jede
Aussage einfach nochmal diskutiert, darf man überhaupt sagen,
ist das von der Meinungsfreiheit gedeckt.
Und das ist natürlich ein wunderbares Feld für Anwälte.
Genau, wir lassen das Gericht also anwältlich mal überprüfen,
was der Anwalt dazu sagt und teilen das in den Briefen mit.
Alles kann so überprüft werden und deswegen sehe ich, was diese Zunahme von
der Einflusssphäre der Plattform und der Gerichte anbelangt,
tatsächlich die Meinungsfreiheit.
Das ist vielleicht die viel größere Gefahr als jetzt wer wo mal gecancelt oder was wird,
sondern tatsächlich haben wir eine Stimmung, bei der man immer sagt,
na da gehe ich mal wieder vor Gericht und das kann sich immer nur der leisten, der Geld hat.
Und um das jetzt abzubinden, kommen wir jetzt zurück in die Hochkultur.
Es gibt ja die Autorin Adania Shibli, israelische Autorin palästinensischer
arabischer Herkunft, die nicht diesen Preis da auf der Buchmesse bekam.
Die hat diesen Roman eine Nebensache geschrieben. Und es gab dazu,
zu dieser Ausladung, einen Artikel, in dem es um ihr Buch und ihr Werk ging,
in der Taz überschrieben mit dem Titel Schatten auf der Buchmesse.
Damit war die Autorin Schiebli nicht einverstanden mit diesem Text.
Und was machte sie? Sie ging vor Gericht.
Es war also eine Rezension und in dieser war folgendes zu lesen.
In diesem Kurzroman, also eine Nebensache, sind alle Israelis anonyme Vergewaltiger
und Killer, die Palästinenser hingegen Opfer.
Die Gewalt gegen israelische Zivilisten kommt wohl auch deshalb nicht vor,
weil sie als legitimes Mittel im Befreiungskampf gegen die Besatzer gilt.
Das ist die ideologische und auch menschenverachtende Basis des Buchs.
Das war also der doch sehr scharfe Angriff in der Kritik. Ich habe das Buch
nicht gelesen, keine Ahnung, aber ist auch völlig egal, ob ich das so sehe oder nicht.
Jedenfalls hat das Gericht entschieden, nein, das darf so erscheinen,
dass es in Form einer Rezension erschienen und so ist das Werk interpretiert worden.
Denn wo kommen wir eigentlich hin, wenn so etwas plötzlich abgemahnt werden kann?
Also dann kann ich meine Filmanalyse sofort schließen. Also wenn ich da sage,
der neue Disney-Film propagiert ein frauenfeindliches Ideal und er hält dies und das hoch,
den Kapitalismus, was weiß ich, dann können die mir dann auch sagen,
nee, also frauenfeindlich ist das nicht.
Nicht, dass Disney bemüht sich um ein diverses Bild von Frauen in seinen Filmen oder was.
Also wir, wo sollen das noch hinführen?
Also ich bin dann froh, dass jetzt so ein Gericht da gekommen ist und gesagt
hat, das geht jetzt nicht. Und dann verstehe ich auch nicht,
wie man da als Autorin oder als Verlag auf die Idee kommen kann, so etwas abzumahnen.
Dann muss man sehen, dass man entweder damit lebt oder man versucht ein Interview
der Taz zu geben oder macht auch eine Replik und die wird irgendwo veröffentlicht.
Man hat ja auch alle Möglichkeiten, das nicht in der Zeitung,
sondern woanders zu veröffentlichen, auf dem eigenen Blog hochzuladen,
was auch immer und sicherlich gibt es auch an dieser Rezension dann wieder was
zu kritisieren, was man ja tatsächlich aufgreifen kann,
aber dass man glaubt, man müsse jetzt alles in die Hände der Gerichte legen,
finde ich eine ganz besorgniserregende Entwicklung und das können wir hier erleben.
Allen Ebenen und es geht nur noch darum,
dass man versucht, also andere zum Schweigen zu bringen und nun müssen Monte
und so weiter das zum Schweigen bringen, gar nicht so sehr über die Gerichte machen,
sondern die können ihre Trollarmeen dann losschicken und hetzen lassen und die
anderen, und die müssen sie ja gar nicht losschicken, sondern sie sagen einfach,
guck mal, was Shoyoka gemacht hat und dann setzen die sich schon von selbst in Bewegung.
Und zugleich versucht man dann da wieder die Plattforming zu betreiben.
Also es ist sehr ungut. Wir sehen das hier in einem Streamerfeld,
wo es uns wahrscheinlich, die wir hier zuhören, fast alle nicht besonders betrifft.
Aber wenn wir sehen, wie sehr das jetzt auch sonst Einzug hält,
wie das also auch im Journalismus, in der Literaturkritik dann selbst vorkommen
kann, dann merken wir plötzlich,
wie also die freie Meinungsäußerung sehr stark eingeschränkt wird,
weil die Schere im Kopf dann irgendwann da ist, dass man sagt,
Wenn ich das so schreibe, könnte es dann sein, dass ich so ein Abmahnschreiben bekomme.
Dann formuliere ich es mal lieber so ein bisschen, dass es nicht ganz so hart ist.
Also ich bin da ein bisschen unentschieden. Ich wünsche mir nämlich auf der
einen Seite, dass grundsätzlich weniger fabuliert wird.
Wir hatten ja früher eine Situation, es war politisch alles relativ ruhig und
man hat sich eine Viertelstunde lang am Tag mit Politik befasst.
Danach hat man mit Egon am Gartenzaun über Politik gesprochen und wusste genau,
gefährliches Halbfest von beiden Seiten.
Das ist nur der Egon, ich nehme mir nichts für voll. Heute kommt natürlich Egons
Meinung sehr viel aufgehübschter über technische Geräusche, sagt Habermas.
Genau, irgendwie so. Also es ist omnipräsent und die ästhetische Qualität ist sehr viel höher.
Also man unterstellt politische Argumentationen, die man so im Internet oder
wie auch immer mitbekommt. Immer sehr viel mehr inhaltliches Zeug.
So, jetzt haben diese Twitcher hier solche Sätze wie, sie lässt keine anderen Meinungen zu.
Da würde ich sagen, da braucht man kein Jurist sein, sondern man versteht sofort,
der Streitwert ist ungefähr null.
Also die materiellen Effekte eines, ah, das ist eine Lüge oder nicht, ja, keine Ahnung.
Lässt sie halt Meinung zu oder nicht, also wie soll man es entscheiden?
Ist die Frage, wenn die aber so schnell dann auf so einen juristischen Weg ausweichen,
heißt das ja, okay, das ist auf jeden Fall mit Kosten verbunden.
Also von Solmecke weiß ich, der hat 100 Mitarbeiter und die Kosten,
wenn man sie bucht, 370 Euro die Stunde. So.
Wenn ich jetzt auf einen Brief antworten will, der mir geschickt wird und ich
bin sozusagen Twitcher, ich habe keine Ahnung von nichts.
Ach ja, da ist ja dieser Solmecke, der ist doch Anwalt. Frage ich natürlich
bei WBS Legal nach in Köln, ob die das irgendwie für mich regeln können.
Dann sagen die, okay, Erstgespräch, 10 Minuten am Telefon, kostenlos.
Danach, wenn wir wirklich für sie tätig werden, 370 Euro. Mache ich das oder nicht?
Also wir sind relativ zügig auf einem juristischen Feld. Aber,
meine Erfahrung ist, man ist auch schon auf dem juristischen Feld,
wo es soziale Effekte hat,
auch wenn noch nicht ein Jurist argumentiert, also der Briefkopf ist dann entscheidend,
sondern wenn man schon mal fünf Seiten ausformuliertes Zeug mit der eigenen Meinung,
die nur noch sozusagen den Unterschriften-Federstreich eines Juristen,
ab dann wird es teuer, das ist das Signal.
Und meiner Meinung nach werden wir relativ zügig jetzt nicht nur hübschere E-Mails bekommen,
weil man einfach GPT sagt, mach mal die E-Mail schön, sondern formuliere sie
auch juristisch zutreffend mit den Beispielen, die ich dir gerade genannt habe.
Diese Briefe werden ihre Wirkung haben, schon allein, weil sie lesbar sind.
Also man hat dann ein Schriftstück in der Hand, das erstmal für sich intrinsische Logik hat,
denn wenn jemand GPT einfach sagt, nimm dir mal meine letzten Streams,
transkribiere und antworte auf diesen Vorwurf, dann habe ich auf jeden Fall
schon mal eine Gesprächsgrundlage.
Wo dann das Gespräch geführt wird, vor Gericht oder wie auch immer, ist ja egal,
aber man hat schon mal was in der Hand, was in die richtige Richtung führt und
ich glaube, wir werden relativ viele Sachen, die heute noch so rechtsstreitsmäßig
irgendwie im unklaren sind, schon allein, weil niemand die Expertise einholt, weil sie teuer ist,
dass wir da relativ zügig so Klärungen haben.
Ja, aber die, die sie einholen können, die...
Also ich habe ja auch zum Beispiel mal ein Anwaltsschreiben bekommen von jemandem
aus dem Influencer-Bereich. Völlig unhaltbar.
Durch einen privaten Kontakt wurde das abgewendet, dass ich darauf reagieren musste.
Aber natürlich ist man in diesem Moment eingeschüchtert und denkt,
oh, bin ich rechtsschutzversichert, bin ich das? Ja, okay, und was wird das
wohl kosten, wenn ich das so und so mache?
Während die Person, die das macht, einfach Multimillionärin ist und sagen kann,
boah, dann schicke ich das mal los, mal gucken, was passiert.
Und diese, das finde ich so tragisch, dass wir immer mehr in diese Richtung
gehen und dann wird mich ja auch nicht Chet Chibiti selbst daraus halten,
wenn du einen Brief bekommst, wo fünf Anwälte drauf aufgeführt sind und eine
Großkanzlei, da wirst du ja nicht sagen, oh, ich gehe mal an Chet Chibiti und schicke den selbst.
Das wird man nicht machen, Stefan, weil man muss dann auf Augenhöhe denen begegnen
und dann musst du schon eine Säulmecke oder so an deiner Seite haben,
um darauf reagieren zu können.
Ja, ich habe ja selber solche Rechtsstreitsigkeiten auch sehr erfolgreich geführt,
beispielsweise gegen den Endgegner überhaupt, das Finanzamt.
So, und das Ding ist, bislang verlassen sich zu viele Menschen,
weil es nämlich über das Geld geregelt werden kann, darauf,
dass der Brief eines Anwalts alleine schon einschüchtert, während dir jeder
Anwalt sagt, rede nur mit Staatsanwälten oder mit Richtern.
Rede nicht mit der Polizei, rede nicht mit Anwälten. So, wir,
die wir alle zehn Jahre mal einen Brief von einem Anwalt bekommen,
sind natürlich dann eingeschüchtert.
Nur, was wäre denn, wenn du diesen Brief fotografierst und dein Handy sagt dir
einfach, Standard, mach dir hier mal wirklich keine Sorgen.
Okay.
Also meine Vermutung ist, es ist natürlich nur grob geschätzt,
aber von den zivilrechtlichen Briefen, die in Deutschland verschickt werden,
sind 98% Einschüchterungsversuche.
Die führen genau zu nichts und bislang haben sie immer Erfolg,
weil sie einschüchtern.
Ah und du meinst, dass wir mit JetGPT eine Waffe an die Hand bekommen und können
uns dagegen billig wehren.
JetGPT geht ja sehr gerne mit formatierten Text um.
Deswegen ist das ja beim Programmieren so stark, dass sich mittlerweile 80%
der Programmierer einfach Sorgen machen, weil sie nicht zu den Top 20% gehören.
Juristische Texte sind ja genauso formatiert, inhaltlich.
Die kann man also genauso gut auslesen, den Sinn eines Gesetzes sich anwenden
lassen auf die eigene Fragestellung.
Das ist wirklich nur, also das wird 2024 möglich sein.
Da gebe ich dir, na was heißt ich gebe dir recht, ich würde sagen,
ich halte das auch für möglich, dass da Verbesserungen kommen,
dass es da eine Demokratisierung gibt, die bislang nicht stattgefunden hat und
man gegen solche Schreiben anders vorgehen kann. Ja, weißt du wie?
Die primäre neue Vorgehensweise wird sein, Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020,
Okay, lassen Sie uns das vor einem Richter klären.
Denn üblicherweise ist das, also man kriegt die Einschüchterung,
mein Anwalt hat gesagt so und so.
Und der Gegenentwurf zu sagen, ja dann lassen wir es aber auch wirklich,
also wir lassen uns noch keine Vergleiche ein oder so, sondern dann muss das
aber auch vor Gericht geklärt werden.
Das ist dann immer sozusagen die Gegenprobe, die dann meistens abgeblockt wird.
Aber um den Satz zu sagen, musst du schon auch Geld im Hintergrund selbst haben.
Denn wenn du das nicht im Hintergrund hast, also sagen wir mal,
du wärst jetzt freier Journalist und hast irgendwo einen Kommentar verfasst.
Ich kenne zum Beispiel jemanden, der eine Reportage verfasst hat,
in der es auch am Ende darum ging, dass er sagt, mit seinem nachtblauen T-Shirt
leuchtete er bis in Reihe 10.
Und der entsprechende Mann kann dann nachweisen, dass er gar kein blaues,
sondern ein rotes T-Shirt anhatte und dann gibt es eine Abmahnung.
Und ich habe mitbekommen, was das für Kosten sind.
Man muss sich um diesen Mann keine Sorgen machen, weil er so ganz gut versorgt
ist. Aber der hat das aber in der Tätigkeit als freier Journalist geschrieben.
Das heißt, wir haben es da mit einem Artikel zu tun, für den der 160 Euro bekommen hat.
Und der macht jetzt dieses Gerichtsspiel mit, weil er Geld im Hintergrund hat,
wo er sagte, ich fechte das mal durch.
Aber wenn er natürlich jetzt von 1400 netto als freier Journalist leben würde,
würde er natürlich sofort sagen, Hilfe, ich mache alles, was ihr wollt,
aber bitte lasst mich in Ruhe.
Ja und dieser Punkt bleibt bestehen auch durch Chachibiti und ich stelle nur fest,
wenn ich das auch sehe, was da welche Streitigkeiten Dara da bei Twitter austrägt,
von wem er da angegriffen wird und so,
es geht wirklich nach zwei Tweets immer gleich Anwaltsschreiben kommt, Abmahnung etc. etc.
Also das ist jetzt so ein ganz, das gehört jetzt mit zu einer Diskussion dazu.
Also es ist nicht, dass man nochmal irgendwie ein neues rhetorisches Bild aufmacht
oder eine Metapher sucht. Nein, man sagt dann Anwalt.
Wir streiten jetzt über irgendwas und ich sage, naja, so also noch ein Wort
Stefan, dann aber Anwalt.
Man hat halt gerne Anwälte.
Ja und das finde ich so furchtbar und wenn wir das jetzt mal auf dieser politischen
Ebene sehen, ist das, wir haben jetzt diese diese...
Große Gefahr, dass Trump wieder Präsident wird. Jetzt guckt man nur noch,
ob man irgendwie gerichtlich das noch einlegen kann.
Und es ist eigentlich Nahrmutzeugnis, dass man es nicht auf einem demokratischen Weg mehr hinbekommt.
Und wir haben eine Gesellschaft, die eigentlich sehr weit gekommen ist,
auch was Liberalisierung von vielen Rechten anbelangt und zugleich wird auf
Twitch oder auch bei YouTube ein Frauenhass ausgeschüttet,
wie er in den letzten Jahrzehnten nicht zu finden war.
Also ja, wir haben zum einen ganz viele patriarchale Strukturen überwunden,
zum anderen haben wir barbarischste Äußerungen gegenüber Frauen,
die da sind und wir können jetzt nur noch darauf vertrauen,
dass die AGBs irgendwo greifen, dass gewisse Kommentare nicht mehr stattfinden.
Worum es aber eigentlich natürlich gehen müsste, wäre eine Gesellschaft zu haben,
in der solche Äußerungen gar nicht getroffen werden.
Ich habe jetzt diesen Film kürzlich gesehen, How to have Sex,
der ist bei mir auf Platz 3 der Bestsellerliste.
Und da geht es darum, dass 16-jährige Britinnen auf Kreta ihren ersten Urlaub
machen und die eine will die Jungfräulichkeit verlieren und so weiter.
Und dann geht es darum, dass sie dort Sex hat, der nicht wirklich freiwillig ist.
Und es gibt aber so einen interessanten Punkt in diesem Film,
wo die Regisseurin uns zeigt, ja rechtlich wird das schwierig.
Sie sagt ja und als sie ja sagt, legt er los. Und dann merkt man,
die Kunst kann aber einfangen, dass das nicht ein Ja ist.
Also ist Ja ist auch nicht Ja in dem Sinne. Und was uns eigentlich die Regisseurin
da zeigen will ist, dass wir Sexualpraktiken, alles kennen wir,
sind wir bestens aufgeklärt durch Internet und Co. Aber wie wir miteinander
umgehen, das wissen wir eigentlich nicht.
Und das ist auch über eine Verrechtlichung nicht herzustellen,
was gesellschaftlich fehlt.
Das Recht müsste eigentlich da im Ernstfall einsetzen. Wenn mir gleich einer
das Auto geklaut hat, dann müsste ich mal irgendwie sagen, hier stimmt was nicht.
Aber der Rest muss im Miteinander eigentlich so funktionieren.
Und das sehen wir, wie das hier nicht stattfindet. Und das letzte,
zu dem man greift, sind Gerichte und AGBs.
Und das, glaube ich, ist kein gutes Zeichen für die Zukunft unserer Gesellschaft.
Stimmt, stimmt, stimmt.
Mir schwebt Folgendes vor Augen. Wie dies Jahr geschehen, ich fahre nachts mit
der S-Bahn und sitze in diesem ganz kleinen Erste-Klasse-Abteil.
Und muss 23 Uhr sehe ich mich konfrontiert mit einem Schaffner,
der mir sagt, das geht nicht, sie haben ja nur ein Deutschland-Ticket,
also zweite Klasse wäre gegangen.
Und dann ist die Frage, muss ich jetzt eigentlich den kompletten,
als hätte ich gar kein Ticket, 60 Euro zahlen oder kann ich das nachzahlen oder wie auch immer.
Das sind solche Sachen und das ist jetzt Schiffrefüge, ganz viele Sachen,
Gartenzaunthemen, Autoverkehr, was darf der Nachbar und so weiter und so fort.
So, da will man ja eigentlich juristische Klarheit, aber in dem Moment müsste
man in irgendwelchen Gesetzestexten plus den AGBs der Bahn nochmal nachblättern,
wie ist das jetzt genau geregelt.
Diese Fragen werden wir ab jetzt einfach auf Zuruf für uns klären.
Was ja für uns bedeutet, nicht nur können wir sehr schnell einschätzen,
ob wir im Recht sind, sondern uns wird einfach neuerdings eine Maschine sagen,
dass wir im Unrecht sind, wenn wir im Unrecht sind.
So. Bislang hat man dann so auf Freundschaftsdienste zurückgegriffen.
Du hast auch schon mal Erfahrung mit dem. Das müsste doch eigentlich so ähnlich sein und so weiter.
Und so länger dieses Gespräch führt, umso mehr quatscht man sich in so einen
antizipierten Erfolg rein. Zieh mal durch und so weiter.
Diesmal noch im allerersten Impuls fragt man GPT und GPT sagt einfach,
naja, Paragraph 7 heißt halt volles Fahrgeld.
Also man muss alles nachzahlen, 60 Euro.
Dann weiß ich doch in dem Moment, aus der Nummer komme ich jetzt nicht raus.
Egal wie sehr ich es mir wünsche, egal wie sehr das dem Sachverstand,
wie auch immer, das müsste ich jetzt politisch anleiern, dass sich das ändert,
aber die Grundlage ist erstmal wie sie ist.
Und ich glaube, wir werden bei sehr vielen Sachen sehr viel Klarheit bekommen.
Selbst bei solchen Sachen wie hier im Podcast, wenn wir, es gibt ein sehr interessantes
Video von Solmecke, wo er mal klärt, darf man eigentlich einfach anderen Kram
spielen, wo er ganz YouTube überflutet ist mit.
Reaction-Videos. Also Monte guckt ja konkret Videos von ihr und bespricht die
dann. Darf er das eigentlich?
Weil sie macht das ja aus Unterhaltungszwecken für ihr Publikum und verdient
damit Geld und jetzt spielt er das einfach auch.
Also spielt er das eigentlich eigentlich zu Unterhaltungszwecken und baut den
Konflikt nur drumherum, um sich an ihrem Material Publikum zu erarbeiten.
Ist ja irgendwie naheliegend. So und jetzt ist die Frage,
ab wann ist denn die Schöpfungshöhe bei der eigenen Kommentierung erreicht,
reicht, sodass man sagt, ich muss das spielen, damit mein Publikum versteht,
was ich sagen will, aber erst das, was ich sage, führt zu Verständnis und ist
dann das Werk. Genau, solche Sachen.
Und selbst sowas, also wo es wirklich sehr viel auf, okay, dann nehmen wir mal
ganz viele Beispiele rein und gucken dann, ob das damit irgendwie ins Verhältnis
zu setzen ist und so weiter.
Also solche gefühlten Argumentationen.
Selbst dafür wird GPT oder andere AI-Sachen, es sind ja unglaublich viele Unternehmen
da gerade, uns einfach sehr gute, Ich möchte trotzdem nochmal ein Plädoyer dafür machen.
Ja, es gibt dieses Ja, Nein und 60 Euro zahlen oder nicht.
Aber es gibt auch ganz viel Uneindeutigkeit und ich bin eigentlich froh um diese
Uneindeutigkeit in der Welt und sage, dass erst wenn man miteinander gut auskommt
und wenn man einander versteht, dann werden auch Missverständnisse erzeugt.
Aus dem Weg geräumt, beziehungsweise dann erkennt man, auch wenn jemand gerade
ja gesagt hat, meint er vielleicht eine Minute später doch eher nein und man
ist nochmal vorsichtig.
Diese ganzen Sachen, die wichtig sind, wenn man einander begegnet,
aber auch wenn man eine größere Gesellschaft zusammengestaltet.
Und wo diese Uneindeutigkeit, man glaubt mit Gerichten nur vereindeutigen zu
können, da greift man zu kurz, da minimiert man eigentlich das Menschliche.
Beim Kartenpreis okay, aber wo es jetzt wirklich darum geht,
dass jemand Äußerungen trifft, feuilletonistische Äußerungen trifft,
da wird das schon sehr schwierig auf eine Eindeutigkeit, Uneindeutigkeit,
also eine Uneindeutigkeit auf eine Eindeutigkeit festzulegen.
Und da würde ich sagen, muss man eigentlich weg von einer solchen Gesellschaft,
die ständig in Klagelaune ist.
Also ich würde nicht auf die Idee kommen, jemanden zu verklagen,
wenn irgendwelche Äußerungen über mich getätigt werden, die mir nicht gefallen.
Es sei denn, es wäre jetzt im höchsten Maße gefährlich, was über mich gesagt
wurde oder grundfalsch so sehr, dass man sagen würde, gut, das geht jetzt wirklich
nicht, dass jetzt jemand sagt,
dass ich mit Olaf Scholz verheiratet bin oder so, da würde ich wahrscheinlich
dann gegen vorgehen. Aber mit der Realität.
Dann verweisen wir einfach nochmal auf die juristische Diskussion im Deutschlandfunk zum Thema.
Bundesverfassungsgericht entscheidet, nein, auch 2023 gilt, was schon vorher galt.
Man darf nicht für dieselbe Tat nochmal verurteilt werden, auch wenn man freigesprochen wurde.
Selbst wenn neue Beweise, selbst unhintergehbare Beweise vorliegen.
Und daraufhin der Deutschlandfunk den Experten fragt, wie ist das dem Laien zu erklären?
Und er sagt, gar nicht. Wir haben es hier also mit juristischen Sachverhalten
zu tun, die einfach auf Recht und nicht unbedingt auf Gerechtigkeit abzielen,
allein um Rechtsfrieden herzustellen, der…,
Die Allgemeinheit befriedet und die wenigen Verlierer vor Gericht so isoliert,
dass sie es mit sich selber klären müssen und nicht alle in den dann abermals
generalisierten Konflikt verwickeln.
Zu deinem Thema allerdings, du möchtest es unklar halten, du hast uns ja einen
Text vorgelesen zum Thema.
Vergangenen Salon aus der FAZ, warum das selbstfahrende Auto nicht kommen wird.
Genau, wir haben darauf sehr viele Zuschriften bekommen von Leuten,
die dem Professor seine Fachexpertise absprachen oder gleich Augenhöhe mit dem
Moment, denn es ist ja nicht alles Künstliche Intelligenz.
Ich glaube, man kann auch ein Auto automatisieren, ohne da überhaupt irgendwas
mit Künstlicher Intelligenz einzubauen.
Jedenfalls fand ich es witzig, auf TikTok oder Instagram, kam,
ich weiß nicht genau, dieses Video hier zu sehen.
Denn manchmal stellt einer Professorin Meinung einfach die faktische Realität gegenüber.
Und jetzt kann man natürlich sagen, er, das selbstfahrende Auto,
wird aber nie so und so fahren. Das kann dann gut sein.
Aber dass es fährt, steht ja dann außer Frage. Also hier ein sehr witziger Clip.
Man hat sich ein Uber bestellt in Amerika.
Hier ist sie.
Okay, okay. Okay, ich bin in einem Autofahrzeug. Es ist niemand hier.
Hallo, von Waymo. Es gibt eine urgentere Anzeige.
Fahrer-Support wird mit Ihnen verbinden und Hilfe bieten.
Also sie sitzt jetzt in diesem Auto, musste nur einmal klicken und jetzt fährt
das Ding los. Und ich muss sagen, es fährt ziemlich gut. Ich denke, es fährt besser als ich.
Bitte beachten Sie, dass es klar ist, bevor Sie aussteigen.
Also kann man einfach buchen in Amerika. Es kommt ein selbstfahrendes Auto.
Aber nur bestimmte Straßen, ne?
Nur bestimmte Straßen, aber ich will nochmal darauf hinweisen,
alles was wir hier sehen ist ausgedachte Wirklichkeit.
Der Straßenbelag künstlich, Straßenränder künstlich, Auto sowieso technisch
künstlich, alles das kann sich auch in 50 Jahren einfach komplett ändern und
dann ist eben alles nicht mehr
für menschliche Fahrten, sondern für automatisiertes Fahrten ausgelegt.
Ja, ich möchte nur nochmal sagen, dass es in diesem Artikel nicht um solche
koordinierten Strecken ging, sondern nochmal sehr viel weiter.
Aber wir haben das ja sehr ausführlich im Salon diskutiert. Also wen das interessiert,
kann es ja dann noch nachhören.
Und dann würde ich sagen, wir weisen noch darauf hin, was wir lesen im nächsten
Salon. Und zwar von Gaia Vins.
Das ist eine sehr…,
Renommierte Journalistin, die unter anderem für den Guardian und die BBC arbeitet.
Sie hat ein Buch geschrieben, das heißt Das nomadische Jahrhundert,
wie die Klimamigration unsere Welt verändern wird.
Und wir haben schon mal über Move von Perik Kenner gesprochen in einem Salon.
Wer das nochmal nachhören will, findet man auch.
Und hier geht es aber vor allem um die Klimaflucht. Und das ist ein Thema,
das wir also ausführlich diskutieren müssen. Was heißt das eigentlich?
Muss man den Nationalstaat dann neu denken, überwinden, was auch immer?
Da bin ich sehr gespannt drauf. Ich will noch nicht zu viel ankündigen,
weil ich noch verschiedene Optionen habe.
Ich will nur einen Text auf jeden Fall besprechen, gerade auch weil wir Kevin
Spacey erlebt haben und zwar der Weg in die Trump Diktatur von Robert Kagan.
Der Robert Kagan.
Uns, ist es gegen uns und so und teilt die ganze Welt und macht den Krieg gegen
den Terrorismus so richtig groß.
Gut möglich. Er warnt aber jetzt vor einer Trump-Diktatur.
Ist das nicht der Ehemann von der Nuland, die in der Ukraine vorher fürs Weiße Haus und so?
Wir sind hier mittendrin im amerikanischen...
Also wir sind wirklich hier mittendrin in allem, aber ich kann sagen,
es ist ein unglaublich erschreckender Text und vielleicht muss man aber doch
Thesen nochmal mal überprüfen.
Also ich bin sehr gespannt, das mit dir zu diskutieren.
Und ich kann auch sagen, ich habe da einen Artikel gefunden,
den habe ich aber noch nicht gelesen, der sich kritisch mit Taylor Swift auseinandersetzt.
Du hattest es im Live-Salon gesagt und ich kann es immer noch nicht fassen.
Sag es doch nochmal mit Spotify.
Ich gehöre zu den Top 1% der Taylor Swift-Hörer auf Spotify. Ich bin Oberswifty.
Und ich habe eine neue Theorie. Willst du hören? Ganz kurz, einen Satz nur.
Taylor Swift konnte sich den Raum, den sie jetzt gerade hat,
medial, in der Welt, nur erarbeiten, weil ihn die Queen vorher freigemacht hat durch ihren Tod.
Ich lasse diese These so stehen, frage dich noch, ob du schon Lektüren ausgewählt hast.
Habe ich noch nicht, aber ich fahre ja morgen auch nach Hamburg zum 37C3.
Er findet das erste Mal seit, dreimal ist er ausgefallen, vier Jahren wieder statt.
Und ich denke, es ist auch ein guter Start zurück in dieses,
wir nehmen mal ernst, was die Techniker uns sagen. Und da gibt es auch Kritiker und so weiter.
Wir müssen jetzt nicht nur, wir haben ja Sam Ortman jetzt schon sehr verurteilt
im Salon, für alle, die es nicht gehört haben.
Ich habe kein gutes Haar an ihm gelassen und ich bin sehr froh,
dass jetzt diese kritische Stimme endlich wieder, ich bin sehr gespannt,
was die nächsten vier Tage da abläuft und danach entscheide ich, was ich lese.
Sehr gut, dann sehen wir uns im neuen Jahr. Es war uns ein Vergnügen.
Wir freuen uns schon auf 24.
Ihr könnt uns dann im Salon besuchen. Anfang Januar zeichnen wir ihn auf.
Aber jetzt gibt es ja noch den Live-Salon zu hören.
Wie gesagt, alles erreichbar über Patreon, Steady und Apple.
Das ist die einzige Möglichkeit, den Podcast zu unterstützen.
Wir freuen uns sehr, wenn ihr das tut und wünschen nun einen guten Rutsch.
Guten Rutsch, Leute.